malcolm summers was an eyewitness to the
1963 assassination of president john f
kennedy he recorded this oral history in
2002 for the sixth floor museum in
dallas which is located in the old texas
school book depository evidence that
shots were fired from the depository
sixth floor was found soon after the
assassination
this program is about 35 minutes
thursday march 7 2002 gary mack curator
6 floor museum
talking today with malcolm summers also
here are
stephen fagan and our linda abbott of
our staff and we've just spoken with uh
al maddox
and now we come to you sir and your
story let's start um at the beginning
with a little biography when you were
born and where and something about your
upbringing they're like
i can do that i was born and raised in
dallas texas
and certainly always been partial i i
went to i was born in
1924
uh july the 28th
and i went to grammar schools here david
crockett was in my grammar school and i
was a graduate of crosstown tech high
school in dallas also
so i
am a native and i think maybe i'm one of
the few that's still around you know to
say it's old anyhow and uh yes i'm very
much in love with dallas and uh and i'm
very fond of it
matter of fact i think that's
assassination thing where hurt me the
most with the fact people didn't like
dallas
we'll get to that a little later um you
went to uh you went through high school
did you get to college or you go off in
the service or i did not go to college i
went to college i was an aviation cadet
in the in the service i volunteered for
air force and was an average cadet and i
did go to college up in oklahoma
and i was in the
service twice i was uh they stayed in
reserve and they called me back up for
the korean war
okay and you got out of the service
when i got out of the service the first
time in
october halloween day of the 31st
of 19 45
i was out of service until uh may the
i think it was maybe something they
activated this on may the 20th to go on
this coriander it was a national
emergency and i never did go overseas i
was
never shipped out of the united states
and i served another uh 18 months up in
south carolina with the second shift of
the
airport by then i was too old to uh
continue my flying
education and uh i just stand in there
because they found something else for me
to want to do
okay she got out of the service
eventually and i got out of the service
and that
uh that time would be uh
december
of 19 and
52
and i returned to dallas when i went to
end the service i was working for a
dallas time so i was a newspaper here
and i had been employed with them
approximately three to four years before
i went into service and then they kept
my job open when i was called up and
when i came back i went back to the
dallas time zone
and continued to work there for another
seven or eight years okay and what was
your job there i was in the mailing room
department there
and
just prepared newspapers for
distribution
okay and
but you you left them in what in the
early 60s
yes i left them i believe it was in late
59 and i went to california pursuing my
trade which was uh in the mailing
department and
i worked at several paper
several places in
california i worked
probably
eight to ten months in l.a area and then
i went down to the san francisco area
worked with several other newspapers
down there
and it was a good job and good money and
making good money and then
i moved my family out there and uh my
wife did not like california at all
and she said well if you wanna know if
you like this uh she said i'm gonna go
back to texas
and you can stay but i didn't want to
leave her for sure but uh the reason i
was wanting to stay out there was
because of money i was making good money
but ultimately you came back to dallas i
came back to dallas and then i started
my own company and my own company
is why i'm
probably at this event at that time okay
what was the name of your company my
name of my company summer's maitland
company okay and you're still in
business i'm in business and i'll be
going back to work today with this
interview now but i've been in business
41 years
yeah i've been it's been successful been
blessed in a lot of ways because of the
success okay were you active politically
uh well i yes i've always been active
political
uh
john f kennedy
uh i'm a republican but i voted for john
f kennedy because i liked he and jackie
i certainly did
can you expand on that
well i know that uh i i like the things
he stood for and i felt like he was a
real good man and i know a lot of people
here in dallas
uh believe that because he was a
catholic that he uh he would take orders
from the pope i never did believe that
and i voted for him anyhow and i'm not
sorry yet that i did and then
that
uh i'm still a republican but i didn't
vote for him
at that election is he the only democrat
you voted for it might be i i don't
remember any other that i particularly i
we've had some good democrats down here
in texas but i don't remember voting for
him
okay you voted for kennedy in 1960 and
then how did you find out that he was
coming to dallas well because i was a
kennedy fan
and so i
read in the paper constantly and
certainly i'm sure i heard it on the
radio and tv
and uh although i wasn't prepared to see
the parade when he came
uh i in my mailing business i
delivered mail to the postal annex over
here which is just right across the
street from the grassy knoll
and i was delivering mail that day and
all the uh noise and the people stand up
curbs there
and he was coming down they knew he's
coming they were getting ready for him
to come
so because i was already here
i wanted to run over and see him and
wave at him because i like feed clothes
up close
and that's exactly what i did and that's
exactly why i was over here on the
grassy knoll that particular day
over there at the post office i had to
try to get a couple of the postal
employees
to uh come run over here with me to
watch it and a couple of made a comment
says i wouldn't go see him with a a
buckshot a bookshot gun you know
and uh as is part of the store when i go
back over i'll tell you but i i ran on
over by myself because it was a short
cut across the grass grassy knoll
what put me down there so close to the
car and the assassination site okay
let's make sure we've got the the
terminology straight the grassy knoll is
the area up on the hill by the fence you
were down on the grass
by the street yes sir yes sir i'm sorry
i would refer to it but i cut across the
two
islands somewhat after separated between
maine commerce and
and help me okay so you got out there
what a few minutes ahead of time i got
out there probably at least five minutes
ahead before you come around
did you did you talk with any of the
people who were standing near where you
were
well no i didn't i was probably uh the
nearest people were probably 10 feet
from me they were closer up to uh
houston street i was feathered down
and uh they we wouldn't have no reason
to talk i suppose uh but you know you
just stand there i wanted to see him and
they would certainly get concentrated on
that also do you remember anything about
them
the people
i
don't remember any thing about the
people in general i read a lot about who
was there and what was there you know
but i know i didn't make any uh mental
note about them being there or
who was there or anything like that did
anyone ask you to not be there
no and no no no one asked me nothing no
that didn't come up not at all okay so
at some point then you must have heard
the the commotion at the end of the
street and that you realize that the the
parade was was getting pretty close yes
i knew it was
coming close i knew i was saying i got
closer to the curb where i could be
there was no uh nothing in between me
the curb and their car where they was
going to drive by yes and i want to be
as close as i could how close to the
curb you think you were i was within the
five feet
of the curb okay so what happened next
well the they they came around and then
uh
the first thing uh i heard was uh i
thought was a firecracker the first shot
and uh
i uh
that i have a hard time about that yet
today because the fbi secret service
people that was on the back of that car
they look down at the ground now i think
this is a power suggestion or something
but they look down at the ground i think
they thought it was a firecracker also
and i've always maintained this and it
did sound that and then i thought in my
mind what a heck of a joke in order to
be playing like that well then the car
kept coming and then the second shot
rang out and then the third was just
about where i was at
rung out and uh the first shot and the
second shot
was fairly close
and then the second and third
was likewise there wasn't much
difference in any of the timings there
and of course i stand beside the curve
there i saw kennedy get hit i heard uh
kindly say are they going to kill a song
or shoot us all i'm not sure which one
on that deal
and then
i
heard jackie kennedy i screamed out oh
god no no no
and there was a shrill it was very
sad to hear that after you think back it
was just
eerie
and i mean that's why she said oh god no
no
and then i was a motorcycle cop
right coming along on the side leading
the
caravan there in the car
and he uh laid down his bike right in
front of me and looked straight in my
direction
and and look like he's gonna pull his
gun well
but he's looking at me and i knew he
wasn't looking at me but i mean in my
direction i thought well somebody behind
me was doing the part
and because i thought that well i fell
down i hit the ground i kind of stayed
on my hand somewhat where i could still
see in the car
but not you know be standing up
and then uh
the
he jumped back on his bike and then he
took off along with with a car and
everything i i guess it was his job to
get to the hospital with him and he
certainly did
well i uh
stayed there just a few minutes a few
seconds i'll put it that way until the
all the commotion uh went by other cars
and a lot of screaming a lot of going on
and then
from that point i uh
lots of people was running around
running down towards the racetrack uh
railroad track
down there and i
again figured power suggestion i thought
well everybody they saw him and catching
him down there so i immediately ran
across the street too and i was going to
go down there and see him catch him
and i hope
i hang him whatever because i got mad
because i saw the blood and all that
and but when i ran across the street i
was stopped by a guy that how my ex told
you about it was similar we think that
when we put it together and he was
dressed he was about five ten six foot
uh well dressed and uh had a tie
and a coat over his arm
well uh he also had a hat on
so uh he
also he had a gun under his coat that
only the barrel showed through that you
could
you couldn't it wasn't uncovered it was
just because i was running straight
headed i could see the barrel that's all
the reason i guess i saw it
but i was not the only one running
across that street it was other people
you know done right in the left and he
said you better not come up here you
could get shot
and i immediately did not need i want to
argue with him because he looked like a
man of authority you know i thought he
was maybe a detective rfb i mean
and i had seen these stories where they
go around and protect them always
and i just assumed there was one
one of them because i wasn't going to
argue with them about coming over yes i
am or anything like that you know
so i immediately uh after he wouldn't
let me go on down there but then i
immediately turned around and went back
over to the post atlantic
and um
everyone in there
i told them about what happened
and then i say every one of three or
four of them they were laughing at me
because i was so white and so scared
and everything i grabbed the phone and
tell my wife to turn on tv and see what
happened
and uh because all these guys were
laughing so loud and when i was talking
to her she said well okay what's the
joke i said listen it is not a joke this
is for real turn on the tv
and so uh she did
so when i was leaving the post office
there and now this was over a period of
time i'm going to say
20 to 30 minutes after all of it left
well when i was leaving i
noticed it was three spanish-looking
guys jumping their car and they were
leaving from the front of the post
office where they were apart of the car
and they head toward oak cliff which was
houston street
i didn't think anything about it
at the time but for sure
and they put it out of my mind really
and then i went on i told my wife i said
look turn on tv i said i'm i'm coming
home i want to see all this and uh so i
immediately went home and where i lived
was uh four
five uh west 12th street
east 12th street and uh
the
by time i got there and this must have
been a time of
30 to 45 minutes maybe and that whole
area was full of squad cars
well i i did not know the reason why
they was all
full of squad car that area and i'm
talking about 15 or 20 it appeared to me
uh i thought they uh had a gunman
cornered out there somewhere well uh
the uh
tepid was shot in the 400 block
of east 10th street
and that was only two blocks from where
i i went i lived and went over there and
so it was still a bunch of
excitement and a lot of things going on
and then uh they they didn't find what i
saw because later on they found him at
the
school book i mean texas theater over
there so i ran back to my house and you
know it was just
horrible i began to feel bad i was
beginning to be almost sick because it
happened in dallas there again when i
set up the dollar sign
and
uh i watch tv i guess probably all night
long about and and listen everything i
could
so
did your work put you in contact with
people from outside of dallas or outside
of texas
well it does yes it did
yeah and what were you hearing from
those people
well uh only i guess if you anything
from out of town i don't recall hearing
anything particular other than uh i know
when adelaide stephenson was here just a
little bit before that that they uh some
dallas people or maybe someone
claiming to be dallas people
insulted him spit on him and hit him
with a sign and and then that's one of
the things other people in the newspaper
and everything
picked up about dallas was a hate town
well dallas was not a hay town and it's
still not but that's what they were
picking up on because of those incidents
and then kennedy getting shot
and i i certainly you know resented it
to a great degree
and i can't remember people anything uh
certainly over the
past few months that he was running for
an election uh we're talking about uh
him being a catholic and all that you
were just something that was always in
my opinion it was just not just keep
from voting for him
all right let's um
let's see we can clarify some things
about uh what you saw when the
assassination happened all right um can
you
can you explain better about the
shooting itself i mean you heard three
shots i heard three shots not four not
two three shots yeah you're pretty
certain of that i'm certain okay and how
are they spaced
i'd say the first one was uh like it
sounded like a firecracker well
uh and then if you guess the time i
don't know how to say how many seconds
but the
second one and third one was the closest
together of all and that was where i
when when kindly said they're going to
shoot us all or kill us all
well that's when i thought he it was
more than one person involved for sure
but when he caught he said they
and certainly it sounded like they were
that many shots
uh i think in your earlier description i
think you said um that the first two
shots were closer together well now i
misstated that really because it was the
second and third i'm i investigated that
a little bit nervous um
tell you what i don't know if you've
seen the film one of the other witnesses
was asked to do this can you kind of
knock on the on the table
that kind of thing to tell us how to
give an impression of how these shots
were spaced out
yeah
i'd say like that
and then
like that
i would say that was basically what
you know given to me and
did you have any idea where they were
coming from
no i had no idea because i didn't have
time to think about an idea only thing
it was because that cop came off his
back there suggested that the guy was
behind me now i had a lot of people ask
me said you've been there about five
minutes ahead of time uh could you
looked up and seen uh that sixth floor
wonder and i said yeah i certainly could
have and i said if i'd have seen uh
somebody up there with a shotgun i mean
a rifle i would have not thought second
about uh they wouldn't know if i would
have hollered or i notified somebody i
said absolutely not because i've read
where the
fbi guarded the president on every route
he takes and they on top of buildings
and places like that
were protected and i said that would
have been exactly what i thought even if
i had looked up and seen someone in that
sick four winter i would not said
anything not because of fear or anything
just because i thought it was supposed
to be
but your initial reaction then was you
really didn't know where the shots were
coming from no no i certainly didn't
when you ran across the street
um let's see
you've seen there's a pruder film of the
assassination i have seen it uh okay i
mean
you were almost directly in front of him
you were down a little farther but you
were almost directly in front of him
when you ran across the street did you
run straight or to the left or to the
right to the right okay yeah
and
how far did you go before you ran into
this guy
that you were talking well this uh
person he was standing probably about
five to ten feet from the street it goes
by in front of the school boat depositor
where everybody was running and the
sidewalk of the school boat support
store uh from the top of the knoll he
was standing probably three to five feet
away from that particular spot oh okay
let's see if we can pinpoint this a
little better
um i know you've been back to the plaza
many times and you know about where
zapruder stood yes how close to where
zapruder was did this man
did you meet this man
uh i would say uh
just guessing distance i'd say uh 50
foot
50 feet 40 to 50 feet 40 to 50 feet to
the right as you look at it it would
have been to his left the pruders
surprised
okay
um and you saw the barrel of a gun
sticking out from under that coat i mean
just because the coat covered it up it
wasn't sticking out to retract that it
was just under there because if you i i
never had really tried it but if you
hold your coat over your arm and you got
a gun in it well then it doesn't droop
over the gun or anything it wasn't it
was just
even a flush with a gun
and
this was a white guy yes yes okay and
very well the groom guy glasses no he
didn't have any glasses no mush days
okay
um
and he told you what
he said y'all better not come up here
you can get shot
or kill one statement like that and
which one because you're so excited and
then you revved up there
you wasn't listening nothing except
don't come up here and you know and you
just put that with that man uh
was a authority to say don't come up
here well i didn't think anything about
anyone else would you know say you can't
come up here like you for instance you
know i would have ignored you or someone
like that
and that's why i paid attention to this
person
did you see him talking to anyone else
i did not see him talking to anyone else
because by then i did want to turn
around and go on back over there and
call my wife real quick and get her on
the phone
see the events as they were happening
and that was my
reason why i
didn't linger around to go longer or
just wait and see what happened because
of my i want to get back over real quick
um this guy have a hat on yes he had a
head on what kind of hat
uh that's all i guess one of them just
regular brim hats
not a wide brown hat just a regular
dress hat that i'd call it
uh certainly one a texas hat or anything
of that sort but it was just a dress hat
that people wore
um
and he was a well-groomed person i mean
when you just wouldn't he's not the
normal person that would have went to
see
uh prayed unless they had to step out of
their building
or something like that you know that
they were in their office they would
step out here and get closer view
so he gave you the impression that he
was an authority of some type yesterday
that's exactly
what he says you don't come up here well
you tell me you know the same way or
anywhere they'll don't come in here
don't come there and how long after the
shooting did this happen
i'd say uh
three minutes however long it took them
for the rest of the procession to clear
out you know where i didn't want to run
across the street where they were still
trying to get out of here and get to the
hospital now i don't remember how many
cars were behind it
or how many more motorcycles
but i do know that it was a few minutes
before they all cleared out
and i do know that uh the car itself
that kennedy was in it hesitated and
stopped there for a second or two
and i saw the uh secret service man
right up there
and he slipped on the back bumper at the
time i did not know he was slipping on
that back bumper because i thought he
was just trying to dive in the car but
he wasn't trying to dive and that's
where they saw jackie kennedy reach for
him
and i've heard some people say she was
try to get out that's not so at all
so after this guy told you to uh not
come up there you just turned around and
didn't i mean you crossed the street
again i guess i went back crosstalk
back to where you were yeah i went back
across the street and then another
street on the third street over there to
get back to the post-atlantic okay
um was there anything about the gun that
you remember like the color of the
barrel
no i could not see a barrel except i
described it to the sheriff's department
over here later when i went over there
to give his statement and they asked me
what did the muzzle look like well i
didn't i don't know that much about guns
period i was shot at the rifle 22 or
something like that but i when i
described the barrel it said it would
sound like an automatic and that's what
i presume it was because i didn't see
side or back of it or anything just a
barrel
um okay you know your car
from one of the
from one of the other accounts of your
actions
my understanding is that your car was on
commerce street but it was the commerce
street extension right next to the
terminal annex building well what the
little side street
well okay my car um it is a little side
street the head and go drives off of uh
houston street to go behind the postal
post office portland they have a dock
back here where you back up and unload
your mail now that was where it was it
was parked right behind
that uh post office on the on that
little street yet to go down there to
get to okay
okay once you got off the phone uh with
your wife and explained to her what had
happened and convincing your co-workers
that kennedy really had been shot you
then
wanted to head back to oak cliff
absolutely so you drove along that
little side road and made a right onto
houston street that's exactly right and
that's when these three especially right
they were right at the curb where i was
making my ride at that's where they were
parked okay right at the
probably the first car
and did they go around your left side or
your right side no they i hadn't got out
there yet they pulled out ahead of me
before i made my turn oh i see okay yes
and there was something about the way
they did that that
well they were in a hurry yes and uh and
they left at a great speed uh past speed
uh
i only i didn't think anything about it
i didn't necessarily think anything
about it
uh and when they headed in the same
direction i was going and that didn't
mean anything either except later on
when all these other things surfaced
about where ruby uh
lived and where
oswald lived and that was in that
direction okay
um speaking of where
ruby lived in that area in oak cliff
did you hear any
did you hear any stories in the weeks
and months following the assassination
that made you wonder about some of the
events that day
well i certainly heard a bunch of
stories and then of course uh a lot of
people were speculating about uh uh
oswald was at home
and he was walking in the direction
where he did wound up over at 10th
street that is uh
kind of south of where he lived
southeast i guess
and uh certainly i associated that with
with
why he was walking over there and still
this question i think why he was walking
over there and then ruby lived in that
direction also and i
associated those things with them
because they said well he was headed
this way toward rupert's house well it
made sense it could have been
well
um of your friends and neighbors in that
part of town did you
did any of them know any of the people
involved in this story anywhere
no not in any anyway did any of them
know
not at all i uh on a duplex over there
and that was just where i live
okay
you
you gave a statement to the sheriff's
department yes i did okay was that the
only time you were interviewed by any of
the official investigators no the secret
service came out to my
shop and interviewed me on two different
occasions okay have you seen those
reports
[Music]
i did see the reporter i was told what
they how they were uh
the first uh it was about three of them
came the first time he interviewed me
and i heard they heard everything i just
now told you about the fellow stopped me
and all of that
and i told them about the three fellows
that left the curve there in such a
hurry
and then uh
they said well
okay i told him he looked like a fbi guy
secret service or a local city detective
you know that's when they dressed like
that
and uh i said that's who i assumed that
was
and then they said okay we'll take a
report and we'll get back with you well
i'd say
two months later
i was wondering why they didn't call me
sooner or whatever but about two months
later they told me that they did not
have
uh
fbi man secret service or a city
detective was in that vicinity where
this guy stopped me so therefore they
basically told me i didn't see anything
because they said they didn't have
anybody there
and i and my statement well
that's what you say well that's fine i
don't need to argue about it i have no
point to prove
did you ever have the feeling that they
tried to get you to change your story or
to not talk about what you'd seen
i
i don't really guess i that they then i
really don't know i i know i was
disappointed when they said they didn't
have anybody there
and i knew i saw someone there uh i
guess i was certainly uh
um
well number five dumb or whatever
because they said he didn't have anybody
there
uh
it just didn't make sense
at that time okay
um in recent years they're they're
trying to uh
uh
pull you into this story through this
james files fella you're familiar with
this james files i am you have any
thoughts about that
um well i i know uh i had someone come
out from one of the radio station and it
this one could have been houston
a tv station or it could have been
houston it could have been florida it
could have been one of them they set up
a time they come out there and then they
interview me and and have me on camera
and everything and they showed me the
pictures uh
i remember that story talked to you one
time before about that one but uh they
told me well after a little bit of
conversation with on camera and
everything they showed me his picture
said this guy
said he's he's the uh assassin
and uh and then they said does he look
like the guy you saw up there there's no
way no way that guy looked like the guy
i saw up there and they said well he
said he did it
i said well then they also told me he
was serving last term for shooting or
killing a policeman somewhere up in
illinois i think
and i said no way and then this one guy
was persistently
uh saying well if he had on i said he
too sharp number one said if he had on
the high built up shoes
could he have been the guy and
i said well he might have made him
taller and then they said well if he had
on a shirt and tie like a hat could he
look like that guy i said well
i guess anything is conceivable
you know that he could have possibly
addressed in that manner
but uh i got quoted later on that i said
i identified him as a possibility they
changed that conceivable
not my meaning at all about james
thought but i do not believe he could
have been connected in any way your real
meaning then was that this guy in the
picture was not the guy that you would
run into
the fob was not the guy i run into
certainly yes
we've covered
all the things that you have talked
about before and one of the things in in
doing the research
to prepare for the interview i mean i've
gone back and looked at your at your
stories i mean you've told the same
story over and over and over again
except for a couple of things that i
just asked you about so yeah it's
refreshing to hear that
is there anything else about
what you saw and heard in dealey plaza
that would be of importance to
researchers and historians
well except
possibly one thing and i believe i also
mentioned to you i had a lady come up
from houston she was a sketch artist and
she worked for the houston police
and she done sketches uh of people and
she said she had high success with the
police houston police department of
catching rapists and other people and
she wanted to sketch this person that i
saw out and i said well i don't see how
i can remember that far back now it's
you know it's about 25 30 years after
that she said well you'll be surprised
what you can remember if you let me come
and interview you well i set it up for
one saturday when we went busy one
saturday afternoon she bought her uh
book and all her pictures it and i never
been through this that uh the pictures
had pictures of a guy's chin picture
their forehead a picture of their ears
and their noses and she'd think well
what which nose looks like him and she'd
do it in that way and compile it i'm
sure y'all familiar with that
but she came up with a picture
that was remarkably
what i described
the man that stopped me
and then wanted how many described to
you
and uh also she gave me and
she
i see she had some other some pictures
of some known gangsters
uh that was uh running the dallas paper
that was here as they was here that day
or something you know this and she uh
marked the resemblance of the one i
described and what was in the paper and
i still have that
and i think i mentioned it i think i
even showed it to you didn't i
um i've seen the picture i don't think i
don't think you showed it to me um but
i've seen the picture and i know it's
well and i do believe it's a very good
resemblance to that person and this was
done in what
1997 or 98 96 oh no no it's it was done
probably 1990
two or three way back there yeah a long
time ago it's 10 years ago at least 10.
okay and uh and it was accurate as far
as i'm concerned of my description i
gave to her
okay
um anything else you would like to add
well
no i'm just happy to you know come here
and and put my uh
input there because i know that i was uh
first 25 years i would not talk to
anybody and that's one of the things
about jim martha i didn't want to take
the time and my fear of
not taking the time and
uh from the first day was i thought yeah
fbi whoever wanted you to testify they
could take you and they could keep you
in court for a week or two weeks or a
month if they needed to
and i could vision my business
suffering from that and that's why the
reason i wasn't interested in talking
again all this but then after 25 years i
have to convince me that dad said you're
not too busy that you can't talk and i
agree i was wrong
and that you can't give a little of your
time to this and that's one reason i'm
here today uh mr west
uh
is because that's they were exactly
right
and this
wesley frazier worked with lee harvey
oswald at the texas school book
depository in dallas at the time of
president kennedy's assassination
in this oral history recorded for the
sixth floor museum at dealey plaza
frazier recounts working with oswald and
oswald's activities on the morning of
november 22nd 1963.
this program is the first of two parts
the second half will air sunday august
16th check c-span.org for the c-span
three history schedule
this is one hour
for me at texas school but the twizz
story i talked with
mr roy s truly
and uh he turned me over to his um
assistant which was uh
bill shelley
okay and
do you remember approximately when you
started work at the depository
i started there in the uh
my memory search it was in the summer of
1963.
can i jog your memory a little bit might
have been in september
could have been uh i'm not for sure
are you aware what day i actually saw
you there i remember september when i
because i read your warren commission
testimony this morning and i think you
mentioned september and i want to say it
was around the 13th or the 15th of
september
uh what's important though is you were
living with your with your sister and
her family and this was probably what a
temporary arrangement or what
uh yes it was the temporary arrangement
i was going to live there with them
until i found employment and i could
move out on my own okay
um
and working in the depository what was
your job title and what kind of work did
you do there
okay
being employed by the texas school book
depository i was employed
as an order filler
and what i did there i
filled orders from different publishers
and by the way uh if you're not familiar
with texas school but depository
we had several different stories that we
stored our textbooks on
uh different publishers
say for instance like
greg
was located on the fifth floor
and
then scott's foreman was located on the
sixth floor
and i could go
from any floor from the basement up to
the
top
and pull out
the orders as needed
now the
depository book building at that time
there was some force that was uh
strictly uh
for administration and uh a clerical
type work
and that started like on the second
floor
uh
second and third and fourth four i
believe had offices on it at that time
so when you and your co-workers got your
orders for the day you knew basically by
the name of the publisher which floor to
find those books on yes that is correct
at some point after you got hired you
must have apparently became aware that
there might still be some openings
and you must have mentioned that to your
sister
well
because she supposedly mentioned it to
ruth payne a friend of hers
is that how you remember it
well uh the way i remember was that uh
i was working
uh quite a bit overtime earlier every
day we was working overtime there would
be some days that
miss shelley would give us a break
but
my sister noticed that i was working a
lot overtime and by the way my sister's
name was
miscellany randall she asked me she says
are they doing any hiring and i said
well i don't know i'll have to ask
uh mr shelley and see what he says and
so i asked mr shelly i said are we doing
any hiring
and he says yes he said we're taking
applications
uh
so my sister
used to meet with ruth payne and some of
the women in the uh right there in the
immediate neighborhood and they would
get together sometimes in the morning
and they would have coffee
some type of
coffee cake or whatever
they had and they would sit around and
visit and drink coffee or tea and um
and that's where my sister told miss
payne
that yes they were taking applications
and she and return miss payne
told uh there was a lady living with her
at that time named marina and her
husband was um
uh lee oswald
is marina oswald and so she told marina
oswald and she in turn told uh lee that
he might go by then fill out an
application
if he was still looking for work
so
do you think that your sister asked you
about employment as a result of talking
to marina or is it something that she
just knew
from talking with you and then she
told marina
well there's a way i i recalled uh my
sister
uh
asked me were they still doing any
hiring and in these meetings there are
gatherings that sometimes the women
would do in that neighborhood i guess
something must have came up about
uh
marina's husband looking for work
and that's where my sister asked me and
then i checked with mr shelley and and
he said yes they were and
and the information got back to uh
marina and lee through miss payne
and uh
lee came by and filled our application
so
when was the first time then that you
actually heard of lee harvey oswalt not
not that you had seen him but had heard
of him
uh right before he um
he started to work there uh my sister
told me that uh
marina's husband
i was looking for work
but at that time i couldn't tell you
what his name was because i never had
met the man
so when did when did his name when did
you first learn his name uh and and that
he was in fact going to be working at
the depository or did you
well the first uh day i met uh lee awful
was the day that he started to work at
texas school depository
so before that
time you had not even heard his name no
i i did not know his name or i never had
the opportunity to meet him
so how'd the meeting take place and what
did you think
well the
my first meeting with lee osborne was
that
that he had reported to the texas school
depository for work
and mr truly uh
summoned mr
shelley and told him introduced him to
lee
and told him he was there and put him to
work
and
after uh talking with him a short time
mr shelley um
asked that i come to his office and i i
did so and when i
uh reported to his office he introduced
me to lee oswal
and at that time he told me that
he would like for me to teach him how to
fill orders
and i did that
what was your first impression of him
my first impression of uh
lee he was
uh he
he
appeared to and i later found out that
he was he was a very quiet type person
he he wasn't someone that
talked excessively
uh
and most of our conversation matter of
fact all of our conversations quiet
while working was strictly business
uh he'd asked me a question
uh how did i know the difference between
or what
what actual textbook was they were they
referring to
and i would show him the difference
between one text and another and i said
when you see this this is the
this is a copy that they're asking for
right here
and uh
he learned he learned very quickly
uh seemed to be quite intelligent
and now
it was a pleasure working with him
because uh
he he never uh he never just asked you a
question and asked you a question it was
always
he was trying to find or understand
after reading the invoice that he had in
his hand if he would have any question
he'd just come find me
did he talk about other things or any
other things sports or politics or
anything with you um we never talk
politics
the two things that i could get a
response out of lee and this especially
when
uh we were
riding back and forth to irving it was
two things that i could get a comment
out of him
was
uh one about his his child
at that time he had a small daughter
and his wife marina was uh pregnant with
their second child
he wasn't a big talker
you would get a
chuckle out of him when you asked
something about the children
i guess he would think of something that
happened
and and he would say a sentence or two
and then the other thing was um
a lot of time we talked about the
weather or something
if you look like it was gonna rain or
something i'd say it looks like it's
we might get some rain today and you get
a few uh words out even there he
um
he wasn't one to initiate a conversation
but he would answer you
and talking about children now all the
children in the neighborhood at that
time
that lived around there in that area
they they all knew lee because lee
played with the children a lot of times
in the evening late in the evening
in miss uh
payne's front yard
i know my little nieces
knew him they knew who he was on site
when they saw me he was the man that
lived at miss paine's
and
he played with several children in the
neighborhood along with his own child
did you
meet marina or the kids or mrs payne at
any time before the assassination
uh no
so
in writing back and forth which we'll
we'll get to in a minute
um it was always oswald coming over to
your place
uh most time yes that's the way he is
sometime i would uh
when we would be coming from dallas i
would drop him in front of his his house
but you never stayed no i never i never
went in we never uh visited i never went
in we visited or sat down and have a
a soda or a cup of coffee and never did
that or we never went together anywhere
after work
uh sometimes i would let him out in
front of his house because maybe i was i
had some errands to run maybe i was
supposed to go by this
the store and pick up milk or bread or
whatever my sister had asked me to bring
that afternoon
how did the
writing back and forth come about
the way that uh came about was that
after learning that um
that his wife lived with marina out in
irving
and i asked him i said well
how do you get back and forth and he
said well he says i usually go out and
see my wife on the weekend
and
i said well you get out there he says
well he says you know bus ride the bus
or taxi however i can get out there
and i told him i said well you know i go
back and forth every day anytime you
want to go over and see your wife i said
all you have to do is tell me during the
day and i said
you can uh you can ride out to irving
with me and then uh if you spend the
night then you can ride back with me the
next morning
and actually what
uh eventually occurred on that was that
he would run out to irving with me on
friday afternoon
i would drop him off
and then i would not see him again until
um a monday morning
and i know sometimes people might ask
well
did you ever go anywhere together did
you ever go to the movies or
ball games or did you ever do anything
together
we never did
um
did he ever offer to
buy your gas now and then
uh
no because i never asked him
because
he he lived like less than a half a
block his wife lived with this pain less
than half a block where i live
and i was going there so
i i just always um
said to myself well it takes that much
gas for me to go to work why charge him
now some people would but i'm not the
type of person if i'm going somewhere
myself
why charge someone
and he never volunteered though either
did he
i think he may have i i
asked a couple of times and i told him
it wasn't necessary
i think at first he he did since you
asked me the question i think he did and
i told him i said well that's not
necessary
your regular routine uh
started at eight o'clock uh and when
would you guys normally break for lunch
noon or so or i think it i think it was
um
12 12 30 okay where did you have your
lunch normally
i usually had my lunch there to take the
school book depository because i usually
carry my lunch
a few times
i did go down to a little
diner
that you could just go in and order and
sit down as little
which was now part of the west end it
was between the uh
school book depository and uh the state
building
there was a little diner there you could
get sandwiches and so forth and a few
times i walked down there by myself
and eat lunch there but most of the time
i brought my lunch and i would uh
uh some of the guys would eat their
lunch out on the dock somebody to lunch
in the um
break room
uh playing dominoes or cards
there there's usually something going on
all the time because some uh
some of the guys uh like to play
dominoes and different card games
the break room was also known as the
domino room and that was on the first
floor yes
what part of the building north south
east west
okay uh
the uh break room was located over in
the corner
of the
uh
it was the first floor like well if
you'd walk up from outside walk on the
dock and walk into the first floor
it was um in the corner and it was to
the
left
of mr shelley's office
it was between mr shelley's office and
uh
the uh men's uh restroom okay so that
would put it right by the the northeast
corner of the building
yes
okay
okay i understand and and that's where
most of you and your co-workers would
eat your lunch would you guys go up to
the second floor lunch room at all
um
i did go up and eat my lunch up there a
couple of times
but but the launch room was small
and uh we didn't have a lot of tables
and chairs and there a lot of times the
uh
women that worked in the different uh
publisher's office
was then there
and uh
i didn't feel it was right to take a
seat from someone that
wanted to get away from their desk
and we had a lot of places to sit down
to eat downstairs
sometime i i used to eat up there on the
first floor sometimes i eat down in the
basement because that's where i kept my
lunch
it was nice and cool down there and
sometimes it's quite if i if i just want
to have some quiet time
just eat my lunch and and not talk
anymore lunch and just
for a few minutes just have
as i said not to be reptiles just quiet
time
to yourself
and sometimes i would uh i'd take a book
and i'd be looking at a book while i was
eating something i wanted a reading
there
um
i often look through the books we had a
lot of publishers
for
anything from kindergarten to
college
unfortunately there are very few
photographs of the interior of the book
depository building and and of those
hardly any other color
do you remember anything about the
colors in the lunchroom
no i i don't i
like said i only was up there a couple
of times i knew they had
uh
like a coke machine and i think they had
a snack machine in there and
i'm not real
um
i can't
think of much anything else in there
that i that i can recall at this time
but he just had a few chairs in there
and tables but but it was very uh very
small
i'm going to ask you a question that's
really obscure but you know if you don't
know that's fine
the the soft drink machine was actually
a dr pepper machine
now my question is
what did they just have dr pepper or did
it also have cokes or pepsi or other
flavors in there
the best of my memory uh there was there
was a variety of drinks in there
okay
it's an obscure question but it comes up
now and then so i thought i'd ask okay
um
i understand that there was a caterer
who would come by in the mornings with
lunch do you mean i'm glad you brought
that up because i was just freaking to
tell you i've forgotten something
yes
there was a uh there was a catering
truck that used to come by
on the
morning break time
and some of the
people that worked in the building not
only people in the warehouse but
sometimes people from upstairs would
come down and they would buy their lunch
off of the catering drop
plus whatever they wanted if they wanted
something for the break time okay do you
remember the name of the catering
service or who is the guy when it was a
white guy a black guy a woman
i think over the period of time i worked
there i think and i could be wrong about
this but i think there were several
different people that worked for that
one
uh catering a service and if our memory
serves me correctly i think it was
uh industrial catering service
now you can check that out but i think
and i think they may still be in
business today
okay but i i'm not real sure of the name
but it's something
seemed like it was industrial
that's pretty good going back almost 39
years for something pretty pretty
insignificant i appreciate your
your memory on that okay um
you drove lee harvey oswald to and from
irving
uh on a few occasions before the
assassination and that was always on a
friday yes and then he'd come back with
you on monday mornings yes that is
correct did he ever bring his lunch with
him
on those monday mornings
he may have and then he may not have uh
oh
i'm not sure
about during the week but maybe a couple
of times he might have brought his lunch
but i'm not real sure
had you ever
did you ever eat lunch with him
no
no as far as he and i sit down say like
at some
place out on the uh
the first floor there
and sit down eating lunch together just
he and i along no
uh
i did eat lunch a couple of times
in the break room
with the guys playing cards and dominoes
and it was too noisy
for me that's why i often like to just
sit out on the dock or go down in the
basement and eat my lunch and for the
quiet time
of the
of the crew that you were working with
did oswald hang out with with any with
you or any of the other guys more than
anyone else
no he really did uh lee um
we tried to fit in and he tried to mix
in with with the personnel that worked
there
and the warehouse
but no he didn't hang with any one
individual or group more than others
he um
even though he tried very hard to fit in
uh
he didn't fit in very well with with
some of the other uh workers why why do
you think that is
well
uh because sometimes he would uh make a
statement referring to something or and
some of the people will laugh
and uh he asked me about that one time
he said while they laugh at what i say
and i said well
i said possibly because they don't
understand what you're saying i said
they talk
and describe things different than you
and i said you're talking a little bit
higher level and i said it's it's very
easy to make fun of someone when you
don't really understand what they're
saying
i said you take the uh
you take the spotlight off themselves
and they put it on you
and he made the remark one time he said
well you never do that with me and i
said no i don't because i said um i was
taught there and that i said you don't
make fun of someone
i said if they say something you don't
understand i said you don't make them
appear to
be something wrong with them
in any or
way they said something
and one day he had he and i was talking
and he said something and then a few
minutes later he called me over and i
had a dictionary and i was reading this
dictionary and he says
he said he said what are you doing i
said well i'm looking up this word i
said use this word in a sentence and i
wasn't quite sure
of the meaning the definition and i said
i was trying to
fit it in where i could understand it
better and that's when he made the
remark that i just said he said you
never make fun of any comment i make
so
so i can understand
oswald
sometimes would
to use the phrase he would talk over the
heads of some of the
some of you some of the guys he was
working with and they in turn would then
make fun of him
and he didn't quite understand until you
explained the facts of life to him about
this that's correct
so this wasn't a black and white thing
or a rich and poor thing no
and now do you remember what it was that
he was talking about
but sometimes not anything in particular
sometimes it'd be just like
you would see something and i would see
something and he would see something or
he'd read something in the paper
or had uh seen something on television
and he would be describing in his
own words to the best of his ability
uh
what he had seen
and then that would happen
but uh
i think he tried very hard
to um
[Music]
mix in with the people and
but as you said
that he uh
didn't realize it but often he talked
over their head because he he had
whether it was
through
going to school or self-taught
his education was at a much higher level
um
were you aware that he was a high school
dropout
no
not at that time
now
i have learned a lot of things and i've
read a lot of things and
and i've been told all things about lee
oswal
since november the 22nd 1963
but
to answer your question no he never gave
me the impression he was a high school
dropout
he was um
aware of current events and he was
he was aware of things going on in the
world apparently yes
he was very knowledgeable
when did you
first learn that president kennedy was
coming to town
and then the follow-up course would be
when did you first realize that he was
going to come right by your building
well i think it was a day or two before
uh just hearing people talk they said
that
[Music]
president kennedy was going to come to
dallas
but that didn't
anything didn't restaurant me about that
because uh
presidents they visit cities
in america and cities um
in other countries
that's that's that's a common pretty
common thing for them for one reason
other they go there for business
uh
where it's political or whether
campaigning or um
or they're trying to uh be a negotiator
um
as a uh
and a peace type situation
or whatever
a president of the united states
traveling uh uh two different points
in the world is it's very common so
uh him coming to dallas now that that
didn't
uh
mean anything particularly to me
how how about some of your co-workers
was it well
the morning friday november the 22nd
it was
i think around break time
they found out uh that um
that the presidential parade was going
to be coming by
the texas school book depository houston
and elm street
and a lot of people were very excited
about that they said
god says we got a chance to see
president
and as they were talking then they
realized
that
he may come by
before
lunch break or after lunch break and
and
there's a possibility we wouldn't get a
chance to see the parade
so someone
uh had gone to mr shelley and asked
are we going to get to
see the presidential parade
and
there was uh yeah i guess he checked
with mr uh truly and mr truly checked
with his um
uh bosses who were up in on the second
floor
and and they
uh come back with a reply yes we would
stop and everyone could see the
presidential
parade
and um
so we continued to work
and then at a certain time we stopped
and everyone got ready to watch it to
pray
the day before
thursday the 21st lee harvey oswald came
to you and asked you what
he asked me
i was
i was over in the area where we would
bring the freight shipments down that
would be carried out by the different
freight lines and i was filling an order
and putting it together and he asked me
he says
he said i ride home with you this
afternoon
and not thinking about what day it was i
said sure
and then a few minutes later
i don't know where it was due to i
looked at the date on the invoice i was
filling
and i said hey it's not crazy so when i
saw him i said
hey i said today's not friday today's
thursday
he said i know that he said but he said
i need to go out to irving and
he said that marina had made him
some curtains
for his apartment
he stayed over
an apartment in dallas
during the week and would go home with
me like on friday
so he was going out to pick up
the curtain rods
where he could uh hang the curtains in
his apartment
marina had made some curtains for him
were the curtains ready or was he just
going to pick up the curtain rods or
well from what where he's find it they
were ready and he was going to get the
curtain rods
to hang the curtains
so you thought okay
i think from your warrant commission
testimony you indicated that you guys
would get off work like 4 45 or so
that could be correct yeah
okay so you guys did you walk together
out to your car
uh when we black on friday afternoon no
on thursday afternoon the day before
so i want you to talk about taking
oswald back to irving
okay uh i'm sure we did because uh
that's all the way he's gonna get in the
car with me to go home because it was
like i say several hundred yards
north of our building and i would go
down from the uh
parking lot there i would go around and
go down that continental
uh
street to
through what he's now known as 35
okay simmons
um this will be a little thing also but
just just see if i can tweak your memory
a little bit do you remember what he was
wearing was he in shirt sleeves or did
he have a jacket on when he went to the
car
what he was actually wearing no i don't
remember but it was in november so the
chances are
we were wearing uh
jackets or a long-sleeve shirts then
could do whatever someone wanted to wear
how
did he have anything
with him was he carrying anything or
were his hands
empty or oh i understand what you're
saying you you won't know if he carried
anything from the texas school book
depository with him that day on thursday
home with him
and the answer is no
how certain are you
pretty certain
didn't have a box or a package or
anything
not that i know of
i know he didn't have a box or a package
um what'd you guys talk about on the on
the way home that that afternoon
you and lee
i really don't remember everybody but if
we talked about anything on the commute
out to urban it would have to be in
something of reference probably to his
children
so there wasn't any talk about kennedy
coming by tomorrow oh no
now i know
that next day friday november the 22nd
the parade route was published in i i
think all the uh uh
papers the dallas morning news and um
at that time
there was a dallas times herald which is
uh which is uh no longer today
but
they were both published in the papers i
believe
okay so
you and oswald head back to irving
from the depository on thursday
you dropped him off at ruth payne's
house
and that's the last time you saw him
until the next morning teddy's correct
so he then came over to your house or
did you drive over to payne's house to
pick him up how did how did that we been
on a friday morning on friday morning
well the friday morning uh
lee
came down to
where i lived with my uh sister
and she lived
on memphis uh
maybe fifth street yeah straight cross
street was
i think the number was 2439
i think i could be wrong about the
number but i know it was on 5th street
and they lived on my sister lived on a
corner
i'd have to go over there
in that area to be specific about the
house number and what the cross street
was but i do know where the house is is
it still there have you been by there
i haven't been by there in several years
but the last time
i was by there
um
the house was still there
and i got to go into the house
i explained the lady uh who i was i told
her at one time a long long time ago i
used to live there
and so she let me come in and look
around the house and when i got in when
you walk in off of the carport into
like the um
the living area and the kitchen
combination there
i explained to her i said well this
wasn't here this used to be air and i
walked around and explained things
before i even got down the hallway i
told her where the bathroom was and
where the bedrooms was and
and she said you remember this house
very well
and uh
and i uh thanked her for letting me come
in look around i said i know you didn't
have to do that
but i said i appreciate that i said i
spent a lot of time at this house at one
time when i was a very young boy and i
said
it means a lot to me this house
but far as uh on friday november the
22nd 1963
lee
came down to the house
and
the first
time i noticed that he was already down
to the house
was that
he was looking in one of the windows
into the
kitchen area
and my sister said who's that
and i said
oh that's lee
and uh
so
he came around to the door like coming
to the house and i said well i'm just
finishing up my breakfast i said i'm
uh and my sister was finishing my lunch
i said
i'll be out just a few minutes i'm gonna
go brush my teeth
and i'll be on out
and i did when i got out to the car uh
he was standing by the car and we got in
the car
and as i got in the car i got glassed
over my shoulder and there was a package
laying on the back seat
and i said what's that and he said oh he
said that's the curtain rods i told you
about i said oh okay
um
at that time of the morning which i
guess would be like 7 15 7 30.
um because because i know in your
testimony you made it clear that you
uh had to be at work by
eight yeah
was it raining
that morning well is my memory going
back
uh
it was kind of an over class
uh overcast day
and it was a little missed a little fine
uh real pinpoint type miss in the air
um
so you get in the car and oswald gets in
the front seat with you yes
and off you go taking the same route
that you normally did
a story road down to
what is now called airport freeway and
then into stemmons and then to
continental and into the parking lot
what was that ride like and what what
kind of things did oswald talk about if
anything
well uh
that morning on the way to work he was
like no other
i mean he was just the same as he was
any other time that he wrote in with me
on uh
monday morning
but today but this particular day it was
friday
he's quite
just watching the traffic and
[Music]
and i mentioned
i said well i said
just kind of overcast and missed you
today
but later on
the um
the mist stop and the um
and the uh
sun broke through the clouds and came
out it was a real pretty sunshiny day
that happened though after you'd already
gotten to the trees
yes on the way in um
uh
let me back up a little bit on these
rides back and forth did you have a
radio in your car
we did did you listen to the radio
uh yes
the the reason i asked was there was
there talk about president kennedy
coming to texas on the radio that
morning
then i don't remember because most of
the time it was mainly music
that well i listened to i didn't like
too much i wasn't too much into
listening to the news like i am today i
listen to news a lot more than uh
i do music but at certain times of the
day i'm if i'm riding along i i know
where the dials to go to hear the most
updated news and i'll do that
well
what i'm getting at is i'm trying to
find out
uh
if there was anything about oswald's
demeanor
that was different
in any way from any of the other times
you guys have gone back and forth
uh no i've been asked that and
and i can't i can't put my finger on any
one thing
because he was just he he was very quiet
and
he very seldom never initiated a
statement
usually
he would answer me something i had asked
him
but um
no
there was no mention of the president
coming to dallas that day or anything
so as best you can remember and i know
you've thought about this many times
over the years
as as best you can recall this was a day
like any other day as far as lee harvey
oswald was concerned at least
as best you can tell yes
it was a
it was just like any other day
you normally you get to go to work i
knew it was friday
and unless we was working overtime and
sometimes we did work on saturdays and
heavy shipping season but most time you
knew that you
when you got off that afternoon you
would be off until monday morning
and just no different today as it was
back in 1963 a lot of people look uh
forward to fridays
uh
but
whether anything was different about the
way he acted or anything no i i can't
remember that at all
because uh except to answer that he was
just he appeared to be himself
but the thing that i know now
that i didn't know at that time was that
on that day a young boy would
leave even go to work
but he
would return as a man
when you arrived and you parked you've
told this part of the story many times
that you sat there in the car and was
revving you were revving up the engine a
bit to get the battery charged and all
and oswald got out of the car
he must have reached into the back seat
at some point and grabbed his package
and off he went toward the depository
and you saw him walking ahead of you
was that different than his ordinary
routine
uh we did walk together other occasions
but on that particular morning
uh we got there a little bit earlier
and uh
the gauge on my uh vehicle i was driving
that time
i said well i'm just going to sit here
for a few minutes and
uh
reel my engine up just a little bit and
the needle and actually remove and
charge
charge my battery because
uh on this car that i was driving at the
time being uh sometimes when i would get
down there if we worked late sometime
i'd get down it wouldn't start i'd have
to
i would have to uh have a jump
and sometime i would give a jump to
someone else billy love lady and i uh we
often helped one another by the way
billy lovely was
employee there at the texas school book
depository he
he did the
receiving and shipping
and he looked kind of like oswald didn't
he
well the only thing they have in common
is they both have a high forehead
if you would put uh lee oswald
beside billy lovely you would have a
mutt jeff team
one was uh slender
and and
the other billy love lady was short and
stocky
and their personalities were nothing
alike it was totally the opposite
billy lovelady was a
he was a big kidder
a real happy-go-lucky guy
lee was very quiet and
observant
lee was about five nine or so how tall
was uh billy
i don't actually
know how tall he was
but i would probably say billy was
probably
maybe in the 5-2-5-3 area
and i'm not sure about whether that's
correct not but
i
maybe 5'4 the most probably
i talked with billy on the phone in 1980
i believe it was maybe 79 not too long
before he died
and
he told me a story
billy told me that
yes he was aware that there was a
certain facial similarity between he and
oswald
and he said uh
gary some of the guys in our crew
purposely called lee billy
and they called me lee
and he said i thought it was funny as
hell but oswald didn't like it at all
it really got him hacked off
is that ring a bell for you at all
the other thing i can remember about i
think i remember something similar to
that and
and
the reason i could barely remember just
a little bit because i wasn't
present when light was going on i
happened to come over to the area where
billy was
writing his uh freight bill of ladings
and something was said
and people was laughing and i turned
around i said well what are they talking
about
but uh
that could very well be true
but he was a short guy you say five two
five three yes so these
conspiracy theories that came up later
that
lee oswald was actually standing on the
steps with you and the other guys it's
just silly isn't it yes because
uh you can't see me but billy there's
one
uh
photo that is often been
discussed it shows uh billy lovelady
standing on the uh
steps of the school book the toronto
story
well back in the shadow where you can't
see me i was standing back there you but
and i know that spelling
and i've been asked about that photo do
i know that individual and i said yes
matter of fact i think the one
commission asked me about that that
photo
and i told him i said yes that's billy
love lady
and they said are you sure i said yes
and he said
how
could it be lee oswald i said no way
some of the people who ask you this i
assume are
kennedy assassination researchers when
you tell them
that yes that's
uh billy
what is their reaction
how they listen what i have to say
how do they try and talk you out of it
or are they disappointed no uh
to me there's no comparison
you could put a picture of leopard which
there is pictures of him after he was
arrested
uh
and within the dallas police department
you can take that photo
or any other photo of him and put it
beside a picture of benny lovelady and
you can quickly see you're talking about
two individuals
we've jumped ahead a little bit
let's go back uh till just before the
assassination
you talked about how
mr shelley mr truly said it would be
okay to
maybe adjust your schedule a little bit
so everybody could see the president if
they wanted to
when was the last time you saw lee that
morning
it was uh sometime
uh shortly before uh
we was gonna break for uh lunch and the
parade
uh exactly
you know
how many minutes or
i i can't be specific
but it was it was a short time it wasn't
too long
and did he say anything about wanting to
see kennedy or
did he say anything or did you just see
him
uh he never mentioned anything about the
to me about you know the president
and
actually uh
after
the people that
worked in the area i worked in in the
warehouse
there i've
filling or packing the orders
or whatever when they found out that we
were going to get to stop and see the
parade uh
there was often a lot of chatter and a
lot of people was excited about that
um
so several of your co-workers
expressed interest in seeing kennedy oh
yes do you remember which ones
uh
i remember uh
when i was over getting some orders out
out of the box uh lee drummond told me
he says uh
he said we're gonna get to stop and see
the parade
and i said
well that's nice i said that'd be great
and
different different employees had
different reactions but everybody was
excited because
uh
to my knowledge i don't know if if any
of them
had ever had the occasion to see
american president himself
this would be my first
so you and some of the others decided
that
i mean you were all going to go out and
see the president whether together or
separately or whatever right
so where did you go and how did you wind
up
where you were you told us a little bit
about it already
okay
i was standing
at the top of the uh steps
the entrance
to the texas school book depository i
was standing in the shadow
because i was taller so uh in order not
to keep someone that
was shorter than now from being able to
see i thought it'd be a good idea that i
stand in the back
and the shorter people could stand on
the steps and and everyone could see
and that worked out really well because
um
i had seen pictures of the president and
jackie and like life magazine and so
forth like that in
and
uh when they
uh turned um
from houston street on to
elm there and started down to the
underpasses there i i remember a remark
to myself i said
well they look just like they do in the
pictures
and and my own way i had my own
photography
had you thought about bringing the
camera
uh no
uh because as i said earlier i didn't
even know i did i i wasn't aware that
the parade was going to be coming by the
uh school book depository
and
at that time i didn't even own a camera
so it wasn't any it wasn't done really
me any good if i had thought about
because i didn't own one how about some
of the others from the depository did
anyone else have a camera that you know
of
um
not that i know but maybe maybe maybe
someone did uh if it is uh i'm not aware
of it
so you don't recall seeing anyone in the
crowd immediately nearby having a camera
well now
there was people
there to uh watch a parade that had
cameras
but uh not anyone that i i knew
personally
did you see any cameras on your side of
the street you know the depository side
um
standing there on the steps you can see
people walk around trying to get the
best position
uh for the view and there may have been
some people on that side of the street
that had cameras but as i said earlier
not anyone i knew personally so
therefore i wouldn't really
say what well there's miss smith or
there's joey or something with a camera
because um
i was just really excited to be able to
to actually get to watch the parade
um you were standing uh on the top step
then yes or actually the landing part i
would i guess okay was there anyone back
there with you
uh yes
there was a
lady that worked up in one of the
offices
and i do not remember her her name
was she off to your right
or off to your left
to your left
um
was there anyone with a camera up where
you were
not that i know of
now they could help i didn't mean maybe
i just didn't you know wasn't aware of
it or didn't notice it but not to my
knowledge
okay um
so you and uh and billy love lady and uh
who else was out in front there with you
uh bill shelley bill shelly
and there were some uh women that had
worked in the offices there
several of them was there
none of the other order fillers were
there with you
yeah
how long were you out there before
kennedy came by
uh not very long
five minutes or
uh
i really can't be specific but i know it
was a short time
did you remember um
i want you to be careful here that
you're not recalling something that
you've read about later on
um
did something happen in the plaza
shortly before kennedy came by that was
out of the ordinary
uh
the only thing i could remember
uh
that i thought was a little unusual
and maybe it wasn't
but it it was a little unusual to me but
then i just
thought that the
the motorcycle policemen that were
escorting
the
president's
car
there was
several of them and they were because
they were getting pretty close to
getting onto the freeway and i don't
know how long the how many blocks they
had gone in this parade
uh but they were they were kind of
climbing around cutting their
motorcycles on and off to make them
backfire and so and so forth and uh
i thought that was a little unusual but
then
uh now that i've had time to think about
it but at the time been uh
it didn't it didn't seem anything
unusual to me
so this is before the shooting yes and
there are police motorcycles in the area
yeah that may or may not have been part
of the motorcade and you heard them
backfiring yes now the motorcycles that
i heard that her background were
motorcycle policemen they wouldn't even
say like someone a spectator on the
motorcycle no there wasn't that uh the
only uh uh motorcycles that was actually
running
and they were cutting them all and
cutting them back on and make them
backfire
was
the uh
policeman
and so they were doing this on purpose
why do you think they were doing that
i have no idea
okay um do you remember a uh an
ambulance in dealey plaza
before the motorcade came by
now
have you heard about that since then
that
an ambulance came by to pick up a guy uh
you hear a lot of things but i i heard
anything about that
okay
um
that's that's an event where if you had
been there if you'd seen it you probably
would have remembered it
um the ambulance was gone
a good five minutes before kennedy came
by
so so that means that tells me
that you probably didn't get out on the
steps until about 12 25
and kennedy came by at 12 30.
so okay
um
at some point you must have become aware
that the president's getting pretty
close i mean i would assume you heard
that the crowd
the crowd was
cheering i assume you could have heard
some of that noise
and then finally the motorcade turned on
houston street and started coming up the
street towards you
take it from there what can what do you
remember and
what did you see what did you hear
uh the only thing i remember is uh
seeing that the uh
the car in which the president and his
wife and john connolly and
and
there'll be nelly
i was writing
how
i was just so uh
captioned by that
because i'd never gotten it close to
american president
did i actually see
and i was observing all the things right
around the the car in which he was
riding
um
and this about all i i was just uh
watching the people seem to be very
happy and very responsive
uh before he got there and then is
all the waving and so forth that
politicians do and
people trying to get noticed
i guess i was just
caught up in the moment at that time and
i was i was so excited to be able to to
witness that
so the car is coming up houston street
and it makes a left-hand turn right in
front of the book depository doorway so
as you're looking straight out
the car is completing the turn
how long after the
the car completed the turn and started
moving away from you
did the first shot
happen it wasn't it wasn't very long
yeah there was a there was a shop
and
as i said earlier
uh
from
listening to the motorcycles that was
leading the
president's car
they had been backfiring at first i
thought it was a backfire from a
motorcycle
so it sounded pretty much like the
backyards
but then
shortly after whether there was two more
and by that time
there was really chaos there was people
running and everything knew something
wasn't right
uh
from where i was saying you couldn't see
because there was people
standing out on the curb uh they're uh
to the street that was going down to the
underpass so therefore i couldn't
actually
see what was going on in the president's
car
kennedy actually dropped below yes okay
and i could see uh my best shot of uh
him or my best view let's rephrase that
my best view of he and jackie and
governor connolly was when they made the
turn
because there was no one in front of us
and you had a very clear view
but after they passed and dropped out of
sight
i couldn't see what was going on all i
like but after
i discovered that it was actually
someone shooting there was
people running and falling down
and there was just uh
a mass confusion of what was going on
viewel wesley frazier worked with lee
harvey oswald at the texas book
depository in dallas at the time of
president kennedy's assassination
the morning of the assassination as he
often did mr frazier gave oswald a ride
into work
in this oral history recorded for the
sixth floor museum at dealey plaza mr
frazier recounts the events of november
22 1963
and the immediate aftermath of the
assassination including oswald's arrest
later that afternoon
this program lasts about an hour
what was your first realization that
those were shots did someone say that or
did you figure it out yourself or
well uh by time the
the second and third shot was fired i
realized
that it wasn't motorcycle backfire
because it has a different sound to me
and i realized someone was fired and
people was as i said in that whole area
there it was running and falling down
you really couldn't tell at that time
actually what was going on with you were
standing in the position i was standing
and
did you have any idea where the shooting
was coming from
um
the
the sound to me at that time it sounded
like it was coming
coming from above
and so in other words in the building
well i was standing on the steps it was
somewhere it sounded like it was coming
from a building very
the one in which i was staying on the
steps because if you go to that
intersection there that houston and elm
there's buildings of a certain height
in every and on three corners
and
i don't i do not know if the same effect
of buildings like that present kind of
like an echo
uh effect uh
the
the only thing i could i could say was
that uh i realized that it was gunfire
but
to be specific
of which building it was coming from
other than it sounded like it come from
above
where i was standing
i i can't i can't be more specific than
that and and it sounds like it come from
above where we was we were
standing
and you heard three shots yes were they
evenly spaced or were some closer than
the others or
i heard three shots there was one
and then there was uh
the other two was was much closer in
succession
how many seconds do you think the
shooting took altogether
i don't know exact
but probably
i would probably say all
and this is probably i don't know for a
fact i probably say all three shots were
were taken within 15 seconds
uh and the last two were closer together
than the first two yes
the further there was a war the first
one
and then the second and third one was
was was just almost this back to back
it was very fast
um how much time then between the last
two shots
i'd probably say
maybe five seconds
if it's a if it's that long
um
since then of course i'm sure you've
heard that some people heard a different
number of shots yes
could there have been more than three
or could there have been fewer than
three
not fewer than three
now if someone
like i said if you go to that area and
i'm not uh
well versed enough
to
debate something on a echo or acoustics
type fact
but uh
if
two weapons fire at the same time
which would be very hard to do but
anything's possible i guess
maybe there could have been more than
three but i know three i heard three
um
i'm trying to i'm trying to think of a
way to figure out from where you were
where
when the shooting actually started
when you stand
in the doorway of the old depository
building today and you look straight out
almost directly ahead is that street
light or the the the
traffic light yes and had the car gone
very far
where was the car in relation to that
traffic light when the first shot was
fired couldn't you
can you
can you explain it that way
well it would be hard to pinpoint that
because not knowing
the speed of the car
but
it wasn't very far
after it dropped out of my sight
well okay maybe that's the way to do it
then
the first shot
when the first shot was fired you could
not see the car at all at that point no
i couldn't see the car
okay
because the intersection there is kind
of flat and then it starts to go
downhill drops off rather quickly yeah
so it was after the car dropped down
when the first shot was fired
uh
like i said the car was out
out of my my view when the first shot
was fired
and you'd asked me earlier about how
long did i think
the
these the three shots that i heard
uh
had taken
and i told you 15 seconds if you've
taken fire
a shot say like for instance
on the first second
and then the second shot might not have
been
somewhere to like to eight to ten
seconds and then the the third one on
the say like
somewhere between the 10 and 15.
okay
what did you do next
well
after
the first shot
and then when the second and third i
walked down
on the steps
uh to where billy was originally
standing
because uh my memory surgery correctly
uh billy and um
mr shelley
had gone down the street that ran right
in front of the depository there
they had walked down there
and
um
the lady i was standing by we we just
stayed right there on the steps
and um
and then people remember
somebody come running by and said they'd
shot the president
over that time it was really uh
really chaos
and i thought the best thing to do is
just stay still and say where somebody
could see you
because at that time there was policemen
uh
all around and they had their weapons
drawn
and i thought it'd be best just to stay
still
how long did you stay
on the steps
oh a few minutes
and
i may have walked a short way down that
street you know in front of the uh
uh
texas school book depository i think
it's usually referred to as the elm
street extension okay
well i may have walked a short distance
down there and then i then i thought
maybe the best uh did i just turn around
and go back to where i was
um
okay let me make sure i understand
you stayed to the best your memory you
stayed on the steps for two three maybe
four minutes something like that
at some point though you you walked part
way down that
extension straight okay yeah alex and
then you came back up the steps and
we stood around there and we talked for
a little while and and uh then we went
back inside the building when you say we
talked and you're talking about bill
shelley
uh she's still there or
bill shelley and billy were they they
had gone further than i had gone on the
street and there was so many people
running everything i lost them i didn't
know where they were
i would probably have gone further if
i'd if i could see billy and bill shelly
but not
being able to uh
pick them out of the crowd
i i just uh said well i was going back
to the steps and i did that and i stayed
there
you know
a few minutes
and the lady i was standing by
i told her she asked me and i said well
i don't know any more than i did before
i went down there i said
and
so we went back into the building and uh
people that worked there began to come
back in because there was
there was women that worked there and uh
for the publisher they were crying and
everything about you know they shot the
president and so forth and
so i
realized that i hadn't eaten my lunch
now i know this may sound strange but
but i was hungry and being a young boy
you're usually hungry so
i
i went back into the building and i had
gone down to the basement
and i sat down and i was eating my lunch
and there were several uh plainclothes
uh
detectives and uh i remember uh
a uh
police
a uniform policeman
uh
he came by and he asked me how long i'd
been there and
and had i seen anybody and i said no i
didn't see anybody unusual down here
i said i heard somebody over
it was two ways you could go down into
the basement
it was uh right there by a belt
that went up to the meter where
junior
i put the postage on the packages and
then over uh
right by um
where billy lovely would write up the
freight bill of ratings there was a uh
entrance and you could go down into the
basement that way it's a stairway
let's go back to the to the steps in the
doorway of the depository
first of all let me ask you do you
remember what kind of clothing you wore
that day what color
what kind of shirt did you have on
i'm asking because i'd like to be able
to
to find you in some of these early
pictures of the depository
uh
probably had blue jeans and boots well
western boots
uh
the shirt
i don't too much remember but i i know
that day i had a jacket on
when you were outside
oh yes because it was cool that day
i had i had a jacket on and uh
matter of fact the jacket that i was
wearing that day
was
my ffa jacket
and what color was that
it was a
dark blue
but on the back i think it was yellow
riding
of uh ffa
ffa stands for future farmers of america
and then it had the stadium from which i
i i came
okay um
did you see lee oswald at this time
after the assassination
no
have you heard subsequently how he left
the building
well there's been a lot of rumors uh
when
when we
were when we were out
inside the building before we'd gone in
uh
i remember
seeing
a lee come from the uh the um
dock area
and walk up the
street beside the texas school
depository
building
and there's so many things going on it
and i saw him when he walked up and he
went across um
houston street
and i thought he may have been going to
get him a sandwich or something so i
really didn't think anything about it
and i lost him in the crowd and i don't
know what happened from there
how long after the assassination do you
think this was
i'll probably
five to ten minutes probably
so you remember seeing him briefly
coming down houston street along the
side of the building yes
so that told you that he must have gone
out the back door by the location yes by
the way that's that's exactly right
and did you see him cross houston street
uh
he crossed houston street and then
started across the elm street
and i turned because someone said
something to me
and i turned to answer them
and then
when i turned back and looked in the
direction he was gone
could he have come out the front door of
the depository no
no
so how far away from him do you think
you were when you saw him
the closest i
uh got to him when he was walking up
the um
alongside the texas school book
depository coming
from the dock area
was probably
probably 10 12 feet
do you remember anything about him did
he look
no he didn't look any different or act
any different than he did
there was so many people and so much
chaos and everything all around but then
that
i thought maybe he was just going
somewhere to get him a sandwich
and how was he dressed do you remember
was he in his t-shirt or did you have
his shirt on or uh he has his jacket
down nice jacket he has jacket on that
guy
um
let me regroup here
um
so at some point you finally went you
went back into the building then went
downstairs into the basement to to
finish to eat your lunch yes
you were down in the basement when some
investigators police or whatever came in
yes you were all by yourself down there
yes i was all by myself and they asked
me had i seen anyone come down
into the basement where i was there
or did i see anyone go up
the stairway there by the
belt
and i said i told him i said no sir
and uh
and i told him i did hear somebody over
on the stairway but i never could see
what
see anybody i heard somebody over there
but i i couldn't see anybody
so it was
so
i don't know but maybe it was just uh
one of the investigators or policemen
you know in the searching of the
building
kelly i had a question there and it went
away oh um
had you seen anyone in the building that
day that you didn't recognize
no
no strange faces no scientists
um at some point then you
must have thought
what am i going to do for the rest of
the day am i supposed to stay here and
work or are we dismissed what do we do
so what did you do all right actually i
ate my lunch
i
went back upstairs
and
by that time on the first floor there
people were milling around people that
worked in the building there and were
talking and everything and
uh mr shelley got us together he and mr
truly and we had a roll call
and where did this take place outside mr
shelley's office right there between mr
shelley but shelley's office was right
next to
uh mr truly's
if you came in off if you i would have
entered the texas school depository
building
uh by the steps on which i was standing
watching the um
parade
when you when you come into the building
there uh to your right would be an
elevator going up to the uh
offices publishers offices
and
and if you would come straight uh
through the double doors there then you
would be and right to your right with mr
truly's office
and there was a uh
uh counter there that a lot of time uh
teachers would come and uh for a wheel
call and pick up a textbook
and we had the wheel calls laying right
there because sometimes miss shelley
would say here i i will call them
they'll be about to pick this up shortly
and i'd go and pull it and i'd bring it
back up there and then actually he'd
check it
before letting the teachers have it
so
uh mr truly's office there was first and
then right next to his
uh
was mr shelley's and in that area right
there is where we
uh
where we all uh
uh grouped together there and we had a
roll call you and the other other guys
who were order fillers in that yes sorry
everyone that worked in the warehouse
there
either were they regardless of whether
it was uh order filler or a packer or
what their function was
now the people up in the that worked up
in the publisher's office i'm sure they
had their own roll call but the
warehouse personnel had theirs right
that that location i i stated earlier
there
outside of mr shell is in mr truly's
office okay and truly and shelley are
both there yes okay
and
did they actually read off names or did
they just ask you guys anybody missing
no they they read names off and you had
to answer
okay and who was missing
uh the only person missing was lee
osmond
okay let's go back to
the roll call um oswald was unaccounted
for yes what did all you guys think
about that
well at first i didn't think anything
about it because i thought he might had
as i said earlier he might have walked
over because in some of the buildings
around there
uh
there was places that you could get
sandwiches
and i thought he may have walked over
there and
and due to what had happened earlier
and i thought maybe he was
he got tied up with getting him a
sandwich something and that
he would probably be back shortly
because nothing was made of it at first
when he wasn't there
um
okay so then what happened were you guys
told to just go home for the day or
well
after
we had the roll call and we stayed there
for a short time i don't know exactly
how many minutes it was but when they
realized that lee wasn't coming back
mr truly and miss shelley got the okay
from
management
upstairs off the second floor that
due to what had happened that day that
we were just going to shut down and call
it a day
and that's what we did
during the roll call
you mentioned that truly was there yes
do you remember him saying anything
about having seen oswald
i don't remember anything but but i
think
i have
heard or read somewhere where where that
uh
mr truly was with
someone searching the building and i
think they had uh uh
they had seen lee in the lunchroom
that event happened and that event
happened within a minute or two of the
assassination
so the roll call took
place when how long afterwards did that
happen
uh roll call was probably
probably somewhere i'd probably say 30
45 minutes
after that
okay
so
well this is it i'm not sure now about
exactly how long the roll call was
afterwards uh from my memory i'd
probably say it was probably 30 to 45
minutes after the assassination that we
actually had the
roll
call so in this 30 to 45 minute period
you were just hanging out
wondering what to do and wondering what
was going on yes
um
after the roll call then the decision
was made to call it a day yes was that
before or after you had learned that
president kennedy had died
that was before because when i had left
and was on my way home
that's when i learned that he was
pronounced
uh dead out at the hospital
and now
and by that time the
news channels were
everybody was
trying to report what had happened
uh
there that day
okay now this was a friday normally you
would take oswald with you on friday yes
but not this day what happened
did you
expect to be taking him home that
afternoon
no he had told me earlier when i asked
him why he was going out on thursday
rather than friday to and that's when he
told me to get the current ross to hang
the curtains for his apartment
uh he told me he wouldn't be going home
with me
that day
and was did this strike you as being
unusual
no not the time bit
because when i said nothing unusual
because
uh
our conversations were mainly
about work while we were working and he
never had
given me the impression that
he had
lied to me so therefore it was
i didn't have any reason to
to think something was unusual
okay you're in your car
you hear on the radio that president
kennedy has been pronounced dead yes
you're on your way back home
to irving
yes um
when you got home
who was there your sister was she there
with the kids or well uh
i didn't go directly home okay
what i had what i did was that uh
i stopped by the hospital where my
stepfather
he and my mother were up visiting my
sister
and her husband and children
and uh he had had um
he'd had i think a heart attack
uh i know he was he yeah
he had several heart attacks before he
passed away and but he was in there and
they were they were treating him i think
for um
for heart failure
when had he when had he gone into the
hospital
uh he had gone in to the hospital
uh
i think a day or two before friday or
he'd been there several days
and so i thought i'd just stop by and
check on him and see how he was doing
and i could tell my mother because
when i got home
how he was doing
and which hospital was he in
he was in the hospital
it's not a hospital anymore it but this
at this time it was a hospital located
at uh irving boulevard and uh pioneer
pioneer so that was in dallas or in
irving and airbnb in irving okay
and how much how long how much time did
you spend there at the hospital before
you went home
well
i
had only been there a short time
and
by the way i didn't go home directly go
home
after i left there uh i was there a
short time and i and the nurse uh came
into the room
because my nurse earlier had asked me
she was uh they were giving him um
i always glue clothes or whatever they
was giving him she asked me to count the
drops per minute to check her and i was
doing that because she was going to be
back in a minute
another nurse came in not the one that
asked me to
check the drops per minute that he was
getting
on the medication
that they were giving him but she said
you have a you have a phone call and i
said well
just patch it to the room and
i'll get it i thought it might have been
my mother or somebody calling to check
on my my stepfather
and she said well she says we can't do
that she'll have to come out here to the
the nursery station and take the call
well i
opened the door and proceeded to the
nursing station and at that time
i was met
suddenly by two detectives
from
the dallas police department they were
detective rhodes and
detective stovall
and
they
proceeded to
first me frisked me and checked me
and i was
uh
totally surprised because i couldn't
understand why this was being done to me
uh
and uh
after uh
uh cat uh catching me by surprise and uh
they told me that they were taking me
downtown dallas
and
we
they were parked out close to my car
and they had already been searching in
my car because i remember looking in the
back seat the back seat had been pulled
out and i asked him i said uh
what have you been doing in my car and
they said well we've been searching your
car
had they not indicated to you what their
interest was in talking with you
how they uh they said it was in
reference to the
the death of john f kennedy
and uh
and then after
i've been in their custody i learned
more
but i could not i i will never
understand why they treat me the way
they did but
it wasn't long that they found out that
that i didn't know anything and
detective rose and detective uh stovall
they became two of my best friends
okay let's
do you have any idea at what time what
point in time
this happened
um
oh at the time that they arrested me
yeah yeah when you when you first met
these guys
uh i'd probably say probably somewhere
probably
between
1 30 and 2 o'clock in the afternoon
now i don't know what time they showed
that they actually
you know picked me up or arrested me but
i just i'd probably say it's probably
1 30
somewhere between 1 30 and 2 o'clock
okay let me see if i can jog your memory
a little bit here
president kennedy was pronounced dead at
one o'clock okay
but it wasn't announced until about 1
30.
okay and i was on my way out to the
hospital because i heard you on the
radio
okay
so
you probably would have gotten to the
hospital about
no later than two o'clock i would think
maybe maybe
five or ten minutes after
so you're with your stepfather
for some period of time
a short time very short time 10 minutes
or half hour probably uh probably
probably not more than 10 minutes
at the most 10 15 minutes at the most
okay and that's when you got the call to
go out to the nurse's station and that's
when rose and stovall appeared yes well
that would put it at about 2 30
quarter to three at the latest
well i i don't know exactly all the time
but like i said i would
i wasn't looking at the time
and uh well how did they f how did they
come up with your name so fast did they
ever tell you that first of all did they
tell it
did they tell you that back then or have
you subsequently learned from them how
they
got your name
no i don't know how they got my name but
i know they they had been out to my
sister's home and irving before they
come to the hospital so they learned
from from lenny
where you were
i think i called her once i got to the
hospital
from the phone in the room i think
called and told her that i was up at the
hospital
and i was going to stay up there for a
while
a little i did i didn't know at that
time that all this other was going on
because uh
they had i remember they did go out to
the house before coming up to the
hospital
is it possible that your
your
memory might have distorted the times a
bit because
this seems awfully fast
and i wonder if some of these events
might have taken place later in the
afternoon then you're remembering
i could be wrong but i don't think so uh
gary because um
because i know i left work
and i heard about the president being
pronounced dead
and now
at that time the area one is congested
with traffic it is now the the
population is much greater now in the
dallas area
than it was then it and i remember
going out to the hospital there and i
wasn't there
very very long
10-15 minutes at the most they were
there
but how they got my name and how they
got
on to me
i don't know
um
oswald was
walked into the police department
right about two o'clock
so sometime after two is when
they learned
that he was a depository employee
they could only have learned about you
from him i would think unless it was
there anyone else in the depository who
knew that oswald rode to and from work
with you sometimes
uh
billion mr shelley knew
well i wonder if the police could have
heard from those two
uh well of course then see they still
have to tie in oswald's name to all of
this and how how that occurred i can't
answer that because i had no idea
now maybe uh if you would
check with detective rosenthal stovall
because
they they worked under
captain will fritz
maybe they could give you a better idea
about that
but
that i can't help you with because i i i
don't know
and you say since then uh you've become
uh friends with these guys have you seen
them recently no uh when i want to
clarify that i became friends with them
um
not like
somebody i would see on a
uh
weekly or a day basis or something like
that but
uh after they thoroughly checked me out
and and they interrogated me for quite
some time
they had gone to uh captain wilfred's
and says this kid doesn't know anything
he's clean
but captain will fritz won't accept that
and they told me that they uh
and they had other people in the police
department there was other detectives
beside them that cross examined me
um
it's quite intense
uh was just one
uh cross examination after another a
team would work on me for a while
answering me questions and i'd tell them
what i could and then somebody else
would come in this went on for quite
some time
and they finally were convinced that hey
i wasn't
guilty of anything
i'm just a person in the wrong place at
the wrong time
and
they both gave me their their cards
and told me that if i ever had problems
about this
be sure to give them a call
and somewhere over the years i have
i would put them
put them up i don't carry them in my my
wallet i did for a long time
because i was real uh afraid that
someone would ask me about that
and um
but
um that is my friendship with them that
afterwards they found out that
i wasn't involved in this and
and i could talk with them more freely
but
so they took you from the hospital up in
irving all the way down to the downtown
dallas down down dallas
and you were there for how long
i was there
it was after midnight before i got to
come home really
i was there quite some time they they
said that at one time they were late
they were taking me home and they
started out
stemen's freeway
and probably got out to some area around
inwood or mockingbird
and then they turned around and took me
back
again and i went through some more uh
questioning and so forth
and
by the time i got out there it was after
midnight
do you remember the names of some of the
others who uh
questioned you
uh
no
i have i have a third name i have three
names here you've already named two of
them
adam jack
that was his last name
say again adam check
i don't remember that name but at that
point
things were happening so fast
here's a boy
that's only 19 years old from a small
rural area and all of a sudden you're
involved
in a case
that you did not choose to be involved
in
that everyone in the world now knows
about
and it was um
it was quite uh
it was quite a horrifying experience for
me because i never had had any problem
with the law at all and then all of a
sudden
i was
in the process of trying to be tied into
the assassination of john f kennedy
when and how
did you first realize
that
you were connected to this event
through
lee harvey oswald
when they arrested me
did what did they tell you why
uh
they told me they were taking me
downtown for some questioning
but did well
when did you first hear that oswald
your friend lee was a suspect
uh on the way out to the hospital
he came over the uh uh
the news station that i was listening to
um
and i don't remember where it was uh
820 or 1480 i don't remember which
station i was listening to
uh
probably 1480 but i'm not for sure
uh
they said that the
the suspect
that they were trying to find and was
their best lead
uh was lee oswald
that really that really threw me for a
curve
i i was going to say you're in your car
driving and you're hearing that the
police are looking for
the oswald
in connection with the assassination of
john f kennedy well that was to me that
was mind-boggling because
i asked myself how could lee do
something like that
because the man i knew
was so
was was such a uh perfectionist and what
he did and he tried to do everything
correctly and he was so good with the
children in the neighborhood i asked
myself how could someone do something
like that
are you clear that
that the information you heard was that
the police were looking for him or that
he had been arrested
well the first thing they said we have a
uh
we have a suspect that we're looking for
in connection with the assassination of
john f kennedy
and he said his name is lee oswald
well i knew that
the chances of it being somewhere and
then they said well he was
employed at the texas school book
depository well i knew that was the same
lead that i knew
and this
did not make sense to you that
no oswald could be connected no
well
it was it was very hard for me to
to even begin to believe
that he could do something like that
and you're certain that this happened
before you arrived at the hospital yes
now what time this news
thing
was and what exactly what time it was i
was on the way out to
to the hospital to see my stepfather i
can't be specific but i can only
estimate
we were talking about
the interrogation sessions
at the dallas police department
the afternoon and evening of the
assassination and you were telling
telling me about
they really grilled you i mean they
really questioned you do you do you
remember some of the questions they
asked and
what they were trying to find out
um they were trying to find out if
if i was involved
with lee oswald in the assassination of
john f kennedy
and i don't remember the questions
exactly but they were over and over
one
two officers would come in and now
interrogate me
and they would go through the questions
several times
and
during this when i was doing this they
had me looking straight ahead into the
wall i couldn't left i couldn't look
left or right i just had to answer them
and when they would
tire or
decided that they couldn't get any more
information out of me then uh they would
leave the room and then two more
uh
detectives would come in and they would
begin to interrogate me and it was the
same questions over and over and over
and after
numerous hours they finally realized
that i was telling them all that i
actually knew
when was the first time then that you
realized
how you were connected
um
other than
just taking him to work taking oswald to
work that morning
um
that first occurred to me when i was um
arrested out at the hospital where i was
visiting on that friday afternoon with
my stepfather
when the detective rose and stovall uh
arrested me and took me downtown did
they actually
did they actually arrest you or just
say we come with us we want to talk to
you or uh
they didn't put me in handcuffs
because i remember i requested that i
said that
i won't be any problems i said just
don't handcuff me embarrass me in front
of my myself love it
and um and they i didn't
they followed that request
and i had gone downtown with them
and once downtown then the
interrogation or trying to find out
what my involvement was
if any to what extent
and that went on as i said not to be
repetitious uh
quite a few hours
did they actually pull out the handcuffs
though when they first talked to you
out of the hospital
i think they i think they had thought
about it i knew i i know they have
handcuffs
but i
requested they not do that and i think
when they realized that
i was actually quite harmless
they i agreed to go along with that
um did they ask you about
oswald and whether he had anything with
him that morning
um
i'm sure they did
they asked quite a bit about
oswald and and the work we did at the
texas school book the trial story and
and uh
and the route that we took in to work
that morning and uh so forth like that
if it was any different than others and
um
and basically uh if we talked about
anything and if we did what did we talk
about
um
and i tell them generally what i told
you the the most thing you could uh
comment you could get out of lee was
about his uh child or our child that was
unborn
and the weather and uh he wasn't a he
wasn't a big talker
when uh
when did it first occur to you
or
when did someone first make you aware of
the possibility that the rifle may have
been in your car
on that trip into work that morning uh
that was uh
made clear to me when uh when they began
their interrogation of me trying to find
out
uh what i knew if any about the
assassination of john f kennedy
well
how did they
how did they get into that what made
them
uh
pursue that that line of questioning uh
that i did not know but i i do remember
if they asked me if if lee had brought
anything to work with him that morning
and i told him yes he had brought a
package
and that i asked him what it was and he
told me it was the curtain rods that he
told me that he would be bringing to
work the day before
and
the package story is is one of the
stories that you've had to tell over and
over and over again over the
over the years
uh
but we need to ask you to tell it one
more time as best you recall
when you first saw oswald
out at your house that morning did you
see a package at that time
the first time i saw the package was
when i opened the car door and as i was
sitting down
i glanced over my shoulder looking at
him and i i saw out of the car of mine
and something was laying on on the back
seat
and that's when i asked him i said
what's that on the back seat and he says
remember that's the curtain rods i told
you that i'd come out to get that i was
taken back
to hang the curtains in my apartment
and that was the last that he and i had
talked about i didn't think anything
else about it
the size and shape seemed like it might
be just what he said
uh yes i'll
only get in a glance at and not actually
looking at it
real thorough
i've often described that the package
was in the area of
of uh two feet take an inch or two
one way either way
and um
and that's about the best uh i can
describe the package it was made out of
a brown
wrapping paper that you could buy
anywhere
and it's quite common in companies that
do
where they package and mail
out packages to customers
regardless of the type of business
that they are out
and the tape and so forth that they use
at the
at that time that we use there at the
depository or even a business today is
is very similar
have you become aware of the the
controversy involving the bag and how
long the rifle was and things like that
yes
i know a lot of people is
is wondered
actually what i did see
and
what was inside the bag
i don't know
all i know is what i was told
and as i said earlier
um
jordan working with lee lee was always a
very sincere type person to me and he
never uh
gave me the impression that he would
not tell you the truth
and so therefore when he told me there
was curtain rods in there i didn't have
any reason to doubt him
[Music]
when you guys were on the on the way
into work that morning what was his
attitude like was it different in any
way from previous trips
i'm glad you asked it no uh actually um
lee was the same as he always was
very quiet uh just deserving watching
the cars and
uh as we drove along uh
and the that morning when we was driving
in
the the day was a kind of overcast
cloudy it was kind of misty early in the
morning
so there wasn't anything about what he
said or did that was
in any way out of the ordinary no
he acted as isn't as perfect normal as
he had uh
if if we'd had some way could have taped
some of the things we talked about our
uh
our
these reactions to our uh
short conversations i i think people
would really be amazed at how
really bland he actually was and uh
and and as i said not to be repetitious
uh he wasn't a big talker
and uh
and he would answer you if you asked him
something but uh he's usually one or two
sentences
um let's go back to the bag
just for a minute and
you know we're almost 39 years after
after the fact and
um
i i'm i'm sure a lot of this is
still pretty clear in your mind but you
know
you have to people would always wonder
if you've picked up something over the
years and blended in into your own story
the controversy about the bag is that
when the rifle is fully assembled it's
about 40 inches long
you and your sister
um
in the early days always indicated that
the bag was
a little over two feet 26 inches 27
inches somewhere in there give or take
an inch like you said
when you take the rifle apart
it's
34 or 36 inches in length something like
that quite a big difference i mean
that's the shortest it could possibly be
so the conclusion is that either the
rifle was not in the package
or that you and your sister were
mistaken
how do you how does one resolve that
or is there a way to resolve it well i'm
not sure if there is any way to resolve
it i can only tell
you what i had actually seen
now
i know
the things like what you discussed about
the length if you if you should break
down the calcano rifle
and that the barrel is a certain length
and the stock is a certain length uh
we'll really never know actually what
was in that bag
he have a rifle in it i don't know
uh
and is there any way that uh we could be
certain after this amount of time
to uh
solve that
uh
i don't have an answer for that uh
i i wish i did and and i wish i could i
could just say right out whether it was
this and this or that was this way
but
only seeing something for just a
very
small amount of time
and not knowing at that time how
important
the short time that you had to look that
was going to mean later on and how how
much significance it would be on that
i'm sure
a lot of people has uh come up with
their own
conclusion
uh but i would like to assure you
that
my sister and i are telling you the
truth at actually what we have seen
now where one wants to believe that or
not that's up to them
uh
but uh
i know
what we did see and that's all i can
tell you
okay where were you uh sunday morning a
sunday morning actually
i was in the kitchen
the same place i was on friday morning
when lee had come down to the house
uh
i was in the kitchen
and uh
eating my breakfast
and we were watching
the uh they were
was watching the news we had the
television on
and
they were getting ready to move lee
oswald
from the place that they
had him at that time
and on
and while we were watching
we
witnessed through
television
uh
jack ruby uh shooting at lee oswal
what was the reaction and
what were your thoughts or at the
immediate your immediate thoughts
well
i
i was kind of sad to see that because
uh knowing what i knew at that time
i was hoping
that we could clear this all up
by that way
lee would be able to stand trial
and we would find out if he was actually
guilty of assassinating president john f
kennedy
or if they had the wrong person
what did you think
did you think you did it
well
i've been told a lot of things
i've read a lot of things
but i've never
been completely
convinced that leopold did that
and i know if you sit on a jury
and
in a courtroom
and listening to a trial
and if someone uh
is trying to or being prosecuted
and trying to get a conviction
a death penalty
i could not vote
to
uh
put someone to death by whatever a
method whether it be legal injection or
um
electric chair or whatever
method the state would use i could not
do that unless i was 100
absolutely sure
that that individual did that if there
was a fraction of doubt in my mind
that
just a possibility that we don't have
all the facts then i couldn't do that
and oswald didn't fit that uh no
not to me
what was it about him that made you
question
the thing that i've asked myself
and
i don't have a degree
to substantiate this
and i'm sure there's been some people in
somewhere in some time that have
done something similar to this but on a
smaller scale
that have been guilty
but maybe got away with it
uh
but my theory or basis
is
listening to the children
as they
spoke of him
his kindness and usually when you find
a dog that is kind with children
uh
i'm not saying they can't become
uh
a murderer or
assassinate someone
but i think it's uh highly unlikely
because i don't i i i just don't think
unless they were very desperate or put
into a situation
that they had no choice
and i know this there's probably people
that will listen to what i have to say
and
and disagree with me and if you disagree
with me that's that's your privilege
that's because we live in america
and and then that's one of our rights
here in this country
to be able to
to think for ourself
now sometime
what we think may not be correct
and
we could be correct on some things but
wrong on something else
but
[Music]
after all this time i i'm not totally
convinced
and that would been the interesting
thing
if if lee had been able to live and we
could actually have gone to trial
we wouldn't be sitting here talking
about this now because
we would
probably would have solved and got the
correct answer
what do you think the correct answer
really is
that's that's a very good question
i'm not sure but i think it would be
very sad
if if we have after all these years
have said this man
assassinated john f kennedy and he
didn't
did he or did he not
i don't know
but i'm not convinced that
100 that he did that
and if he'd been able to
go to trial
i think he would have answered a lot of
questions
and hopefully we would have come to the
uh
and
to the to the
right
i don't like to use the word assumed
but i
we would we would have found maybe the
truth
because each day goes by
and each year passes
the chances of us
ever finding the 100 percent truth
of
who actually
assassinated john f kennedy
is the chance of finding that out
because it goes uh
it gets slimmer and dimmer as each
passing day
coming up espan.org for the c-span 3
history schedule the following program
is about one hour
today is thursday july 10 2003 this is
stephen fagan with the sixth floor
museum at d lee plaza the interview we
are doing today is part of the museum's
oral history collection and today we are
joined by bill and gail newman
eyewitnesses to the assassination of
president kennedy thank you both very
much for agreeing to this interview
welcome and for the record at the outset
of these i'd like you both to give me
your full name dayton place of birth
and we'll start with gail on that
my name is francis gail
nix newman
i was born in dallas texas december the
31st 1940.
my name is william eugene newman jr
my birthday to july the 3rd 1941 i was
born in dallas texas okay
and i want to say at the outset that um
we want to keep this as informal as
possible go on a first name basis and uh
i also want to say that i've known the
two of you most of my life and we've
been friends for a long time and that's
correct
and so we want to we want to keep things
nice and informal right
all right um
whoever would like to go first is fine
but if you could just give me a brief
summary of your childhood up until the
time you you got married i'd like to get
that from both of you whoever wants to
go first
well i'll i'll go first
i
spent my childhood in oak cliff
i grew up uh
i was born
on windermere street
and i spent the majority of my life up
until gail and i married on beckley
street 1447 north beckley
which incidentally is just
some three or four blocks from where
lee harvey oswald was
uh residing at the time of the
assassination
so i'm an old cliff boy and uh
at the time of of the assassination of
president kennedy
gail and i were living in oak cliff on
clarendon drive
i also grew up in the oakland area
i have a
older sister and younger brother
and
we lived our entire life until bill and
i moved to mesquite in 1971
in oak cliff
all right if i could uh
just get the
full names of both of your children and
their birth dates as well
we better let gail do that stephen
uh
billy is our oldest child is william
eugene newman iii and he was born
october the 8th 1959
and
our youngest son is james clayton newman
and he was born november the 4th 1961.
okay
um can i just get your impressions of
dallas in the late 50s early 1960s
and if you want to do that by comparing
it to today that's fine just however you
want to describe it so that whoever
watches these in the future will have a
relatively good impression of just what
the city was like in the early 1960s
well i haven't thought about that
stephen but uh
i i i think it had the feel of a much
smaller town
in the in the 50s and 60s you know
the communities were seem to be not so
spread out as they are today and i'm
sure the
population is probably tripled or
more in that in that
period of time
downtown dallas
was the center of dallas at that time
and uh
i think we're way outside of that now
but i think dallas had a
uh uh just a feel of a smaller town
that's my feeling i mean i don't have
anything to relate it to very well
uh you know i've always felt good about
dallas and i've always felt good about
texas
no i think it was just a much slower
pace
than it is
now do you recall any of the uh
political atmosphere of the late 50s
early 60s the right-wing extremist
activity for instance that was prevalent
in the city
well we
i was not very political at the time i
mean you know people would discuss
politics and
who was running for president
i can remember as a
when president eisenhower was running
for office and
i was throwing a paper route and there's
a time travel paper route and at that
time it was considered as a
as the
liberal or democratic paper
and i had an i like i
button
and uh and and i can remember going in
my route manager seeing that button
and jumping all over me uh because of it
because he said do you know what's going
to happen to this country if that man is
elected you know meaning that
republicans are going to take over
and of course you know i was
12 years old or something at the time
and
he said i said no and he's you know
eisenhower was a to me was a war hero he
wasn't a politician
so
i
i don't have a
vivid imagination of of what a democrat
or what a republican was at
at the time
as i got older of course
you could kind of
understand the difference or i kind of
understood the difference
but
i would rather not get into a real deep
philosophical discussion about
politics i mean i i have my viewpoints
but
i think i'm not alone in that i think
everyone has but
can you tell me if you uh voted for
kennedy in 1960
i don't think i voted in 1960 we did we
voted in 1916. he had to be 21 years old
and you also paid poll tax for the
privilege to vote so we were not old
enough
to vote
in the first election i can remember my
mother and stepfather voting and i
remember that
my stepfather voted for
nixon and my mother voted for president
kennedy because she thought he was a
nice looking man
and uh so that's about how deep our
politics was at that time
well what did you think of uh kennedy
and jackie just as just as people
throughout their their three years in
the white house
well
they seem like
nice people
like i say at that time we were
uh more or less trying to live day to a
day-to-day life you know working making
a paycheck and
and going out to eat into a movie and
and maybe going to church on sunday
so the president the president
who was the president what he was doing
at the time was not a big part of our
life i think
the fact that he was as young as he was
as president
kind of made him a standout person
you know because
up until that time you thought of the
president being a much older person i
mean especially when you compare
president eisenhower with president
kennedy so there was that
as we look back now that young vigor of
a young man being in the white house
when did you first hear about president
kennedy making a trip to texas
well i'm sure we heard it on probably on
tv and radio
uh
he was on a campaign tour and
you know for his real getting prepared
for his re-election for his second term
and i'm sure it was on the news and uh
and of course we saw the
parade route in the paper and and uh
and we knew that president kennedy and
mrs kennedy were flying into low field
and at what time they'd be there you
know anticipated time of arrival
but i'm sure we got it through the news
media
and you were available to go down there
that morning can you talk about that yes
uh i had taken an electrical examination
and and i was off from work
i'd taken the exam
a few days before and i was waiting on
the results of it and had taken a little
time off from work
and
gail and i
we wanted to see the president and mrs
kennedy it's not every day that the
president united states comes to your
town you know it's not an everyday event
like say a washington d.c or new york
city i mean
maybe several times a year the
president's there in new york city but
very very seldom busy in dallas texas
so we we wanted to
want to go out and see the president see
mrs kennedy
and so you went to
love field yes we went to love phil and
and uh i had clayton our youngest son
and when the plane came in when the
plane landed
and
the dignitaries got off the plane
uh
we ran up to the fence we me and clayton
and myself
and i got a real good view of mrs
kennedy and president kennedy as they
went by
but gail and billy did not and the crowd
was rather large and
so like i say we knew the parade route
we jumped in our car and we tried to get
ahead of the parade before you uh before
we leave the left field area i want to
ask you a little bit about that um how
about how far away were you from the
president
is he passed by
well we were against the fence and
you know
looking back i i would say that uh we
were within um
50 to 100 feet i mean
it was a
considerable distance but there was
nothing between us and
in them uh as they pass by you know
other than
the tarmac or the runway
i've looked at some of the news footage
of the arrival of field because there's
there's lots of footage of the president
shaking hands at the fence and i've
always tried to find you in the crowd
there uh can you describe maybe where
you were in relation to the uh we were
downstream from where the the hand
shaking was taking place they they were
actually in the car and got stepped in
we're in the in the car in the motorcade
moved past us
you know
we were not
what you're describing we were not at
that location we were some
200 feet
down the way or something and i'm just
groping for a number we were some
distance away from where he walked up to
the fence and
was uh touching the people's hands
well what was the what was the
atmosphere like it left field i mean
i've seen the footage
described well people were excited i
mean that's you know i i don't recall
anything negative about it everybody was
pretty excited you don't see that see
the president and first lady
did you see any uh demonstrators or any
uh signs that were derogatory i did not
i didn't either no
uh prior to the president arriving
did you have any apprehension adelaide
stevenson had just had his incident the
previous month were you worried at all
that there might be an incident or a
demonstration
no
i was not
i don't know what gail's feelings were
but
like
like i say i mean
i was just kind of living a day-to-day
life and
well you'll have to realize that we were
just young i was a stay-at-home mom with
two two young children and
probably didn't have much time to even
read the newspaper
trying to keep keep up with the boys
okay
so you you got back in your car after
you saw the president love field pick up
the story there yeah and and we just
jumped in our car and we
like i say the parade route was uh
published so we just uh tried to get
ahead of the parade you know and uh
we ended up uh
behind the uh school book depository we
didn't
we didn't park behind the school but
depository building but we were one or
two buildings across
and up from it across houston street
and we walked to the intersection of
houston street and elm
and there was a large crowd of people
there and there was people lined up
along m street toward going towards the
truffle underpass
and we just walked in behind the crowd
on the sidewalk and
fell in beside the last two people that
were against the curb
and
as i recall it was two women and we just
fell inside them and
had been there a short time when you
could
you could hear the uh
the group the parade coming down main
street and uh
i can remember president's car turning
right onto houston street
from maine and going that short block
and turning left on
on how and coming towards us
did you uh did you speak to anyone or
have any
conversation with anybody as you walked
by or where you were standing in your
spot
i don't i don't think so um
we may have nodded her something at the
two women or something but i i don't
recall us uh i don't recall myself
speaking to anyone as we walked along
before the
uh
cars got to the intersection of maine in
houston you could tell that they were
nearby
from the from the knowledge of the crowd
in those few brief moments before the
assassination
for the the motorcade arrived did you
notice anyone in the the crowd of
vicinity that that stuck out in your
mind the the woman across the street
that was wearing the red raincoat or
abraham zapruder up on the pedestal did
anyone stick in your head prior to the
assassination
well i i remember seeing mr ceruta
and i think maybe gail can recall
later us talking about it
there was a local man here uh
um
oil names yeah
and he was a very wealthy individual and
he was
he was a little bit flamboyant i guess
you might say and
and
like i saw a similarity i kind of
thought that was oil nems maybe standing
up there you know so it was
that
this is all after the fact but uh well
you said that when we first walked up we
looked around you said oh i think that's
oil now i'm standing back up there yeah
and um
and uh so
so uh
as it turned out of course it wasn't
it's mr serpruder but
but
that that's who i thought it was at the
time and i guess after that the thought
run through my mind you know maybe
that's where the shot came from or
something but
but um
anyway
it turned out it wasn't was not mr nams
well that's interesting i've never i've
never heard that have you ever told that
before
well i'm sure i'm sure i have uh
i didn't mean to hold it back from you
but
but
but i i guess it's pretty insignificant
really
well
the impressions that people have prior
to the assassination are always
interesting just to see what they
noticed what stuck out in their mind
before the before the car pass
well i do want to get from both of your
individual impressions of the actual
assassination so whoever would like to
go first again go ahead okay yeah yeah
maybe go first
okay
well
like i said stephen i can remember the
president's car turning on damn street
and
we were on the curb's edge
and the president's car was out one lane
from the curb he was not
in the curb lane
and when he was probably 100 feet or so
from us the first two shots rang out
and i can remember hearing a boom
boom about like that and
i
i thought somebody had thrown a couple
of firecrackers or something beside the
president's car i didn't not recognize
it even to be gunfire
and i can remember the thought of you
know that's a pretty poor joke somebody
do something like that and
present his hands came up and
and i
actually testified that day that he came
up out of his seat which in reality just
more or less
uh
uh he didn't stand up but he just
throwed his arms up kind of raised up in
his seat
as the car got closer to us
uh i could see
governor connolly and i could see his
protruding eyes and
you could see the blood on his shirt and
his out stretched
in in the car and
just as the president got
straight in front of us which is the
width of that one lane we were right on
the curb and just as he got straight out
from the curb from us the third shot
rang out
and i can remember seeing the side of
president kennedy's head come off and uh
and i
i thought his ear came off and i had
testified to that effect but years later
i saw a picture that showed otherwise
but
i can remember seeing a
flash of white
and then the red
blood and
he went across the car seat over into
mrs kennedy's lap and
i can remember her hollering out oh my
god no they've shot jack
and i turned to gail and i said gayle
that's it hit the ground
because
at that time i thought the shots had
come
straight over the top of our heads from
behind
and which we were probably in greater
danger if the shots came from the sixth
floor window we were probably in greater
danger on the first two shots than we
actually were on the third
and uh we covered our children
and uh you know i can remember hitting
the ground and seeing some sob shot the
president and uh
uh that's that's you know pretty well it
we stayed on the ground two or three
minutes
and uh before we stood up just to be
sure that
something else was not going to happen
but
but
that's pretty much what i recall
can i get your impression okay
uh
like bill said we could hear the roar of
the crowd as they
turned on uh to come down
m street
and uh
my uncle was a police sergeant and he
was leading the motorcade so that was
another thing that we were anxious the
kids were always real fond of uncle
steve
and uh
so i'm sure that i was probably
bending over
talking to the children you know
pointing out that's there there comes
uncle steve on his motorcycle and
everything and here comes the president
and uh like bill said the first two
shots
sounded like firecrackers to me i'd
never been around gunfire so i you know
had nothing to compare it with
but
the way he reacted i thought
that man's got a sense of humor you know
someone
doing something like that is such bad
taste
and
then as the car approached and got
directly in front of us that third shot
rang out and just the visual
you could see bits of flesh flying up in
the air and in
uh red a white mass and then red you
know coming out of his head
i heard
jackie kennedy
scream out also and we turned and put
the children on the grass behind us and
and shielded them with our body because
we were afraid you know that that we
were fixing to get shot
you know it's just very
unnerving
and
um bill was looking towards the the
direction that the car drove off and i
was just
sort of looking
uh up towards the uh
concrete embankment there behind the
grassy knob
did either of you um
try to watch the car out of the corner
of your eye and see
jackie climb onto the back
you saw that yeah i saw her climb on the
back i
what i thought was happening steven i
thought she was trying to get out of the
car at the moment
and i guess the reality of it was she
was trying to aid the secret service man
over into the car you know one of them
came running from the
uh car behind and jumped jumped into the
car and i think she reached out
for him and he came over and pushed
pushed her down i guess in the
floorboard and they
zoomed off
um
during the actual assassination itself
were you both focused primarily on the
president
i was yes
you didn't notice any of the other
people around you or anything like that
you didn't see the man with the umbrella
a little further down the street
anything like that no
i i don't recall
seeing the umbrella man like i say from
the time
the car turned from maine on to houston
street
you know my focus was on on the
on the president's car as it approached
so it was more it was a reality it was
probably more like i had blinders on
because
uh
i had no idea of what was fixing to
occur
and
my attention was on the president's car
you you said you noticed connelly's eyes
and then saw the blood on his shirt did
you see um did you see his his hand did
you see him holding his uh station hat
at all
not i don't recall seeing the hat
i recall him being stretched out and
kind of holding himself it seemed like
his arms were stretched out and he was
sort of stretched out in the
in the car and
laid out so to speak
i don't recall the hat i've seen i've
seen pictures of the hat and i know
about
him holding the hat and the first and
second shot you know that
where they were hit by the same bullet
or not but
but i don't recall the hat at the time
you were you're both thinking things to
yourself during the
shooting did you do you recall ever
saying anything verbally to one another
other than hit the ground
um i don't recall that it happened so
quickly you know you really didn't have
time to
to
say anything you know it just the first
two shots and then the next thing you
know he's right in front of you and that
third shot rings out you know it's just
a matter of uh seconds
and then there was so much confusion you
know we i basically was was terrified
because i you know i was afraid that
uh
bill or the children you know might get
get hurt it just you know the thought
flashed in my mind what what hap what
would happen if if something happened to
you know my two children or bill
um
how
long did the entire thing in your
opinion at the time did it seem like it
took for the from the first noise the
firecracker sound to the final shot how
long did it seem to take for the entire
sequence
to take place well not very long i mean
it you know i'm going to say less than a
minute uh you know probably
20 seconds or
something but i'd say certainly
something way under a minute
and then it didn't seem like a great
time span
it it was however long it took that
vehicle to travel at some hundred feet
or whatever it may be
so it was a very short period of time
did you see the brake lights come on on
the vehicle well
yeah that's uh
as i look back at the car i could see
the two men in the in the front of the
car the driver and the man on the
passenger side
uh and i can remember one of them and
and i cannot sit here and tell you
stephen for certain which one had the
telephone i want to say the the one on
the passenger side had a look appeared
like a telephone or a mic to his ear and
and and as i looked back
i i remember the cause as it had already
passed it seemed like the car
momentarily stopped
now i've been told the car never stopped
moving
but i i believe it did and when i say
stop i mean for a very short period of
time they got on the brakes
it hit the brakes it kind of rocked so
to speak and then they floorboarded it
and accelerated out of there but it it
did seem to me that i recall
seeing the taillights and for a very
short moment there it was momentarily
stopped
and then they floorboarded it and went
out uh through the triple underpass
under the triple underpass
so i i do recall that and that's a
little bit i've never found confirmation
of that
you know i don't know that this zurpruda
film shows that
and i've never had that confirmed
but i feel like that did occur
but but
in saying stopped
i don't mean they stopped and
ate a ham sandwich i mean you know it
was a very short time span
um i want to go ahead and move along to
after the assassination we might as we
move on we might come back to various
aspects of that
but we'll go ahead and move forward um
of course
there's so many famous photographs of
the two of you laying on the ground
covering your children were you aware of
photographers taking your picture as you
were laying on the ground yes can you
can you talk about that what it
what you're thinking
well you know at the time
i was thinking what are those fools
doing standing up there i mean we were
not on that on the ground for that long
long period of time we were on the
ground for uh
two or three minutes maybe not for a
very long period
and
it kind of surprised me that someone
would run up and take our
photograph
but uh
we we did stand up a lot when you look
at those pictures now it looks like
we're the only sometimes it looks like
we're the only ones at the assassination
site when you look at us laying on the
ground and it looks like we're posing to
have our picture made but apparently
these people were just across the street
or very nearby
and
after the car moved out
they ran across the street and started i
think some of
them uh
press bus or something that was in the
motorcade and they jumped out yeah they
they may have they may have
because they just kind of appeared on
the scene and uh that's probably true
they probably were in the in the
motorcade
did any of them try to talk to you did
anyone try to talk to you
well the two local people came up to us
while you were still on the ground no no
we no no we had
had stood up uh
no no one tried to talk to us on the
ground and like i say
uh we were not on the ground for a long
period of time
when you look when you're going through
a book and looking at the pictures uh
it seems a little odd to me that we're
the only ones on the ground but
then you'll see other photographs where
you'll you'll you'll notice that people
are down
did you see anyone um dallas police or
anyone official uh that were going up
the uh grassy knoll well i i can
remember seeing some men
run up the grassy knoll and they had
what i'm gonna call like thompson
submachine guns or something
and here again this is a little bit like
the break
story uh
and it's unconfirmed but it seemed to be
like the car behind the president where
the secret service men were standing on
the running board it seemed to me like
they
behind the convertible top
as i looked back they flipped over and
they grabbed
some of these these rifles or
submachine guns or whatever they may
have been you know they didn't look like
hunting rifles they were they were sharp
and uh and
a couple of them
ran up
the what we call the grassy knoll now
they ran up and over you know looking
for someone
it's my understanding
somewhere
it's my understanding that no secret
service people left the motorcade
you know maybe these people were fbi or
maybe there was somebody else but
i have the impression that some people
left
that
vehicle
and ran up the embankment
but i was pretty shook up and pretty
excited
when it happened i mean it kind of it
was overwhelming for us or it was
overwhelming for me
at that at that moment
and
there uh there is some news footage that
i've seen that that shows you right
afterwards still on the ground and you
are pounding the uh the ground with your
fist you said you recalled that that
moment yeah i could i can recall that
and he didn't recall what he said for a
long time i
had to
clue him in on that you remembered that
i remembered that yes uh-huh
yeah and you were just angry
yeah yeah i just i guess just
frustrations and that's just the way it
came out and
you know
as you can tell from our interview when
they carried us to
wfaa we were we were pretty shook up and
i
i tell you what i think i shook up the
whole day if not for a
couple of days
yeah i want to talk about the wfaa
interview
right before you um
before we get to that though before you
stood up did you say anything to each
other while you were on the ground no
nothing
not that i recall
how did you decide to stand up
i believe bill said it's okay and you
know everybody
was rushing towards the railroad tracks
behind the concrete
wall
and uh
you know we didn't hear any other
gunshot or anything so we we
uh
just stood up and stood there just for a
couple of seconds and then we started
walking up the grassy know
and that's when
jay watson and jerry haines
with
wfia
approached us and i asked bill you know
what we had seen
did you think about
where were you headed you were heading
up the grassy know were you going to
follow everyone out i think so i mean i
think we're just kind of
going that way to
see if it caught somebody or what what
was going on
i have i have a gary mac question here
oh boy
okay there there is um
a bit of confusion over
the the the men that approached you and
then you getting over to wfaa
um
in a 1964 interview jay watson
said that he did not come and approach
you
at nd lee plaza that when he heard the
shots he saw you laying on the ground
and he told jerry haynes
go get those people and he went on back
to the studio
that's not the way i remember it okay
and and another
another aspect to that is there was a
reporter a wfa radio reporter named
pierce allman does that name ring any
bells with you i know who pierce almond
is i don't remember remember i know he
was
there
but i i don't know that from the day of
assassination i know it from
from years later well there was a radio
interview uh with with peers from either
the day of the assassination or the day
after and he mentions you by name saying
that he spoke to you on the grassy knoll
and that he was the man who drove you to
wfaa do you recall that at all
well
i recall that two people carried us to
wfaa
i mean there's two people approached us
and and i recall that one of them was
jerry haynes
i cannot definitely tell you who the
second person was
so
i mean i can't dispute
mr allman i can't dispute what he's
saying gail may be able to i know there
were two men
and uh and jerry haines asked us what we
saw and we told him
and he said would you come with us to
wfaa and we said that we would and we
started in that direction
and either on main street or commerce
can you recall which was on houston and
maine houston and maine he stopped a car
he walked up to a car because there was
traffic jam you know things were just
and he asked this man he said these
people saw the president
uh shot
would you mind carrying us to wfaa and
he said no sure and we got in the car
with him and and we rode to wfaa
so you know just to dispute
what either one of those two men said
i i i just simply can't recall
i can recall that two men walked up to
us and i can recall that one of them was
jerry haynes because he was a
local personality as mr peppermint
and he wasn't a
local personality here
you know and i definitely remember him
but you know you you do think jay watson
was was one of them
i was thinking that uh this has never
come up before i was thinking that it
was who it was
i remember meeting pierce almond a few
years ago
and
he was
jerry haynes was a tall person and i was
thinking that the other person that was
with mr haynes was also tall
excuse me pierce almond never indicated
that
when we met him he never indicated that
he
he had talked to us someone oh well this
was this was from an interview that just
recently surfaced that was done either
the evening of the assassination or the
next day now bill
talked
on on the wfa radio
the day of the assassination i did not
go to the radio
area with him and he talked with someone
uh at the radio uh you know that day
well it's it's a minor point but it's
you know it's part of his well yeah i
can't dispute in other words yeah i
can't say for sure i couldn't dispute
either one of them
uh
we do know of course there's records of
jay
interviewing us uh at the studio
i mean that's undisputed but
uh whether he was the other second man
at the
at the assassination side or whether he
wasn't
i mean he should know and uh
i i just can't recall who the second
person was i just know there was two of
them
i remember the fella on the radio if i
remember he was a big tall fella that
later became an actor
uh
on the monsters or or one of the
programs he was a
a giant you know about a seven foot tall
guy that interviewed me at the radio
station
okay and this was the day of the
assessment yes uh after we went off the
air
and and gail can
probably be best that she'd tell you
about
the show that was going on at the time
you know and
but after they interviewed us and
before we went to the sheriff's office
they i had a short interview on the on
the uh air
at the radio station which was nothing
but in just another room at the studio
and then uh
then after that they carried us to
sheriff bill decker's office and
gail and i are two of 16 people that
gave affidavits that day to the
sheriff's department
i want to talk a little bit about your
experience at wfaa because that that
interview is such an important part of
the story and i believe you're the first
two eyewitnesses that went live on on
television um can you describe just the
general atmosphere when you walked into
the studio there as people were just
beginning to hear the news can you just
describe what what you were seeing when
you walked in
well
i think people were kind of disturbed
and and
you know a little bit shook up and
what to do they
they broke into the was it the julie
bonnell show
they broke into her program and
and put us on the air i mean i
i think there was a little bit of a
hustle bustle or disturbance about it i
can't
you know i can't remember in detail but
uh
we were there a few minutes before they
actually put us on the air i don't i
evidently they were having to get
clearance
from washington d.c or you know
to be sure that lyndon johnson had been
in a secure
uh place before they
announced what had happened i mean
that's what i think
the when we walked in the julie benell
show was was underway
and you know we sort of stood out to the
side and uh
and then they asked us to come over and
sit at this little area that they
quickly put together
and uh
they broke into her her program
how were your kids doing during this um
[Music]
i don't really you know i mean just
excitement i don't think that
that uh i know clayton doesn't remember
anything at all
and uh i think that they were probably
you know
a little in awe and maybe a little
afraid and and because i mean we were
quite excited and nervous and scared and
you know a lot of emotions rolled into
one
stephen um something that i can recall
is me making the statement
you know someone's saying what happened
outside well i saw the president shot in
the head
and then a few moments after i said that
now this we weren't on the air at this
time but a few moments after i said that
someone's saying someone else at studio
they said well we've got a report in
that the president's been shot in the
back or shot in the neck
and he's alive
and i was kind of dumbfounded to hear
these people saying that
and just
minutes earlier
i'd seen the side of his head come off
and the report was being fed back to him
that the president was at parkland
hospital and he was alive and
in the emergency room and had been shot
i don't know what coffee said in the
neck or the back you know it was kind of
puzzling to me
to hear that and then a few moments
later they come back with the
information that the president was dead
and had been shot in the head
and so
they put us on the air and we moved
forward from that but it kind of
dumbfounded me for me to make one
statement
and then hear something that sounded
contrary to what i had just
said said that i had seen
after after seeing what you had seen you
were pretty much convinced that the
president was dead
well i yes
yes
i mean i'm mortally wounded and now
i i wouldn't think that anybody could
live with the side of their head i mean
if you
if you would have seen it yeah i mean
there would be no question in your mind
that he was dead do you recall did you
mention to jerry haynes or jay watson or
anyone from wfaa did you mention to them
that you felt like the president was
dead when you when they first
encountered you
yeah well
that's that's i indicated at the studio
that i saw him shot in the head side of
his head blown off
and uh i don't recall saying
the presence dead you know i don't
recall
saying that statement but
when you see something the size of a
grapefruit or orange or something blow
out into the air
and then and then you hear the statement
he's he's
he's he's in an emergency he's been shot
in the back or whatever was said it just
kind of it dumbfounded me there
momentarily what else
uh
the way the report was coming in
but you don't recall being being told by
anyone to not say anything in particular
or not no no no no no we were not
schooled on what to say or what not to
say
that's important but but it just uh
i i think later on we we recognized that
there was a necessary delay there
before
in other words
i think
gail has said this that
they had to get clearance
to go on the air and to say the present
united states
had been assassinated or was dead and
here's two eyewitnesses to the
assassination there was a little bit of
a delay
not a long delay but like gail set up
five or ten minutes before they put us
on the air to get
get clearance to do so
so would you say that you were
live on the air within half an hour yeah
yeah oh yes i'd say
last yes
um during the the interview with jay
watson that he talks to both of you and
then you get a little upset and he sends
you off camera do you recall where you
went what you were doing when he while
he was talking to bill
uh yes i do
they kept trying to get me to drink
coffee and i've never been a coffee
drinker and i'm not to this day so uh i
took the boys because they were getting
a little restless uh you know i think
one of them in the uh
tape that that you have
says there's mr peppermint you know they
were excited about that so i took them
uh over to one side of the studio
and uh
julie bonnell was cooking a ham that day
harmel cure 81 ham
and they were
relatively new on the market
and she took me aside and she said let
me fix you fix a sandwich for your
children so she picked the boys a ham
sandwich while bill was still uh being
interviewed and we were you know over
in the same studio but over to one side
and then you were on the air for a
little while longer
and after your interview bill was done
what did you do after you left the
after you went off camera do you recall
well they asked me to go into the radio
studio
and they did a short interview there
and uh and then when when
i left there there was a sheriff's
deputy there was two of them two
sheriff's deputies
uh waiting on us and they asked us if we
would
go with them to uh to the sheriff's
office which we did and do you have any
idea what time that was when you were
done with your radio interview
a rough a rough guess
well
i i i would say it was um
a half hour to 45 minutes after the
assassination and when the assassination
was 12
something 12 12 30 12 30 so it you know
it could have been 1 30.
before too probably yeah
um when you arrived at wfa did you you
didn't see anyone any law enforcement
there
no no not
so did you ever find out how
these individuals knew you were there
and came up here
no
uh
no i i you know i never questioned that
uh like i say i was in a bit of a fog uh
i was pretty shook up
you know the best best that i can
remember they identified themselves they
were plain clothes when were they not
detectives
and they identified themselves and asked
us if we'd come with them
were you were you nervous at all about
about going with them or did you pretty
much no i was nervous but not about
going with them i was just just nervous
i didn't think we had any choice
okay we'll pick up the story from there
and uh just talk about giving doing your
affidavits
talk about being at the police station
there okay
uh well they they set us down and and
they of course they took our affidavits
separately i don't know if the same uh
interviewer or stenographer took
took gales that took mine
and we just sat there and and made a
statement
what we saw and they took it down and
and we signed it
or i signed it
and then they asked us to remain
there for a while and we actually stayed
in sheriff bill decker's office there
was a group of us in there i guess
conference room was that and i guess
maybe it was
the 16 of us and i'm using the number 16
and i i think i'm accurate on that
um
and we were just all there and the
reason they detanged us
was they were reading
these
different affidavits and they were
comparing one statement against the
other and they wanted us to stay there
in case there was conflict or
if they wanted to re-interview some of
us
to to ask us what we saw again so they
held us over and
it was it was dark when we left there
i remember they fed us bologna
sandwiches or something from the jail
and
and and were very courteous and nice to
us but we just spent a long period of
time there
i remember our children became somewhat
of a problem and
gail can tell you that
every few minutes she had to
take him somewhere and a guard had to go
with her i think
clayton was two and uh
we were potty training
he probably won't appreciate this being
on the tape but
you had to get uh uh officer to go with
you anytime that you left the conference
room
and uh
when he realized that that you had to
get permission well
he he wanted to leave the room about
every 10 minutes
so i called uh my father and he came and
picked the boys up i'm not sure exactly
what time probably 4 30 something like
that
and uh he took him home with him
and
uh you know we were hearing bits of
information uh while we were in the
conference room that they'd
you know caught who had uh
uh
killed the president and you know just
speculation and stuff like that there
was
sort of hustle bustle around
this was the uh this was the sheriff's
station in 1963 that was close to the
texas school book depository correct
yeah it was on houston and
in uh main street
or the jail where the old jail is it was
at that time
started caddy corner across yeah yeah
you remember um what what side of the
building you entered on this this this
has come up but we believe me it has do
you remember what side of the building
well i think we entered from main street
but you know honestly i can't recall but
i think the main street side is what
that what we entered from because we
were coming from that direction from the
studio but uh
you know i honestly can't tell you
uh i have another hard question for you
as you enter the building do you
remember
uh as you were walking in if you're
standing in the in the entrance you
remember in which direction bill
decker's office would have been
well
this is this isn't a gary mac question
it's not a gary mac it's it's another
welcome you know i can't tell you what
vehicle we even rode in over there in
but it seemed to me like we went into
the building
up some stairs just you know like a half
a level
and then straight in towards the center
of the buildings where was interviewed
and then his office would have been
back towards the school book depository
say
if houston street was north and south
i'd call it the northwest corner
does that can you visualize that yeah i
can kind of the northwest corner
area is what i would guess
that's that's good um
sometimes the layout of the of the
sheriff's office is comes under some
questions and so really i always try to
ask somebody who was in there were we
close well i i don't i don't know
i'm asking you to tell me yeah
we'll piece it together um
so you were in a room it was 16 of you
or so uh give or take um did you what
did you talk what'd you talk about
well we just said most of the time i can
remember one gentleman one individual
was near us
that
he seemed to be very
upset distraught
and and
i i had a few words with him
and apparently he was the man that was
in the building across from from where
we are now across houston
uh street daltech's building and he'd
gone in there to use the phone to call
his
employer to say that he was going to
miss his plane or looked like he's going
to miss his plane because of the traffic
congestion and he was not going to make
it to love field
and
he was there
and and he was rather upset
uh that he you know that he'd gotten all
uh caught up in this and and and he was
delayed
now
it's my understanding there's some kind
of controversy about that individual
over the years but
you know at the day that i was in there
talking with him he was just another
person in the room
and i understand there's some question
that has been some questions about that
individual over the years
but anyway i can remember that one
individual in there and him kind of
holding his head in his hands and
and he was a little bit distraught
and acted like he
needed to be somewhere else you
mentioned um that it was as if you were
living in a fog during that entire
period um when did the fog begin to lift
when did you start to have a realization
of what what had happened
and coming well
you know i think i think i had the
realization of what had happened from
the very onset
uh stephen but i it was i was young and
naive
and it was just something that just kind
of grabbed me and shook me up
and
you know i can't tell you if it was but
i was probably feeling better when they
turned us loose and we left the
sheriff's office
but like gail stated earlier we were
concerned
that someone might harm us
because of what we may have saw we
weren't aware of what any what that
might be but if we could
you know point somebody out in a lineup
or
something of that nature that we might
be a threat to someone and the fact that
we was a threat to someone might
meant that we would have come into some
harm you know
and like she has said about
we brought the kids into our room rather
than in in their own bedroom and we kept
them with us made she made pallets for
him or something on the floor
and we did that for several nights and
me laying a shotgun beside my bed you
know a 20 gauge shotgun
you know which is
silly
to think in terms that i was going to
defend my family with a 20 gauge shotgun
you know we were a real threat to
somebody
i don't think that 20-gauge shotgun
would have ever came into play
but uh
we were i was right i was rattled by it
and and i think it it had an effect on
me for several days but nothing ever
happened we've never been approached by
anyone in any way that i'm aware of that
you know to harm us
and of course some 40 years later
you you don't even
think like that but the first
first uh
few days or a few weeks
i was always kind of wondering if
something might happen
we we got on with our lives immediately
you know we had to go go to work
and make our way but uh
you know
i was 22 years old if if i'd have been
32 or 42
i might have packed my family up and got
in the car and drove and
stayed on vacation for a month you know
going somewhere other than staying
staying at home
you know and looking
you um back
spent the rest of that weekend i imagine
just watching television
we stayed pretty close
uh we we went to church
and you know while we were in church
they announced that that uh
oswald had shot jack ruby you know when
huh jack ruby had shot oscillator oh
excuse me yeah
uh
yes jack ruby shot oswald you know they
were they were preparing to make the
transfer from the dallas city municipal
jail to the dallas county jail and
and uh
ruby shotting
and we were i remember we were in church
when that occurred
um
earlier before we started filming this
interview
you made a
statement about a thought you had a
couple of days after the assassination
took place about something you might
have might have done that could have
changed things can you can you tell us
that story for the record here are you
sure what you don't put this on
well
well you know the president was so close
to us
the the thought had run through my mind
you know if i would have only pushed him
you know if i'd run out because he he
was within 10 or 12 feet of us probably
of course i'd had to made my move before
the trigger was pulled but you know if
myself or someone else had just pushed
him over
it might have gotten him out of harm's
way because
i think i'm correct that he had a back
brace on
and you know had the
back brace not been there it's possible
that when the first shot was fired the
first shot that hit him whichever one it
may have been
that he might have slumped and went down
in the car
and i tend to think that that
brace may have
uh aided in keeping him upright in in
the car
and so if he hadn't had that brace or if
myself or someone that was so close by
had just realized of course you see i
didn't even realize it was gunfire
as they got closer i realized something
was wrong when i saw governor connelly
but if we just pushed him pushed him
over and knocked him over in the car he
might have
you know he might have survived
and
so yeah that that thought did occur to
me but uh
um
yeah it didn't happen and and we also
left our eight millimeter uh moving
projector setting on our uh
dresser
and i thought boy if i'd only had that
movie director you know
a movie camera i'd had quite a film but
then i also thought
you know it may have saved my life that
i didn't have it because i could have
come to some harm or
or even the authorities may have thought
i was shooting at the president i could
have been standing out there with my
movie camera and it could appear that i
was shooting at the president so
it might have been in my best interest
that
that we forgot it
when did the
when did the interview start after wfaa
of course
not long
we started hearing from people i'm going
to say
within the month with new
gail i think probably in december first
yeah you know middle well it was that
long and we and we heard from a lot of
people
and uh different ones and
some of them were pretty kooky
and some of them of course were not i
mean but uh
the the early on interviews and people
we talked that i talked with on the
phone and some of the people that i met
with
kind of disturbed me a little bit
but but
as time went on
uh the interviews died off and then when
we started coming up towards the 25th
anniversary
23rd 24th year
then then it really picked up again
and
we've always been willing to give an
interview because
we've recognized that the
the research and the study of the
president kennedy's assassination will
be an ongoing thing you know
certainly through our lifetime and
probably for
many many more years to come
two parts the first half can be viewed
on our website cspan.org
the following program is 45 minutes
okay we're starting tape number two with
the newman's uh you were
talking about some of the interviews you
had given after the assassination you i
kind of cut you off mid thought there
but you were talking about why you
continue to
get oh oh yeah um
stephen i i can remember wes wise the uh
uh
past mayor of dallas
saying to me uh in an interview he said
you know said
billy the
the lincoln assassination people are
still studying it today
and he said
they'll be studying it for many more
years to come and same thing with
president kennedy's assassination
because early on i
in my mind the question was
why don't people put this to bed i mean
why don't why don't we quit you know
uh
all this um
talking about it
but the reality of it is it's gonna be
an ongoing process from now on
throughout my life and probably for many
many many years afterwards
that people are going to be interested
in
and trying to reach the conclusion of
what happened and why it happened and so
i've resolved myself to
to to recognize that
every so often someone's going to
want to interview us
and i would not want to be interviewed
every day in which of course that's not
going to happen but
but
most of the people 99 of the people this
day and time that interview
are
sincere individuals that's trying to do
some worthwhile work
and whether it's an amateur or
professional
interviewer
i think
i think it's worthwhile and and
the fact that gail and myself are part
of it
uh
we're going to
accept the fact that people want to
interview us
and so
we're willing to do so
we're certainly not looking for people
to interview us but
we're willing to be interviewed well i
certainly appreciate you taking all this
time to talk to me for this particular
interview
going back
to uh right after the assassination when
was the first official
uh law enforcement interview did when
did the official agencies come and talk
to you
well
after uh after our
the day of the assassination
uh it was a
a day or two or so later and i can't
tell you gail can you recall when the
fbi came to our home this is sunday that
uh when we came home from church they
were they were there they were there
yeah so
the the assassination was on a friday so
that sunday we were interviewed by two
fbi agents
and they just
more or less asked us you know what we
saw where we were at and so forth and
they had our statements from the
sheriff's office and you know they were
just reviewing
what we had stated there
and
they didn't make any notes or anything
like that
and and they were very cordial people
you know there was nothing
abnormal about it i mean they just
just simply wanted to uh i guess like
gail said they want to review our
affidavits and
and see if we had any changes or
any of the thoughts
and it probably lasted they probably uh
interviewed us for about 30 minutes
in the warren commission in 1964 they
did not talk to you correct
no they did not
why do you think that was
any thoughts
well
i don't know if this is a thought or not
but i've been it's been said that the
reason
that they did not interview us was
because we did not say directly that the
shots came from the sixth floor
from the school book depository
but uh in talking with uh
with the man that uh
interviewed us for the movie uh
uh the trial of lee harvey oswald the
distant district attorney or assistant
district attorney in los angeles what
was the man's name gail
boogalowsi
yeah and i know i i know i'm
mispronouncing the man's billy oscar
julio
i know i'm probably mispronouncing his
name but
he said that was not true that in in the
warren commission they did
interview individuals that said
otherwise and thought the shots came
from somewhere else
but we were just told that and
and
i
i'm really surprised that they did not
interview us
but uh i guess they didn't see the need
to because we were so close to we were
so close to president kennedy on the
third shot
but no they did not interview us and the
explanation that i was giving and it was
not an official explanation
was because we did not
confirm or endorse that we thought
shots came from the school board
depository
uh on wp wfaa that day during your
interview you you mentioned that you
felt the shots came from directly behind
you and you mention a mall or a garden
which
seems to be referring to the
grassy embankment grassy knoll
but but now you seem to be more
feeling that it was just a general
direction behind you well i i thought it
came from straight behind me now it's
it's left up to
to the
assassination buff or the i guess the
interviewer to interpret
but
what i try not to do
if i'm talking to a group of
people or and i make the statement
then i thought the shot came from behind
the shot meaning the head shot
it was a visual impact that it had on me
more so than the noise
seeing the side of the president's head
blow off
see the president go across the car seat
into mrs kennedy's lap in her direction
it gave me the sensation that the shots
were coming from directly behind where i
was standing
so i say behind
and i leave it at that and then a lot of
times the interviewer whoever it may be
will say
behind to your left meaning the school
bug depository behind your right meaning
the big picket fence
and i just leave it i won't define it i
won't define but i think it came more to
the right or i won't say that it came
more to my left
because really and truly i think that
i think that
the most honest
uh
statement i can make is leave it with
behind
because of the visual impact that it had
on me when president kennedy went across
the seat
if i thought it came
from
the sixth floor i'd most definitely tell
tell you so if i thought it came from
the picket fence i'd
certainly tell you so but i just the
reality of is that i don't know
i just know that
that a shot was fired inside
uh
president kennedy's head came off i was
asked earlier today
to define
the difference in the sound of the shots
from the first two to the third
and and i can't do that
i mean i can't tell you
which ones were louder
or not
it just because at the time the first
two shots were fired
i didn't even even define that as as
gunshot
you know so
so
i was thinking in terms of someone
throwing firecrackers beside the car
and i think it's been proven
that you could
at that location where we were at
that by the sound alone you could not
define where they actually came from
you know
did you pretty much have the same
impression that it was
a general behind
behind you area
uh yes
and mine is just visual you know the
impact at the other side of his head and
and the way he fell over
uh i had no idea really
just the visual is
my opinion
um it seems in based on just some of
your early interviews and something you
said earlier in in this interview it
almost seems like rather than the the
picket fence area the the more specified
area that you were talking about was
really kind of where abraham's intruder
was standing in that that general area
is that
i know you i know
i know i'm not i'm not trying to be a
normal a normal interviewer um gary
actually mentioned to me that in a in an
interview he had sing with you in the
past that's what i was leading up to
that in a photo that you had been shown
a photograph and you were actually asked
to point to where you thought the shots
had come from and you did not point to
the fence you pointed more to the the
the concrete pergola where the cruder
was so that would be more in the in
between area right so i guess but if you
want me to define it a little closer
that would be a little closer to the
picking fence as opposed to being closer
to the school that deposits you i just
want to get your impressions yeah
and i'm interested in how
you've you've interpreted that through
the years through the 40 years of
interviews and how well
that's why i try to leave it with behind
because at the day that i pointed
i may have pointed like so
and then if i'd have been there the next
day i may have pointed like so
so that would have been a little close
so but i mean i didn't see a muzzle
flash
and i really wasn't focused on the noise
it was just the sudden shock of seeing
the present hit in the head
and the impression that it came from
behind
so that's
and i know what you're saying and i know
you're not trying to lead me
but
if people are going to view this tape i
i don't want to
to
leave this tape with the impression that
i think it was a little more
skewed one way than it was skewed the
other
because like i say
i think it was the visual impact that
really registered
you know
to tell you whether i heard a noise or
not
we might could have a big discussion on
whether i even heard a noise
you know you could say
bill did you actually hear a noise
and it might be difficult for me to
testify
that i heard a noise
you know
but i think the shot
came from behind
because of uh and i'm sure there was a
noise
but
to define that noise or to pinpoint
exactly where it came from i can't do
that
well we'll just leave it like that good
all right
um after the warren commission i guess
the next real involvement you had with
anything related to the assassination
was the jim garrison trial um you both
testified in that trial correct yes
can i just get each of you to give me
your brief uh
interpretation of those events and
what what kind of a man jim garrison was
and what it was like testifying that
kind of thing
well i went down uh
earlier than bill did i went down
uh it was either friday or saturday i
can't remember now
and bill had the flu we were supposed to
go down together and
i went down by myself
and
was met at
the airport in
new orleans by
a deputy
officer of the law
and he took me
and
checked me into a hotel i didn't spend
the night but they checked me into
hotels so that i could
sort of freshen up before time to go to
the courthouse
and
they came by and picked me up and drove
me to the courthouse and
and i went in and
was sworn in and
basically all they asked me is where we
were were standing at the time of the
assassination there it was not
uh too many questions you know my name
and etc
and where we were standing and who was
with us and what we saw you know
and uh
nothing in any great detail and then i
was dismissed
and uh then bill went down on a monday
and uh i let him tell his story okay but
before he tells his story
was there a small little controversy
involving
something to do with a crossfire that
appeared in the newspaper or something
like that do you recall that an
article in a newspaper that referred to
you that said that you allegedly had
said there was a crossfire well i i said
i was afraid that we might be in a
crossfire i didn't say that there was a
crossfire but that was misinterpreted
yes it was
also i was in the taxi cab with uh mr
and mrs zapruder and another gentleman
and they were driving us not a taxi cab
a bag reporting a police officer's car
you know detective's car they were
driving us back to the airport and we
were almost
hit by a tractor-trailer truck and they
said boy this would make good headline
news you know kennedy assassination
witnesses
you know killed in louisiana was it a
conspiracy and so you were in the car
with with abraham's approval yes i and
his wife
did you
talk to them at all about anything not a
whole lot i mean
you'd have to to sort of
know me i i was quite shy
and
i think that was my first airplane trip
and it was my first trip by myself you
know i was nervous i had to take a taxi
cab from home to love field and i was
scared you know that i was going to get
lost and and they told me
had told me when i got off the airport
off the plane in new orleans not to
go with anyone until they showed me
their id
you know and that sort of
worried me a little bit so
i was just a little naive i was you know
just a young housewife and
but in my later years i think i've
probably bloomed a little bit
and real quick just your impression of
jim garrison i didn't see jim garrison
oh okay
you know did they tell you uh
it'd be two officers
at the airport pick you up
i remember them telling me that as adds
a little mistake to it that
they said now when you get off playing
western when there'll be two officers
and said they'll show you
their identification and said if it's
one officer if it's three offers if it's
something other than two officers and
they fail to show you show their
identification where you could turn
around walk away from them
so that no they didn't they didn't tell
me that they just said be sure that they
show me to show
the identification
and
so i
was
sure that i saw identification
why don't you tell me about your
experience in the jim garrison trial and
your impressions of jim garrison okay
uh well
uh like gail said i had the flu and i i
recovered from it i believe it was that
following monday that that i flew to new
orleans they subpainted us uh and they
paid for our uh
accommodations and and fly there and
back
but i i think in reality i'm not sure
that subpoena would have stood up you
know when a texas court is a state of
louisiana subpoena
but
that monday
that following monday i went to
to new orleans and and
mr garrison
two two officers picked me up and
carried me to mr garrison's office
and he more or less he interviewed me he
asked me the questions in his office
that uh
that he was gonna ask me on the stand
and i can remember
one of the questions uh he was asking i
was telling him about the president
going across the seat in the car you
know in other words he didn't fall
forward and he didn't fall backwards
he fell across it was my interpretation
of it
and i can remember him saying he went
across and i said yeah i just like
somebody shoved him or pushed him and he
said you mean like somebody hit him with
a baseball bat and i said yeah just like
he'd been hit and just thrown across
the car yeah like he'd been hit with a
baseball bat and he said guys that's
good that's good
so uh
i think it was the next
day that i actually
testified in court
and
and i was put on the sworn in put on the
stand
and it's basically the same routine
gail described
we went to a mock-up
of the assassination scene pointed out
where i was standing and
and he asked me a few questions and
and uh
i can remember uh you know answering the
question about the head shot
and and i failed to say
that he flew across the seat
of the car you know like he'd been hit
with a baseball bat and i remember jim
garrison looking at me and saying
mr newman is there anything else that
you recall there's anything else you'd
like to say
and i said no and then he said you're a
witness
and
just as that was said it dawned on me
what he was wanting me to say he was
wanting me to recall that statement you
know as if he'd been hit by a baseball
bat
and uh and then of course
clay shaw's attorney
asked me a couple of questions and that
was it
but i was there again i was overwhelmed
when i went in that courtroom because
people were packed in there like
sardines
in that courtroom it was just jam-packed
was it jam-packed when you were in there
and it was hot in there and of course
when you're testifying in a trial they
just bring you in there for that segment
for your testimony and then you're
shuffled right back out
and that's and i never recall seeing
clay shaw
and i probably got as close to him as i
am to you because you know they were
sitting
not far from us but i don't ever even
remember seeing the man in that
courtroom it was just filled with
reporters if the seating capacity was
100 it must have been 200 people in
there
and so there again i got a little shook
up again and another remark i'd like to
make about
mr garrison
you recall the movie jfk
the oliver stone movie
well kevin kosner
the role that he played in that movie
he seemed to me kind of like an outsider
looking in kind of like a young
district attorney and the system was
sort of pushing against him rather than
working for him you know
and
that was the opposite impression that i
had a jim garrison i mean jim garrison
seemed to me like a
powerful
individual very much in the know very
much in control of
of his actions and
what was going on in the legal system in
new orleans i got just kind of a
opposite impression of him
in life as he was portrayed in that
movie
and i don't necessarily
mean that as a criticism
but uh
that that was something that stood out
in my mind about the movie jfk that the
way i saw it there was no
comparison with the role that was played
versus
the man that i met i couldn't i couldn't
see the similarity between the two
well you were the first person that jim
garrison yeah the assistant district
attorneys had interviewed the other
people on the stand
bill was the first person that jim
garrison had uh interviewed so
i think there was a lot of facts in the
movie i think y'all i think you had to
be nearly a research type
individual of of the assassination
to pick up all the facts because the
movie moved so fast you know in such a
short time frame but
that's the one thing that did stand out
in my mind was uh
was the
the way jim garrison was portrayed
i i didn't view that as the man that i
met
well since we're kind of segwaying into
jfk here can i get you to just talk
about your involvement meeting oliver
stone and
just that that story for me if you would
well
we we uh
we we were asked
to come to his hotel and and for him to
interview us and which we did and
and
he he interviewed us uh but but he
didn't have a lot of time for us you
know i mean he was kind of
tired and and
and kind of wanted to get us on through
and out of the way
and
he's probably a great guy he gave us
two free passes to the
premier showing of the movie but
but
i was not taken with him
now i'm sure that's going to break his
heart to know that i was not taking it
with him but he's probably in reality a
very nice man but
that particular day and that particular
moment
he didn't strike me as
is a
very friendly fella
can i get your
oliver stone didn't get wouldn't give me
the time of day you know he didn't he
didn't want to hear anything that i said
yeah you know he he chatted with bill
for a little bit and then we were
dismissed
yeah yeah
but you know i think
i think making movies
is one thing
i shouldn't hit that table
i think i think making movies is one
thing and
in in
documentaries or
research is entirely another
and i understand that i mean it's i
think anybody that's written a book that
they make a movie out of i don't think
the arthur that book is too well pleased
in most cases with the with the movie
because uh because really
it's just a sampling of the
and and i think jf the movie jfk was
just a sampling of the assassination you
know
were you uh here in dealey plaza during
any of the filming that was done
we we came down one one afternoon and uh
they uh
we met the two characters that played
our our parts and we also had the
opportunity to meet uh kevin kosner
which
gail got a big thrill out of that
and kevin costner was a real gentleman i
mean he was very cordial and
and and very nice to us and
nothing rushed about it
well he was interested to to talk to you
to see how jim garrison
conducted himself when when
yeah
but i thought he was very collegial oh
yeah he was very very nice and uh
in uh in the movie um
your character has a has a brief
speaking role if i remember correctly
right
he's
seen saying some of the same things you
said on your wfaa interview
if memories oh
yeah
i can't quote it something about they
shot the president or something right
there and i think he does mention what
you said about his ear coming off if i'm
right it's been a while since i've seen
jake and it's been a while for us
but overall what did you think of the uh
the way in which your characters were
portrayed in the film well he was a nice
looking guy they were nice looking
actors and actors i'll say that farm i
was well pleased with their appearance
and uh and i thank the man i can't name
him but he's on a
tv series now
you know that's a very small bit part
for him and i think he's moved up in the
acting profession
well um
let's see backing up just a little bit
were either of you talked to by the
house select committee on assassinations
i was not
i think they called uh one day and i
chatted with them for a few minutes but
uh you know nothing
no
personal meeting or
or anything like that
i don't even recall you know they just
wanted to know if i had anything
additional to add to
you know our sworn testimony
and um
but just a very short conversation
so the as far as the official
investigations go other than your
affidavits given that day
and then the brief follow-up interview
by the fbi that has satisfied all of the
official inquiries where on the
other end of it the research ends you've
been interviewed probably hundreds of
times by outside researchers that's
that's i'd say that's correct yeah does
that strike you is odd or interesting
that the the government is satisfied
with your 1963 statements while
you're you're constantly being
interviewed today by outside researchers
well
stephen i don't know if i find that odd
or not
what i have
recognized over the years
is that the outside research people
know exactly what i'm going to say
they can quote it if not nearly correct
me in an interview
but they simply want to hear it from us
they want to hear the words come out
even though
they know what we're going to say
and
so
maybe from the official point of view
it's documented on record what we
saw or thought was well that day
and that's probably the purest that
affidavit is probably the purest
form
of what we saw of the assassination
because sometimes it's difficult for me
to keep separated what i think you asked
me what i think
uh well there's lots of opinions out
there and some of them sound pretty good
to me
but i always try an in an interview like
this especially this one that that's
that people are going to check out and
listen to what the two of us have to say
i try to keep it narrowed down to what i
actually recall that day
and i'm sure this interview today
is not as good an interview
as we could have had
the day after the assassination
but but i try to maintain as much
accuracy as i can
possibly recall
and so
maybe from an official point of view
what we had to say that day
is more important than what we
might say in an interview 40 years later
okay
um
i know you've uh taken many trips over
the years uh to do a variety of
interviews but i know that one in
particular that i've heard you mentioned
uh several times in the past was the
trip to london for the the trial of lee
harvey oswald if i get you to comment on
that experience for me and also who you
met when you were there various people
well it was a very good experience for
us it
because he gave us a vacation and it
gave us some place to go that otherwise
we probably never would have
had a chance to to go to london and and
how many days were we there gail 14 days
or about two weeks something something
like 14 days
and of that 14 days we were just on
standby the whole time except for a half
of a day that
that they brought us into the studio and
we
participated in the
in the movie
uh
we
we met
the attorney
uh
that was the defense attorney
for the uh for for oswald what was his
name uh
you recall his name
sort of a western
well anyway we met him you know he he
was kind of colorful guy and maybe his
name will come to you in just a minute
but uh
he he had western clothes on kind of
indian indian jewelry and this stuff and
he was staying in the savoy hotel
in london which uh i guess it's a
five-star hotel and that's that's where
he
sat down and
interviewed us prior to our
participation in movie which
our participation in the movie was me
coming forth and testifying on the stand
and uh so
that that was a good experience and uh
and then we met
i met
the fbi man uh that was here in dallas
uh trustee
mr toasty mr toasty
you recall the name toasty
postie
that's correct mr holstein i met him and
he was an interesting gentleman and
and then we met
one of the corpsmen
that uh he was orderly or something that
was involved in the uh
autopsy of
of president kennedy uh
lives in florida uh
okay
while we're
we met paul o'connor and
and so
and and we also met the fellow that you
mentioned earlier today
that worked here at the school bug
depository uh
well the girl of oswald to work yeah
wesley frazier yeah wesley fraser i
think they called him junior didn't you
yeah i think so didn't we
meet sarah wick
yeah we met sarah wick you know so we
met we met a lot of the characters or
people that over the years had
it had some
involvement
with the
assassination
so it it was a
very enjoyable trip for me
another of the
important interviews that you gave or
important
documentaries that you participated in
was the men who killed kennedy
uh which is probably the quintessential
documentary that's been done on the
assassination can you talk a little bit
about uh
about that experience
well
we became acquainted with nigel turner
and uh
it was a good experience
he stayed in our home
quite a few nights you know and we we
assisted him we picked him up at the
airport and carry him back to the
airport and
we stored a car for him for a number of
years and
came quite
well acquainted with him and sue winters
which was his assistant on the project
and
there again we just you know we played
our
role in the interview basically what's
been asked earlier today you know where
we were standing and
and
so forth
and
for that interview you were actually
filmed where you were standing in the on
the side yeah we were brought back to
the site and interviewed that on the
side
and and i thought his documentary was
well uh
done
it i don't think there was any
conclusive
evidence in it but i thought it was uh
because he
he he did have a lot of people in it
that were actually at the assassination
side and
and then the interview of the
doctors at parkland hospital and and
various people that played a role along
the way in the assassination
so i think he had something to
contribute
he he
it ended up like everybody else it ended
up
inconclusive you know
but i thought it was well
done um we've been talking a lot today
about various people who talked to you
we mentioned harold weisberg and
josiah thompson and mark lane
you've been interviewed by by most all
of the authors of the various books that
have come out that that are now well
known uh research books on the
assassination do any of these interviews
uh stand out are there any particular
anecdotes that are interesting and
interesting to put on the record here at
the museum that relate to your interview
well
i guess not really i
i thought quite a bit of
thompson his book six seconds in dallas
because it was not sensationalized it
was just
something that was put in a
chronological order of the day of the
events the day of the assassination
and i i thought a lot of i liked his
book as well as any of them
most people are are trying to
sensationalize or
you know come up with some
conclusion and nobody's managed to do
that yet
um have during any of these interviews
have you ever been
threatened or
tried to
forcibly have your story changed or
been swayed in any way or bribed
anything like that that that would be
interesting to note
during these interviews
no
i think i mentioned earlier to you about
the time that we were on the stage uh
up in louisville texas it was uh
i can remember madeleine brown and her
son being there and and
and
uh
jim mars was the was the host and
he was asking questions and people were
given given statements and
and uh
gene hill was there and two or three
others and i remember going away from
there
not feeling real good and steven what
bothered me about it
there was maybe 200 people in the
audience 300 people it's pretty good
crowd of people
and listening to these people's stories
uh some of them i agreed with and some
of my questions and and
and listening to mr mars and
and he would he would ask questions and
then maybe if you gave him an answer
well then he might ask you another
question and
he kind of i think was going a certain
direction with his
with his program
and when i left there
what i did not feel good about
was that maybe the person to my left was
saying something and i was nodding and
listening
rather than disagreeing
uh somebody might think well that must
be factual because the the newmans agree
with it the newmans think that it
happened that away
and uh so i thought after that i would
not get involved
in a program or a group of people up and
you've got a host
uh or con you know a uh what's the word
commentator or
uh person
that's in control
i didn't want to be put in that
environment again not that i think mr
mars did anything wrong i mean
what he did was his business but i don't
want to be involved
in a
event like that
because the story that i want to tell is
the story
of that day of seeing the president's
car coming towards us and
first two shots were fired and
and the car moved down and the third
shot was fired
and to tell what what i know
and not to sit not to sit around and
and like we are here today i don't want
to sit here and speculate or tell you
what theory
that i think best fits the assassination
i want to believe that someone else was
involved
in it other than just lee harvey oswald
that's what i want to believe and i
based that on
what i've read and heard and seen over
the years
but
but
that's not the facts as i remember them
the day of assassination so i try to
keep my
my part
my involvement and my story down to the
events that happened that day
does that make sense it does it does i'm
glad we i'm glad we put that on the
record here that's a good statement to
him
um i know but in addition to these
interviews you've also spoken to some
school groups among them my my sixth
grade class right
how do you feel addressing young people
about what you saw that day
i don't have a problem with it uh
you know when i when i tell my story
uh which is simply what we've gone over
here today
at the end of it
uh a little
i'll open it up for questions because
there's something that
that
maybe i should have said that i didn't
say and something
and i can remember one student
saying to me mr newman do you think the
government killed the president
and i said no i i don't think the
government killed the president
uh uh
you know i think it may be impossible
that maybe one individual or some
individuals could have been involved in
it
but i don't think our government our
congress or our
court system or our president of course
i don't think our government killed the
president
and i don't want to
leave any young person with that with
that impression
you know there can be a rotten egg
in the group or a rotten apple in the
barrel
but that doesn't mean our government
participated
so
so that that's that's the main thing
that
that
if a young person asked me that question
i want to
most certainly not walk away from there
making them think our government
participated in
in the assassination of our president
because i don't believe that that that's
what happened
well i'm winding up here just uh this
last one or two questions um
over the years the the books and the
documentaries that have come out about
the assassination have familiarized
people with the various eyewitnesses
that were in dealey plaza to the point
where they've almost taken on a life of
their own they've become legends almost
like survivors of the titanic i mean
people can name who they were where they
were standing and tell all about them
including yourselves
um
have you ever been treated
as celebrities or been asked for
autographs in that respect
well we have in in respect i wouldn't
say celebrities but
wouldn't go that far but
but people will ask us they'll have a
book with uh uh
and they'll have our picture in it and
they'll ask us to sign the book above
our name something like that
and
that's that's happened more than once
that's happened several occasions
that people want us to do that and of
course i'm glad to do that
but
okay last two questions
it's been 40 years now
are you tired of it
well i'm getting old uh
but uh i'm not really tired of it i mean
i
i don't mind being here interviewed
someone calls us up and wants to
interview it
uh
we either do it or we don't do it and
and and when we allow ourselves to be
interviewed we do it at our
on our terms you know i mean in time and
place
and i don't have a problem with it uh
i i want the interviewer to be sincere
in what they're doing and believe in
what they're doing and
and
you know i wouldn't let somebody
interview me that i thought
was trying to go down some wild trail i
mean i wouldn't want to be a part of
that if it was the truth or not the
truth because
because
like i've said earlier i want to i want
to
stick with what i can recall the day of
assassination and so i don't i don't
think there's a place for me
in some theory
you know i don't think there's a place
for my
what i have to say
based on theory
it's been 40 years
how long is it going to last
do you think
well i think it's going to last a long
time i mean i
in a long time uh
it wouldn't surprise me that 100 years
from today that someone could be
discussing the 140th anniversary of the
assassination of president kennedy i
mean
it may sound a little far-fetched but i
i think
research is
is is
is
going to be an ongoing thing with the
kennedy assassination
i question that we're ever going to
reach the final conclusion
because so much time has passed
and and the people are getting older you
know we were
22 years old i'm 62 years old today so
so i don't see much hope in
in us reaching the
reaching the conclusion
well at the uh at the end of these oral
histories we always leave it open if
there's any
um areas we didn't cover that we need to
cover or stories or anecdotes anything
for the record to be preserved here that
i haven't asked you about it's your
chance to
make any statements
well you know i can't think of
i i can't think of anything that you
left out i want to thank you for having
us here and uh in in your courtesy
and i want to thank you and people like
yourself that
are devoted to uh to carry on uh this
burden and
and to continue to research and
and look into the assassination i think
it's
part of our history and i think it's an
important uh i think it's an important
job i really do
any thoughts
no
okay
well thank you both very email us at
c3history at cspan.org
h.b mclean was a dallas police officer
assigned to president kennedy's
motorcade in 1963
in 2003 he recorded this oral history of
the assassination for the sixth floor
museum in dallas texas which is located
in the old texas school book depository
this program is about 40 minutes
okay today is wednesday july 16 2003
this is stephen fagan with the 6-4
museum at dealey plaza and the interview
we are doing today is part of the
museum's oral history collection
and today we are pleased to be
interviewing mr hb mclean thank you very
much for coming to the museum and
participating in this project
uh for the record at the beginning of
these oral histories we ask you to give
us your full name date and place of
birth and just a brief summary of your
childhood
well i was born in nagadose county
in
november of 1927.
in 1942 we moved to dallas and i've been
here ever since
did you uh did you go to war world war
ii
no i want it's in the merchant marines
okay can you describe that experience a
little bit for us
well there wasn't much to it just
went to uh
catalina island for training
left there went to seattle washington to
load up the ship
and at that time the war was so ended
and we would
all
another six eight months
and then we'd come back to the states
and i never didn't go back anymore you
came back to dallas
and uh when did you join the uh dallas
police force
1953.
what made you want to become a police
officer i wanted to do that ever since i
was a kid
was there a particular reason
i disliked
what they do i guess i don't want it
just
just something i wanted to do
can you describe for me if you can for
people watching this tape who weren't
alive in the in the 1950s and 1960s just
what type of city dallas was like if you
want to compare it to maybe today that's
that's fine too but just a description
well you didn't have near the traffic
that you've got
you didn't have near the crime that
you've got
what was your first position with the
police department i was a patrolman
first job was working the fair at
fair park
when i got out of school i went
that school that graduated during
that period
worked the fair
their first assignment
and then i went on work patrol and
different places
when did you become a solo motorcycle
officer
that was in 1954
okay
and you you held that position for how
long
until 1975. okay
what would be your typical duties as a
as a motorcycle officer enforcing
traffic regulations
work in accidents
just mostly pertaining to traffic
okay
um
in the
late 1950s early 1960s do you remember
any of the political activities in the
city any of the
right-wing extremist atmosphere general
edwin walker for instance or bruce alger
do you remember any of those instances i
remember the incident but i don't know
i paid no attention to it
i didn't read the paper because i don't
even take the paper now
and
it just didn't interest me
do you recall when about a month before
the assassination in october when
adelaide stevenson was here in dallas
and he was spit on and hit with some
signs yeah
did that was that a was that talked
about often in the police department
i don't recall it being talked about
there's a lot of it on the newspapers
um when the when it was announced the
president was coming to town do you
recall any apprehension or was there any
worry or discussion that there might be
some sort of violence directed at him or
any sort of demonstration no to us it
was just another escort
do you remember when you first heard
about the president's visit to dallas
it was oh two or three days before we
got here i guess
uh when did you receive your assignment
for that day
that morning good morning and uh just
briefly can you just outline what your
assignment was
first we went out to
love field
and picked him up there
and escorted him
back the route that they had set up for
him
all the way down through town
and
there was a motorcycle officer on each
side of the
caravan
and there was
i don't know eight or ten of us
that was in it
i read yesterday that
and maybe you can confirm this for me
originally was there a different layout
for the motorcycles along the
along the presidential limousine weren't
you originally supposed to be closer to
the limousine than you than you ended up
being
or is that not true
myself yes
no i don't know about that okay but
they did change the
positions that everybody
normally worked
everybody worked in pairs
had a partner
and they come along and they change the
partner and put them on the opposite
sides to what they normally
ride
and so what was your position what was
your scheduled position in the motorcade
myself and marion baker was
just ahead of the
bus
or with the bus
and that would have been about about how
far behind the limousine there was about
five or six cars back okay
and uh so you arrived out at low field
do you remember what time
no we got there kind of early okay
was there already crowds throwing a big
crowd out there
can you describe just the general
atmosphere what it what it was like i
don't know i feel like everybody was
happy and
laughing carrying on
waiting for him to get there and when he
got there everybody started waving and
hollering and
carrying on
he shook hands with a bunch of people
um
did you get a good look at both the
president and mrs kennedy yeah
were you uh were you fans of the
president
not particularly okay
um
so you all fell into did you did you
fall into place before the president got
into his uh car or afterwards
well we were all
on our motors and as they pulled out the
gate everybody fell in where they're
supposed to be okay
uh well if you can in as much detail as
you can remember if you could just uh
kind of describe the
the trip downtown and talk about the
crowds and just the the general
atmosphere and go ahead and stop before
the assassination i'll ask another
question then
let's see i believe we went down maple
avenue
well it's been so long i can't remember
it's okay don't worry about the way we
went but uh just the general crowds do
you recall with there was it wasn't too
too big a crowd until you got downtown
and when you got downtown they would
just wall-to-wall
uh did you did you keep an eye on the
limousine in front of you or you i
didn't have time
okay i was trying to get through them
people it
wouldn't get out of the way
did you did you talk to marion baker at
all
during the trip no no okay you don't you
don't have time and you don't do that
had you done escort work before in the
past oh yeah we best quoted several
let's say we
escorted humphreys
it was somebody else
i've escorted two or three of them
presidents yeah
but was kennedy your first in 1963 or it
was the last one i think okay
um well as you approached uh dealey
plaza you were uh you turned from maine
onto houston uh describe for me if you
can uh what happened during the uh
during the assassination itself where
you were and and what you did okay we we
came down
main street made a right turn onto
houston
and i stopped right directly across the
entrance to the old jail
and i was sitting there well standing
really
i was ahead of both feet one on each
side the motor
and waiting for them and they was going
down elm street they had turned go down
straight to the triple underpass
and they got
oh i guess maybe a half a block down
there
when i heard the shots
i looked up
and i see all these pigeons coming out
from behind it
school depository building
i just made a comment to myself
somebody's shooting at the pigeons today
and about that time the chief called on
her
radio and said head for parking
so
the race was on
so you had um you had stopped on houston
before you noticed any shots being fired
right okay you you would just stop to
let the uh the parade catch up with you
right okay well you have to stop every
once in a while
to
well you kind of see-saw back and forth
to
make sure everything is and keep people
out of the way they'll walk right out in
front of them cars if you don't do
something
do you remember what the locations in
the motorcade that you were kind of
see-sawing
back and forth between
president johnson's car i know you were
kind of close to it
and that and the bus the press bus
back between the two of them okay
uh at the time you only heard one shot
that's all i recall hearing
and uh and did you turn towards the
motorcade after you looked at the
depository
yeah i looked over there after i looked
up
i just looked straight up when i heard
the shot
but i didn't all i seen was the pigeons
and then uh and then when you glanced at
the limousine what did you see
i seen miss candy
up on her hands and knees
and one of the
security people
crawling over the back of the car
and i seen my ex-partner truck on his
hands knees going up at grassy knoll
over
and who is that and bobby hargis okay
uh what what were you thinking at that
moment did you realize something had
happened
i knew something happened but i had no
idea what it was
did you did you connect that in your
mind between the the sounds you heard
and the pigeons and and the car did you
think it was all related or
no not really because
i don't know i just wasn't thinking
about that it all happened pretty fast
yeah okay
and so as you you said the race was on
as you sped up um what did you see as
you as you drove through the plaza
you
wouldn't you know the same hardest
crawling up that
knoll and
just everybody going every woods away um
did you think anything about that
i knew something had happened
because the chief had already come on
the radio and said
somebody's a shot had been fired and
head for parkland
well we had instructions when we left
that if anything happened
we went straight to parkland
and that's
the way we went
uh do you recall what happened to mary
and baker about this time
not a lot i lost him okay
because because of course he was the
first time i think he i think he uh
instead of coming on
to the hospital he went on over to the
school over to this building right he
was the first person inside the building
and he actually encountered lehigh on
the second floor that's very interesting
um so you drove to uh parkland pretty
fast did you did you stay with the
motorcade or were you pretty much on
your own at that point well i was i was
kind of
back you know behind
but before they got there i had caught
up with them and got up
to the front
and i was one of the front jockeys going
with it
in front of the chief's car okay well
tell me what happened when you got to
parkland if you would
okay we pulled we pulled in behind
parkland
and everybody went ever switch away
and
the doctors came out to get him out of
the car and she wouldn't let him have
him
she just laid down across his head
wouldn't let him have him
so i reached over and caught her by the
shoulders
and come on man let him let him take him
on the inside
so i finally got her up
and they took him on in and i
walked her on into the inside of the
hospital
as soon as i got her in there i turned
around and come back out
did mrs kennedy say anything
not to me was she crying oh yeah she was
almost hysterical sometimes
um when you when you saw the uh the
president did he have something did he
have a coat over his head at that point
okay yeah
so you didn't you didn't get a look at
his his wound at all
no i seen some of his
skull laying in the floorboard of the
car
what just can you describe just what the
what the inside of the limousine looked
like
well it looked like any normal limousine
they were just
splotches of blood and pieces of
flesh
laying in the floor
um
what were you thinking at that point
i don't know i just didn't
i mean
was just a blank
um from from what you saw in the car did
you think that the president was was
fatally wounded
i figured he was
well then what happened after you uh
well when you you went into the
emergency room you took you took jackie
kennedy in there uh where did you where
did you leave her at
they're in the emergency room on some of
the doctors or
fbi or secret service rather
came and got her
um did you did you see anything um
amongst the uh fbi and the secret
service what were they doing at that
point
well it was one fbi man that decided
he's gonna get right in the middle of
all of it
the secret service told him to go on
get out of there i'm fbi
he said i don't care who you are
we don't need you and he mouthed off
some more
he turned round one the officer standing
there said escort him outside and don't
let him back in
okay did you see anything else while you
were in there that's worth
it's a good story anything else i
figured that was time for me to get out
of there
okay so what'd you do when you when you
went back outside just went back outside
and stood around like everybody else
okay then when they got ready to
send johnson to the airport
me and
somebody i don't know who it was
escorted him back out to the airplane
i'd love for you
did you uh did you see johnson
i mean were you were you beside him at
any time
oh yeah
when he come out to get in the car and
then
when he got out
do you recall any anything about his
expression the way he looked
um
what he might have been feeling at that
point
i think he's won't get up get the hell
out of dodge
uh was ladybird with him
his wife
yeah i believe she was i think character
and jackie
went with them
okay
uh so after you got back out to love
field t pick up the story there and tell
me what happened
they got out went up on the plane
and we stood around until they took off
and when they took off
we went on back about our business
did you know at the time that that he
was being sworn in as the president
aboard the plane yeah how did you find
that out
just hearsay
and uh
well if you can tell me about what they
did
now they told us that
judge hughes
was on her way out to swear him in
after they got to love field they called
her and she came out and found them in
on the plane out there
so we waited
she got there swore him in
and then they took off well they brought
the they brought the body out there
and put it on the plane
and they
all went back to washington
did you uh you you saw judge hughes
arrive and go on the plane yeah okay
um there were press beginning to arrive
at both parkland hospital and then at
low field did you did you see any of
these
trucks and the cameras start to come out
well that's normal anywhere you got
something like that
so i pay no attention to it they
they just out there doing their job
was there was there other officers that
were assigned to kind of keep them back
oh yeah you had crowd control and all
that out there
there was some officer
left to guard the plane
during all that going on
even when there was nobody out there
uh were you asked for any statements or
interviews while you were in the middle
of all of this
no
okay
uh so when you left low field about what
time was that right right after the
plane took off yeah okay what'd you do
from there for the rest of the day the
best i recall we got a call to
report to the office
all of us
and the
secret service
wanted to interview all the motor
jockeys
and they wanted to know what happened
we started telling them what happened
how it happened
they said no no no
it happened this way we said no it
happened this way he said you're wrong
it happened this way
so we finally all just told him to hell
with you you ain't gonna believe what we
tell you we ain't telling you nothing
else
this one got up and walked out this was
the day of the assassination
it was that day or the next day i don't
remember this when it was do you recall
what the secret service the way they
were trying to tell you it happened
no they had their own views as to how it
happened
and
they wouldn't hear no other way
that's interesting i haven't heard that
just like they were dead set on that
microphone it was
stuck it had to be in a certain place
to do what they said it done
and i was the only one that was anywhere
close to that position
so they pinned it on me
i want to i want to talk about that in
just a second because that the
microphone issue didn't actually come up
until the 1970s correct right okay
um
so this is the either that day or the
next day you talk to the secret service
uh did you ever talk to anyone else that
weekend any reporters or anyone else i
don't recall any okay
uh did you fill out a statement with the
with the police a normal report no okay
um did you have any other assignments
that evening
i don't cry what
what we had okay you remember what time
he got off work
i think it's about 11 or 12 o'clock
that night
okay
uh saturday and sunday did you
have anything to do with the police
those days
other than maybe being interviewed by
the secret service
i don't think so
did you ever see oswald in custody
oh yeah i was there the night that
brought him in
can you talk about that when you when
you saw him
oh he was just screaming and hollering
what am i here for i ain't done nothing
and he's wanting to fight everybody that
came around
you never talk to them personally though
no no okay
they just shoved them right on by a man
in captain fritz's office
can you describe
the police station in in the frenzy that
that followed the assassination i mean
we've all seen the uh news footage but
just the way it was like with all the
cameramen and all the news reporters can
you just describe the atmosphere
well you couldn't hardly walk through it
everybody milling around bright lights
ever were
had you ever seen it that bad before
no
i hadn't was that was that not imagi i
imagine up there in fritz's office that
they've seen it but
it's on occasion i've had to go up there
to his office
on
sunday when oswald was shot do you
recall where you were
sitting at home watching it on tv
um
what were you what were your thoughts
when you saw that happen
i don't remember what my thoughts was
back then
that's too long ago
i've slept since then okay
um
did you recognize jack ruby had you seen
him before
yeah i had seen him before
did you did you know jack ruby at all
nothing other than just who he was
so you had seen him around the police
station
yeah and one of my ex-partners knew him
pretty well
had you heard anything about him what
kind of a guy he was anything
before before before
afterwards did you hear did you hear
talk about him oh yeah
what were some of the things that were
talked about
well about the clubs that he run and
being involved with the mafia and stuff
like that
did you believe any of that
i didn't know
i didn't know that i'd only seen him
i went to his place one time with my
partner and he introduced me to him and
we they talked for a few minutes and we
left and that's the last time i seen him
until
the day that
they shot oswald
uh after the uh assassination did you uh
did you talk to anyone else um between
between this time and then in the 1970s
when the open mic controversy started no
you uh you did not testify to the warren
commission yeah i went i went up to wars
and talked to them
this was in 1964.
no i thought that was in
80 or 81 well the the the first
investigation was the warren commission
that was the commission that president
johnson assigned
uh and they found that oswald was the
lone gunman
no i didn't talk to them okay
and then they reopened the investigation
in the 70s i want to i want to talk
about that
so but but during the 1960s you never
talked to anyone else about this not
today
okay
well in the 1970s the house select
committee on assassination started their
second investigation on the
assassination and a new controversy
arose
regarding a a police radio mic can you
just talk about what that controversy
was and just describe it to the best of
your ability
well they said that they had a had a
they
brought some acoustic people in
to try to find out where
the shots were or how many shots they
were
and they said it was on a motorcycle
and it had to be in a certain spot
for it to pick up the sounds
and unfortunately my motorcycle was in
the spot that they said it's supposed to
come from
um
would this have been on a on a
particular channel
yeah
can you describe it was two channels
correct yeah can you describe what the
difference is
for people that might not know between
channels one and two
well channel one is for routine
everyday
police work
channel twos with special events
so
all of the motorcycles should have been
on channel
two okay and and the accusation was that
yours was either on or stuck and on
channel almost
mine was
stuck
okay
um
for for individuals who might not have a
very good idea of of the police radio
system can you kind of describe that uh
what what the what a dictable recording
is and how you know how that's how
that's done
i don't know how it's done with a little
cylinder about
eight and a half two inches in diameter
and about four or five inches long
that they put on a machine it puts a
sound on it
um
had you
had your mo
you always drove the same motorcycle
correct yeah okay uh did you have a
particular number on that on that
motorcycle
don't ask me what that number was okay
okay um
had you had you ever had any uh
microphone trouble on that particular
motorcycle
oh yeah whenever you lay something up
against it
had
had all the officers probably at one
time or another had problems with their
own microphones yeah okay had yours ever
become stuck before though
not stuck
okay there's always something against it
um
but do you recall exactly what's what
channel you were on that day it was on
channel two channel two okay
it's good to have that for the record uh
but you were called to washington to to
talk about this can you describe that
experience for me
well to start with
they sent me a tickets
sent me the law at the love field to
catch the plane
well as a love field they kept
announcing those loudspeaker
for me to go to such and such place to
see somebody
that they wanted to talk to me but when
i left i got ordered not to talk to
anybody until i got there
so i paid no attention to them
because it was
the news people
went on went on up there
and
they picked me up at the airport carried
me on up to the office
and we talked for
i don't know how long
and
they kept asking me questions that
i had to answer them with it was
possible
they would let me listen to the tape i
asked them if i could listen to the tape
well you don't need to listen to that
so i just said everything was possible
and when i got back to town
i went back to work the next day
j.c bogues called me over to his office
he was a
i think he's a lieutenant or captain one
i forget now wait
and i walked in his off and he said max
said
did you hear them if you heard those
tapes
before you went up the honor i said no
sir
and they wouldn't let me listen to him
up there
so he
sent me and took me in one of his other
rooms in there
set me down and said i want you to
listen to these
so i sit down listen to him
when i got through i come back out
and there was one man in his office
he introduced me i forget who it was but
he was a
newsman
and it wasn't five minutes that room was
fooling those men
and then they started questioning me
about the tapes and about the
microphones and i said no it wasn't mine
couldn't be because you can tell a
difference in the sound of a
three-wheeler running and a solo
motorcycle running
and it was not mine
what kind of can you describe what the
difference would be between those two
types of
three-wheeler's got a
saturn sound
and solo if it's just island goes
but wheeler morning
uh where were the three wheelers during
the uh during the month they were all
lower
do you have any uh particular theories
as to
where this particular one that recorded
this i know right exactly where it was
who was riding it
what can you tell us
there was less bile horse
and he was assigned out at the trademark
where they were supposed to be going
and he always whistled when he was
riding
and you could hear him whistling just as
plain as day
but it took us about three or four days
to figure out
who it was jc and i was
working on it trying to figure out who
it was
we'd listen to it
and well
and we kept on and
it finally dawned on us that les always
whistled when he was riding his motor
we checked
he was assigned out there
and they
they heard on their work
station one which was the sheriff's
department
heard that on the tape
well the sheriff only had one car in the
whole thing and it was out at the
trademark
or less was
and then the
story of the bell
the church bell there was so many
thousands of years old
nobody could figure that one out
when i left jc's office that evening
going home
as i was crossing the street there was a
pickup truck making a left turn in front
of me
and he ran across a manhole cover that
was loose the front wheel hit it the
back wheel hit it
bong bong
so i called jc told him i said hey i
found out where your bell is
he said where i said it's a manhole
cover
so they checked out a trademart out
there
sure enough it was the manhole cover
there worked lest kept riding back and
forth
and it was loose
so he was running over that
manhole cover making it
sound like a bell ring
how do you account for the uh the
impulses on the tape that the
investigators said were the uh were the
shots
it was the radio popping
and little radios they popped
something fierce
it's
i don't guess they ever took one of the
radios and listened to it
they just assumed that
my mic was stuck and that was shots
that they were hearing
did did you and bulls ever confront this
this motorcycle officer about that i
didn't he might have
do you know if he's deceased now
i don't think he is okay
well that might be worth looking up and
doing an oral history with him too i
don't i don't
don't remember him
dying but
there's been so many of them it's hard
to tell that's true
so over the years
since since the 1970s this is this has
plagued you has it not
you know in a way
can you can you talk about just how how
it feels i mean you you do have a a
piece of this i mean you are a part of
this story you are a piece of history
now
um an unwilling piece of course but uh
how do you feel being at being a part of
this story oh just unfortunate being
that right spot at the wrong time
have you uh have you turned down some
interviews in the past yeah
well we're certainly grateful that you
got tricked into one one time really can
you can you talk about that a little bit
okay i had already gone down the county
and went to work down there as a deputy
sheriff
got promoted started in 85 i think it
was
and i was working the old jail one day
filling in because there was
a short sergeant over there
and they called
the chief's office called a sheriff's
office called
said
the
sheriff wants you in his office
i said i can't leave here i'm the only
one here
okay
a few minutes somebody else called mac
sheriff wants you in his office i said
i'm the only one here i cannot leave
and it wasn't a little bit
later until somebody else called again
and i said i can't
believe well the sheriff won't see you
right now say come on
well that was on the deputy chief so i
said well you want me to just leave this
jail
unattended
yeah come on
okay
so i got on the elevator and went
downstairs walked out on the street well
there was a lieutenant just parking his
car
was coming to relieve me to go to
sheriff's office
well the sheriff was having an interview
of a bunch of college kids i guess
that wanted an interview with him
and i walked in there and he's up there
talking to him
and i walked in the door and he said
where in the hell you been i said i've
been hiding from you or trying to hide
from you
he said at least people wants an
interview and said
i'm going to let you take over and
answer their questions
and this would have been sheriff bowles
correct right
and that's how i got into that one
are you and are you in bowl still
friends today
i hadn't talked to bowls and
well i left in 97
and i hadn't talked to him since
now just just uh one or two more
questions about about the microphone
because questions do come up here often
about it and i want to be able to refer
to this interview and point them in this
direction if they want answers uh if you
had
if your microphone was was stuck when
you were driving would there have been
any type of noise any kind of static or
anything nope there wouldn't have been
nothing it just been blank
and i wouldn't i wouldn't hurt the
orders to go to parkland hospital that
was my other question you heard that
right after the right after the shot um
you wouldn't have been able to hear that
if if your microphone was on channel one
correct
that's right
after that interview over at bulge's
office
they told me i would this dumb didn't
know what i was talking about
i didn't know whether it was or what
well it it to this day remains a
extremely controversial
point and that acoustic evidence has
been studied over the years and it's
still being studied today
uh it's it's there's never it's never
been definitively proven one way or the
other and so uh
so the jury's still out on that well if
it was that three-wheel motorcycle it
was stuck
there ain't no way in this world he
could have heard any shots on it
because it's two and a half miles up
straight up there right
i mean it's
the the story you told us today about
the motorcycle officer at the trademark
did you tell that to the press in the in
in the 1970s
have you told that i didn't figure that
out until i come back from washington
who have you told that story to besides
me
j.c bull
really he and i both figured it out
together okay
so
i hadn't told nobody
okay well i'm i'm certainly glad to have
this on the record here because maybe
that that can shed some light on at the
time he wouldn't let me tell nobody to
just just hang on to it
because had nobody confronted less with
it at that time
have you have you studied the
assassination have you read a lot of
these books and watched i've got several
books
that
but i hadn't studied it i just read
through it
do you have any thoughts on on why 40
years later it continues to be talked
about and why you're here for the
interview today and
things like that
finally you just got that different
types of people that some believe and
some don't believe
and
the ones that don't believe
and the one that believes that trying to
transfer me sway the others
go their way
have you always been convinced that lee
harvey oswald acted alone
no not really
i don't believe the man was shot from
where they say was
you uh you think a shot came from
another location i think you come off of
that railroad overpass
but
is that is that based on anything you
saw that day or is that based on other
things you've written do you do hunt
have you ever been hunting
i i don't do it myself but i've heard of
it and i've heard people talk about it
okay if you shoot something
the force of the bullet is going to push
him away from you right
okay the force of this bullet throwed
him this way
and then back this way
so i think the man is shot twice
so you know he was falling away
and then all of a sudden he just ride
back the other way
so that's based on a a film that you've
seen of the shooting there's a pruder
film
yeah okay
but um but what i mean is that you
didn't you didn't actually see anything
that particular day that would lead you
to think that there would be somebody up
say on this other than the fact that he
was falling
forward and to the left and all of a
sudden he just jerked the jerk back okay
and they had to be something that would
force him back the other way
um did you ever talk to any of the other
officers about the assassination
exchange ideas or opinions about it
okay did you ever talk to
your ex-partner bobby hargis about his
experiences that day no okay
well um i'm just about out of questions
uh at the end of these interviews we
always leave it open
if there's any stories or anecdotes or
any aspect of your story that i i didn't
cover here
so if you have comments or suggestions
regarding our programming please email
us at c3history
at cspan.org
in november of 1963 winston lawson was a
u.s secret service agent in charge of
the security for president kennedy's
trip to dallas texas he recorded the
following oral history in 2003 for the
sixth floor museum at dealey plaza which
chronicles the assassination and legacy
of president kennedy
in this first of two parts mr lawson
recalls his experiences on the
presidential detail and security
preparations in dallas the second half
of the interview which covers the
assassination and its immediate
aftermath will air on c-span 3 history
this coming sunday please check our
schedule on cspan.org for times
the 6th floor museum is located in the
old texas school book depository
evidence found soon after the
assassination indicated that shots were
fired from the building's sixth floor
this program is about 50 minutes
it was the the fall of 59 that that i
was accepted in the secret service
and i was transferred to washington dc
on the white house detail in those days
what it was called now it's called
presidential protective division
in the spring of 1961 after two
different schools a primary school and
then a uh
called treasury school
and then a a
a secret service type school where you
just dealt with secret service things
in the presidential detail that you were
a part of did you have a particular
assignment a particular duty
most regular agents on on the detail
are shift agents
and they have shifts of eight to four
four to twelve and twelve to eight
all around the clock depending on where
the president is and if the president
is in the white house you're stationed
at the white house if the president is
on the trip either overseas or to dallas
or wherever
the the ships go along if the president
is is only going to be stopping
in dallas during the day like he was for
example in 1963 but overnighting
someplace else the 12-8 shift the
midnight shift would not go to dallas
they would go to wherever he was going
to be staying overnight and for example
he was going to be staying at the lbj
ranch
so that midnight shift that got done in
fort worth
was being would have gone to
uh
would have gone to the lbj ranch area
gone to austin and then be taken over to
the ranch
did mrs kennedy have her own separate
agent yes
and to this day
depending again on the president the
family and so forth
there's the main detail for the
president and then these offshoot
details
if the president has a wife if he has
children that are protectable and so
forth
then there are these uh offshoot you
know smaller details that are involved
they're all part of the presidential
protective division but if the
the wife and the children are someplace
while he is
at point a and he's at point b
why of course they split
go that way
who did you uh report to directly
i reported the charge of the uh if
you're talking about after i was on the
presidential detail yes sir uh in
syracuse
or in dallas or chicago wherever a field
office is you'd report to the agent in
charge special agent in charge of that
field office which i did in syracuse
on the presidential protective division
which in those days called the white
house detail you you reported to the
specially in charge of that detail who
had assistance and assistance to the
assistance and so forth
i was assigned
during while i was in secret service
school because we were there in
washington d.c
to the inauguration parade route
i was on the parade route for
after he was sworn in
and then i was by the reviewing stand up
in front of the white house
after he was sworn in and for that part
of the parade and then that night i was
assigned to
one of the
balls which i believe was the shorm
hotel ball that particular night then
the next day it was back back to school
again for another week or so whatever it
was
back to syracuse until i was transferred
about three uh
about a month or two later well actually
in uh it was in in march of 1961.
did kennedy do a lot of fraternizing
with the secret service agents
not really he was he was pl he was
pleasant to them
if he'd been around for a while he knew
who you were
and each president is different believe
me just because of their personality or
or whatever and and
you try
even to this day
uh
not to get too
too familiar you spoke when you were
spoken to unless there's a reason
you know for for bringing something to
their attention or something like that
if there was a reason to talk to them
and um
each one is different each the each vice
president each president some were
friendlier than others and
some of them
well because their personalities are
what was going on at the time
did you do you recall any particular
anecdotes or stories that involve you
and and president kennedy having any
sort of exchange that that you can
recall for us here
yes
on his trip to
on president kennedy's trip to uh
ireland
the uh the summer before he was
assassinated that was the summer 1963.
um he had a number of stops in in
ireland of course over a couple of days
and
one of the stops
he was in the
in the mayor's office and so forth
council chambers came out and the crowds
were just
tremendous
and i think it was it was county court
but i i'm not too sure but it was it was
one of his many stops
of course he had his limousine
but he also had that follow-up car the
famous follow-up car that was
later you know
talked about quite a bit in the dallas
assassination the one that had the
running boards all the way across the
side the cadillac
which we had two or three of them in in
those days
and he didn't want to ride in his
regular car so he because of the crowds
he got into the follow-up car
and the crowds were practic right up to
the running boards and we had agents on
the running boards both on the left and
on the right and the driver and so forth
and president kennedy one or two other
people were
sometimes sitting sometimes standing in
the back seat
and
[Music]
as we slowly moved through the crowd
and they were people trying to reach in
to touch him and all that
somebody
hit me on the chest with their hand or
their shoulder or something like that
and back i went
with the
see there was a
[Music]
the door came up oh right about
not quite waist high maybe buttocks high
and when they pushed me like that it was
just like a fulcrum my feet went up and
i landed on
president kennedy who was sitting down
at that particular time with my feet up
in the air on my back right on his lap
and he went
and helped me get back up and into my
proper post and there was a picture in
the uh
that i have at home as a matter of fact
a little story in the uh in the
newspaper about that in
in that uh
in that city newspaper a day or so later
that's just one anecdote
did you like president kennedy yes
um
he was in office for such a brief period
of time but but it was a presidency that
was marked by many different monumental
events such as the bay of pigs the cuban
missile crisis do you have any
particular memories of
your activities his activities during
those events i do we were in chicago on
a trip
i believe i was working on the 4-12
shift
and he had been to
[Music]
some type of event in in town that
evening so it was like a speech at a
dinner or something like that
and
we got back to the
to the hotel that he was staying in
and
at one point i was stationed at his door
in the corridor in the hotel
and all kinds of scurrying around and so
forth was going on people coming to go
on staff and all that and
when you know something's up
and then they came out and said we're on
our way back to washington
didn't even stay you know the night
and got back on air force one and and we
went back to washington and then
uh when we got back you know like in the
middle of the night practically why
i went home and so forth and the next
day
you see a lot more scurrying around it
wasn't for
a few more days before we found out what
was going on that because of that cuban
missile crisis we'd gone back to
washington
what about some of the other luminaries
of the the kennedy years vice president
johnson
mcnamara
sorensen any particular memories or
thoughts on on these individuals
do you encounter them at all well i
encountered
vice president johnson just whenever he
his detail and he would be near
president kennedy or so forth and um
uh yeah but of course president john's
vice president johnson then
had a different detail
than
than us and so forth and our paths would
cross fairly often
what about president kennedy and his
children do you ever
uh see them together
saw them a lot saw them both at the
white house and and on weekends when
they were either at glenora in uh in
virginia or at the new place that they
just finished building like a couple of
weeks before he was assassinated
and or up in hyannis or places like that
you know they played together a lot and
he was a very good family man
um
did president kennedy to your knowledge
or
did you hear him ever mention or talk
about the possibility of
some sort of violence coming to him or
any type of assassination attempt
uh yes and this is um
i don't know what to call it but
i didn't advance for president kennedy
in buffalo and niagara falls
i believe it was 1962.
president kennedy was going to buffalo
new york for the polish day parade
so he landed in niagara falls
uh
at a marine
base that was adjacent to the niagara
falls
airport there
took a motorcade to downtown buffalo
went out a little ways and joined the
parade that was already in progress he
joined it out maybe 20 30 blocks from
from the city hall where it was going to
terminate and he was going to give a
speech
i'm from the buffalo area originally in
in that area
and my parents and my aunt uncle and my
brother and his wife
i made arrangements for them to be part
of the crowd in niagara falls
and
after
he arrived went downtown buffalo gave
his was part of the parade near the end
went uh gave the speech in
on the front steps of the platform at
the city hall in buffalo
and got back out to
niagara falls he walked he walked the
fence line like he did here in dallas
later and like all presidents usually do
or vice presidents or whatever
and
i didn't introduce my my family to him
but
one of the supervisors on the detail who
was standing next to him said where's
the effect
mr president this is agent lawson's
family
and president uh president uh kennedy
said
well he must be doing a pretty good job
because nobody has shot me yet no
i mean
when you think of what happened
a year later i mean
to hear something like that is is just
mind-boggling
and then
got on the airplane and he left and i
got another airplane and left and so
forth
the uh the kennedy years when you look
back and and see the pictures in the
films they seem to be a period of time
that's full of energy
and excitement uh obviously you had a
job to do during all of that but
did it occur to you when you were
working there that this was a historic
time that what you were doing was you
were part of something that was that was
really great
um
not just because of the energy and so
forth that you talked about but the
whole
the whole idea the thing like for
example
after
the assassination and president johnson
became
the president
and i'd go down the lbj ranch and i'd be
on the midnight shift and be standing
under one of those big
oak trees out in front
and it would be two in the morning and
be cold and you think
what in the world am i doing here you
know i'm a college graduate and i
um
here i am almost like on guard duty in
the middle of the night and so forth you
know and i've been away from home it was
over christmas or whatever you know and
you'd wonder and then maybe two weeks
later you'd go to some event that you
couldn't
buy your way into and all that for
example i was on the
i was at cape canaveral slash cape
kennedy depending on what it was called
in those days
for the first moon
shot when
i was there when they took off
by the time they landed on the moon i
was in canada on vacation but you know
how many people would would just give
almost anything to have been a part of
the audience when someone left to go to
the moon for the first time and there
are many examples of that type of thing
where you know over things overseas or
things united states or
places that and things that you did that
say my gosh you know
i'm a guy from a little town in western
new york and look what what i just been
witness to you know you can't buy that
type of thing and that was what was
wonderful about it
prior to what happened in dallas was
there ever any incident where you felt
like the president was in danger or was
there ever any incident where something
had to be done
to stop someone from
doing anything
there yes
there was a time in
the palm beach area
when someone's arrested down there that
uh you know it's just coming uh down
there to do something to the president
uh at least he said he was and whether
he would have or not i don't know but
you know he was arrested and there there
are other times when
especially in a crowd whenever
you got hundreds and thousands of people
and everybody crushing in on you and so
forth
you just don't know what happened i
remember a time in costa rica
when
he was president kenny was down there on
on a on a visit
and uh
giving giving a talk
and he was leaving by helicopter right
after the talk
and the people just swarmed on the thing
and
you know like those presidential
helicopters have that thing that flaps
down and you're seeing them come down
the ramp and go back up the ramp and so
forth and
we literally
had to shove people off the ramp to be
able to close the thing to be able to
take the helicopter off and all that so
it's you know
there's
quite a few crowd
times when uh
when you just when you just wonder about
it yeah
did the secret service often work with
the fbi was there a good relationship
there
we made contact with them and they you
know we tell them that we're going to be
in such such a place and do you have
anything we should know and and things
like that
but uh
and they had some
investigative things that
also that the past would cross on an
investigation or whatever but
they didn't they weren't really a part
of the
protection per se
they were
intelligence-wise and all that yeah
and
but
probably after the warren report there's
a lot more give and take not only with
the fbi but with the cia with with all
kinds of government agencies and so
forth you know
i could sit here for hours and listen to
you tell stories about the the kennedy
years and all your years as a secret
service agent but
we we want to talk about dallas in 1963.
before we do that though is there any
other particular anecdotes about
specifically about the kennedy years
that you feel like would be
good to have on the record here at the
museum
i
can't think of any right now well yes i
can think of another one okay
i had the advance to uh to berlin
his famous ekine berliner
uh uh speech
and uh that was
part of a
four or five uh country stop matter of
fact he had two in in two stops in
germany
and uh
he had maybe six or seven stops in
berlin itself
like checkpoint charlie brandenburg gate
out in the embassy area the uh
free berlin
university and and uh so forth
uh down at the uh
at the hall where he gave his speech
that i just mentioned that everybody
remembers and all that
well
there was a dry run of that a couple of
days before he was to arrive and so
uh the the motorcyclists they had what
they called the white mice and the red
mice and that just meant the types of uh
bandoliers color bandoliers that that
they had
and the types of uh
the color boots that they wore the
helmets they wore and things like that
so this was a
simulated
stop
where we went
to the brandenburg gate
and we started of course it was in june
of 1963 and it was
at
where it was in europe it was quite
quite light quite a ways into the the
night and got light quite a quite early
in the morning
and i can't remember now but let's say
it was 5 30 6 o'clock when when we
started out and here you have
all kinds of motorcycles in front
and the and a car simulating the
president's car you got the pilot car
the lead car the president's car
follow-up cars staff cars
local press buses international press
buses more staff cars etc etc and more
marked police vehicles and more
motorcycles
this was quite a formidable group of
people
and as we came tearing up the the street
towards the vandenberg gate
why they
on the east side they had a number of uh
areas where they had people all the time
with their binoculars and so forth and
and all that well some of these uh
plastic bubble type things on this
building on this building people stand
up like this i guess they thought the
invasion was coming but that was
that was really something and all that
so that's great
well uh when did you first hear about
the president planning a trip to texas
uh i got a call on on november 4th that
i was going to be assigned the uh
the advance
and i believe at that time also they
said somebody would be joining me or
nearly two in those days two people went
out
and went out about the same time but
because he had some stops
both in florida and in and in maryland a
week or so before
the texas stops
and also because he had not only the
dallas stop but he had houston san
antonio fort worth
dallas and then he was going on over the
lbj ranch
the
[Music]
presidential protection division the
white house detail in those days was
pretty much decimated
for advance agents
for all these places so they said you
know you're going to get on a special
plane you're going to go out and do the
advance and
we don't have the complete schedule yet
but we'll have more for you probably on
the 8th
of of november
and
i did get more information on the eighth
and did some things at headquarters and
made phone calls to dallas field office
to let them know we were coming and
uh wrote a memorandum for the record
that i had called the dallas field
office that we were coming and so forth
found out a few more things and then i
think i said earlier here that
on a special plane
was one of the people dropped off at the
uh at the various stops here and then
the agent to help me who by the way
actually was my senior and if if it had
been any other time
and just like one or two trips and we
had all he probably would have been the
advanced agent and i would have been the
assistant but because he was doing an
advance in florida
and wasn't able to come here until just
a couple of days before the event
i was the
i was the advance agent there
can you talk about what goes into
advanced work especially when there's a
planned motorcade in a speech
well there's an awful lot more involved
now and i like to think that uh and i
think the warren commission showed that
i did
if not everything that we usually do
probably a little bit more than we
usually do
that
did i shouldn't say do because now they
got
all kinds of things that we didn't have
and all kinds of people that we didn't
have
but
the advanced agent has to work with
the
uh what they call a political advanced
man or woman that comes from the white
house sometimes they borrow them from
maybe
if they're
if they're a lot of things going on and
all of their
advanced people are being used their
advanced staff
they know of people in
interior department or agriculture
department or something like that that
they've used in the past and and throw
them in so you work with the advanced
people that are representing the white
house
whether they're from the white house or
not you work with a local committee
you work with the
the air force
that will be bringing
the president to to the event
you work with either the uh
the marine helicopter people or the army
helicopter peeping if people if there's
gonna be
a helicopter movement involved you work
with the local press and and the white
house press
and it's quite a coordinating job
you naturally then you go to the police
jurisdictions
now
that varies if there's a
if there's a
an airport
if there's an airport that's outside the
city limits that might be the
jurisdiction of of maybe a sheriff's
department
and
perhaps the the state patrol or the
highway
police or whatever that particular state
calls their state group
maybe they have jurisdiction of the
roads to and from as well as the
sheriff's department then of course if
there's a a city involved then you've
got the city police so you have to
coordinate all of this with the various
police jurisdictions we get one two
three or whatever
and it's quite a coordinate quite a
coordination job so far was the advanced
work in dallas typical of
any other city you did at vance work for
yes and no
uh it was the for example
most field offices when you would do an
advance
let's say syracuse or let's say
someplace else there's usually a vip
section
in the police department that handles
vips hence the name that come to town
and uh you know whether it's a
a well-known rock group or whether it's
somebody that's a government official or
or whatever
and often that person is a sergeant
lieutenant or once an oil captain and
and the chief of police or whatever
assigns that person to be your liaison
and you work through that person so
forth
it was the very first time
that i ever worked
on any advance before or after that
with the chief of police the deputy
chiefs of police and the assistant chief
of police that you know that was unheard
of
chief curry
uh bachelor
stevens i can't remember all the names
there are four or five of them that were
either deputy chiefs or
assistant chiefs or something like that
they were a part of it from the get-go
in the meetings
not just meeting with some sergeant or
some lieutenant or something like that i
mean you met with chief curry or the the
deputy of the assistant chiefs of police
and when you did the route instead of
going with a sergeant or a lieutenant or
something like that you had one or two
of them
in the thing
that was amazing then on the other side
on the secret service side
uh if you went to syracuse or to toledo
or chicago or something like that
yes the agent in charge would
talk to you and find out what was going
on each day
during the event and so forth but the
person that you worked with the person
that you took you around to the
the host committee or to the hospitals
to the this to that whatever it is part
of the advance that you were doing
was usually one of the agents or a
couple of the agents in that field
office forest soros the agent in charge
of the dallas field office spent every
waking moment with me for that 10 days
that i was here between the 12th and the
22nd
with me from morning till late at night
unheard of
the motorcade route is something that's
come under a great deal of controversy
in the years since
mainly because there's been a charge
that the root was changed at the last
minute can you can you talk about that a
little bit uh well
in a couple of words that's false
that myth is wrong
uh that that root at first we didn't
know what rule it was going to be
because we didn't know where the the
speech slash luncheon site was going to
be it was either going to be at probably
at the women's building at the state
fairgrounds or it was going to be at the
trademark
and early on in the first couple of days
of of the advance
uh
went to both places
and it was later determined that for one
reason or another it would be better to
go to the trademark
and so
then it was pretty much if
the white house wanted a uh people to
see the president the presidency the
people y'all and going to the trademark
but the most people are going to be
downtown that route almost had to be
what it was except for a couple of maybe
a couple of places out near the airport
but
eventually we have to go down main
street and of course it's one way here
now but then we had to come come over
towards the school book depository and
turn left onto
elm here to be able to go
under the stemmons freeway which we
needed to do
best most practical way to get to the
trademark
if the motorcade had continued to go
straight onto main
and then try to get onto the on-ramp to
stemmins freeway but there's a concrete
divider which separates the road there
the secret service would have never
authorized a motorcade to to to go over
a concrete divider would they well that
that wouldn't have been too good i mean
theoretically you could probably make
some kind of a
a
a little bridge-like thing to get over
it and whatever but
this
it was decided by the police and by the
local um
by by the local field office and and by
me that uh
knowing what we had to do and where we
had to go and the time of day we had to
do it
uh that was the best route
and
often and this is not a tail out of
school but if
if a president or a vice president
somebody like that is is going to to a
town to a city
to be seen and to see them
often
it's arranged so that they're going
around noon time
or they're going around supper time or
time that people are getting out to go
home why is that well why not because
people are coming out of the office
buildings
people are downtown shopping you know
especially at noon they're not home
cooking supper or whatever and so you've
got a built-in crowd if you if you take
someone down to a downtown area
that has a lot of office buildings a lot
of stores and things like that
and
so that's one of the reasons that they
came downtown were you part of the um
the team that made the decision to use
the trademark instead of the women's
building at fair park
in a way i had no
no objection to the trademark i had
there was some problem with the with the
women's building was the the the
catering and the and as i recall and
think now we're talking almost 40 years
but
a lot of which i was trying to forget
things rather than trying to remember
things
and
as i recall i think there were columns
and things like that in in in the
women's building where where the
luncheon was going to be
and and some other problems
and
it was a pretty pretty quick shot to
just since we had to come downtown
anyway for the
for uh
you know staff and he wanted to be seen
and have a motorcade through downtown
and then on the stemmons freeway and
right off to the trademark
which would be pretty good then to go
back to the uh to the airport
we've done interviews in the past with
some of the the local civic leaders that
that arranged the luncheon at the
trademart and and a couple of them have
have noted that the trademark has the
the different tiers
and that was a new one for me as a
matter of fact they uh they tell the
story that they were trying to open up
that area because the demand for for
seats was so great and they talk about
having trouble having having
confrontations with the secret service
trying to open up that area to get
seating up there do you recall that uh
no i don't but
you you couldn't really have
uh
you know there were very as i recall
there were various of these walkways
from one side to the other and and up
like one level on another level another
i can't really remember but there were
probably two or three levels at least of
these walkways across and all that
and
you wouldn't want anybody over him
and and so
another thing that has to be considered
is that
you only have so many people
uh to
to put on posts or to to to be part of a
security thing the the the police
department the sheriff's department the
highway patrol what are they i can't
remember now what's what's it called
here in in texas the uh the rangers no
there's a wreck you know the ones that
give the
if you're speeding and you're out on a
regular state troopers yeah the state
troopers all right uh every one of them
did did a wonderful job and and let me
stop
reminding where we are in this thing
okay but uh let me say right now that
there is no way possible shape or manner
that the secret service would be able to
come close to doing what they do
without the local authorities be the
city police
the sheriff's department the state
patrol highway troopers whatever there's
absolutely no way that you know because
especially back in those days when there
are very few very few people not now
there are quite a number more of a
secret service agents than we had plus
plus some other technical things and all
that that we do but
we had very very very few people and
especially when we were making all these
stops
so that it took away from from our
groups of people because they were out
doing advances and so forth
and we depended greatly on the city
police the highway patrol and the
sheriff's department as i recall they
they big brought and stole all kinds of
people you know
if i remember right there were probably
50 or 60 police
for the trademart itself
and uh you know police on the route and
police here and police there and so
forth and
there are many things you could do
if you had thousands of people to do it
but uh
they bent over backwards and gave us
very very good cooperation now like i
said before where were we we were
talking about the the trademark yeah
okay well you see if if we had
uh
oodles of of law enforcement people to
be able to put on all of those things
you know yeah we probably could we
probably could have accommodated them
but uh
it wasn't possible
in your advanced work did you ever visit
parkland hospital oh yes went there
before the
before the event that was standard to
always visit the local hospital in a
range
it's not just the local hospital it
would be a hospital where
would be closest to whatever
place you're going to be you know if
you're
if your staff envisions a uh an
overnight at a hotel
and a ball game and a uh
and a
civic reception or this or that it's not
uncommon to have seven or eight
different uh especially if it's an
overnight events going on afternoon
evening the next morning or whatever so
you pick out what is the best hospital
in the area that you might be in at a
given
time if
if it's a matter of of
not
too much of a difference in time let's
say there's a very small hospital near a
hotel that you're going to be staying
overnight but maybe within three or four
minutes there's a much better hospital
with better emergency facilities and all
that you'd probably go to that one
but
you you pick out depending on where
you're protected will be at the time the
best hospital to go to
then again depending on
on the event sometimes you uh you have
pre-posted ambulances
like if it's at a
many times at a hotel for an overnight
by a city will
if it's a city
ambulance sometimes they're private
ambulances you know again it depends on
the city that you're going to
but
you'll likely have pre-posted ambulances
something or other and then you depend
on
the doctors and the medical people to
take you where they think is best
a heart attack is better go to this
hospital a gunshot wound is better go to
that hospital
dallas during this period of time had
had some political problems it was a it
was a hotbed of extremist activity and
adlai stevenson had had had an incident
here in october uh
obviously president johnson that had an
issue exactly in 1960 um
obviously you were aware of this was was
there any extra
precautions taken or
was there a heightened sense of
awareness i should say
because of this i think there was with
the police and that's my personal
opinion is why
chief curry and the assistant
chief and some deputy chiefs and so
forth were part of this whole thing all
the time and maybe even for
sorrows
that may be why
for first time ever instead of working
being assigned a lieutenant or a
sergeant or something like that to be
the liaison
that
these high
ranking officers were part of this
advance
now that's hindsight i didn't know that
at the time but i mean certainly that
it makes sense to me that that's what
was going on
well uh let's get to the uh morning of
the 22nd if that's all right um unless
there's anything important that i've
left out along the
i'll probably think of 15 things after
that okay well if you come up with
anything let me know but uh the morning
of the 22nd uh you were you had been
been here in dallas the entire time
since the 12th okay uh so go ahead and
let's talk about love field that morning
when you when you met the party
and pick up the story there i think i i
had a few things to do and and went over
to uh
before left field went over to the uh
trademark
and uh left
agent grandoff who
who had joined me a couple of days
before that and who was going to be the
site agent at at the trademark
and naturally there were
many questions to be
answered by people coming up to you and
like there are in every advance what we
do here how about this problem how about
that problem and so forth i i did think
of one thing um at the sheridan hotel in
dallas i understand that there was some
sort of communications
center set up
um
i've read this that that the secret
service had some sort of mobile white
house communication center set up there
um
[Music]
frankly i i don't remember but i
believe that most of the time the white
house communications agency
wh
whca
which is
they call huaka
just for something easy to say
uh yes they they come to town to make
sure that they're
this well especially if we'd happen to
be there was a fuel office here in the
field office by radios
but if we'd have been in uh
or some town out 50 miles away
where the field office wasn't there
wouldn't have been that
those radios and so forth set up so what
the white house communication agency
usually did was was come to town to make
sure that there were relay stations
there's some kind of a base station to
be able to help the uh
the transmission of of messages around
and we had
we had a uh
what's it called uh for the
you know like a
a certain frequency
uh never get alzheimer's like i couldn't
think of frequency for a minute
but uh
we had a frequency that we
used and all that and so
i think
they'd come to town and make sure that
there wasn't anything interfering with
it that there was a base station that
would help relay things that
some places they even probably had to
put some extra relay things up in
certain buildings and all that and
yes i think there was a chief warrant
officer by name of bails who was on that
particular trip from uh from white house
communications agency
and they provided a radios for us
there is still a white house
communications agency but
we had what was called part of like a
p33 in those days you know you didn't
have the little tiny walkie-talkies like
like they have now they either had some
some some larger ones that were about
like this or they had a uh
they had something that was about
this a little bit bigger than this and
about this you know from the table up to
here
and it was called a p33 and had a
big aerial that went up off of it about
like this
and
then of course the sea the president's
car had had a radio a built-in radio
inside of it on the particular frequency
that we were using
and the follow-up car the same thing and
then the uh
the vice president and the vice
president's follow-up car those agents
had hand-held or those p-33
radios
in there
well um going back to your story you had
in the morning of the 22nd you had left
the trademark and okay then left the
trademark and went over to
with
agent agent or agents i can't remember
now how many from the local field office
and they didn't have that many in those
days
very very very few agents in in the
dallas field office and so
uh
i needed help out at the at the airport
and took one or two of them i can't
remember what's out there and one or two
of the agents
from that field office at the at the
trademark
uh we're left and also so went out and
uh
the uh
i can't remember now where the press
came pressed plane came in first
or the vice president's plane came in
which was called air force two
and
had arranged with police to be able to
take
some of the off-duty shift agents over
to the trademart and one or two of them
for for duty there at the uh
at
love field
i say off-duty shift this is something
that still goes on but in those days
when we had
an
event as i said before if we had an
eight to four shift to twelve to uh
eight to four four to twelve and twelve
date shift
the twelve to eight shift never got
bothered
uh because it was bad enough
working overnight and then maybe having
to go like they did in this instance
only from
san antonio they were supposed to go
over to austin but it wouldn't have been
uncommon if this had been a thing where
he was going to be in fort worth
and then in dallas and then tonight
in chicago and then tomorrow night
in los angeles i mean that happens all
the time especially in campaigns
so
the midnight shift has to get to
wherever it is that he's going to be
that next night and sometimes it'll take
them half a day or better to even get
there so they didn't have them but the
eight to four shift in the 12 to eight
and the
eight to four and the four to twelve
shift
were used
interchangeably
as post standards
the the shift that was on duty usually
when he arrived at a certain event
you know if it was a morning event or a
new event or something like that that
would be the 8 to 4 shift and they would
go with him the 4 to 12 shift
would have to be used for post standards
or
other other security features
during that noon or 10 o'clock in the
morning event or whatever it was and
vice versa
if it was an afternoon speech or an
evening dinner speech or something like
that before the 12 shift would go with
the principal
and the 8 to 4 shift would have to go
and be you know so that was a lot of
extra work for these people and that
happened
for years and it is still going on but
because we have more people now see in
those days
that was it you had the dallas field
office and you had the people traveling
with them that was it now
if there was an event here in dallas
they would bring in people from
wherever maybe three from denver and
four from
chicago and
three from detroit and
two from los angeles and so forth
which gets to be quite
an operation if there are three or four
things going on
and especially in a campaign where
you've got seven
six or seven people all campaigning and
they're all making four or five stops
that's when in the campaign years the
secret services had to go out
and train in the past and we'll be
training in the future
customs atf
etcetera and they they will use those
kind of people
also for either post standards or to
fill in on the detail that's been
decimated because they got advance
agents up
was the um was the bubble top planned to
be used in dallas
the
bubble top
of course was not a
uh was not an art it was not an armored
car you know
the
the doors and and the chassis and so
forth
of that car that lincoln was not an
armored car nor
was it bulletproof on the bubble top
which was which was plastic
i think
most people that even knew there was
such a thing figured that it probably
was and looking back at it you'd wonder
sometimes how many people might have
tried something
in parade situations but thought uh you
know what good little would it do if
that's he's he's going to be in this uh
in this car that
you know you'd have to hit with a rocket
or you'd have to hit with a hand grenade
or something like that
but it was raining
and telephone call
to fort worth to and from fort worth
said if it is raining leave the bubble
top off if it stops raining i mean if
it's raining leave the bubble top on if
it stops raining take off the bubble top
and stop draining
now you would you'd want something that
i thought about an awful lot
if that bubble top had been on
would you have tried would oswald have
tried
the shot at all because he might have
thought oops you know this is a uh
this isn't going to work because
you know it's bulletproof or
the next thing is if he had a tried
that thing has a curvature to it would
it maybe have
hit and glanced off
the next thing that thing was put
together in sections and it had these
these strips about this wide metal
strips
and that thing was configured so you
could have the bubble top on the front
you could have it on just on the back
you could have it all off you could have
it all on and and a couple other
configurations that you could have
if
if he uh
said well okay i'm going to try it
anyway and shot
maybe it would have hit one of those
metal
keep the thing on so just never know
that's something to think about
a reminder that you can watch c-span 3
history every weekend at stband.org
in november of 1963 winston lawson was a
u.s secret service agent in charge of
the security for president kennedy's
trip to dallas texas
he recorded the following oral history
in 2003 for the sixth floor museum at
dealey plaza which chronicles the
assassination and legacy of president
kennedy
in this second of two parts mr lawson
recalls the events surrounding the
assassination from the arrival of air
force one at love field to the funeral
at arlington national cemetery
the sixth floor museum is located in the
old texas school book depository
evidence found soon after the
assassination indicated that shots were
fired from the building's sixth floor
this program is about 50 minutes
if you would just
start with the presidential party
arriving at love field and take me
through the motorcade okay
the
to jump back a couple of minutes
the the vice president's plane was in
and so
that's the small staff of his plus his
agents and uh in the vice president and
so forth
they greeted the local host committee
and some other people and then
went over to be in the area where we
were going to spot
the president's plane
uh the press plane had come in prior to
that because the press plane at least in
those days i would imagine still the
press plane tries to leave
after the president leaves someplace so
that they're able to see it's like a
death watch frankly they're waiting to
see if something happens getting on the
plane or before he gets on the plane if
the plane crashes or whatever so then
the president's plane takes off the
press plane gets up in the air and if
it's a far enough trip
then they somehow try to get a head of
the present and then they they land
first so that they're in their press
pen and so forth and and and doing their
thing when the president arrives again
like the death watcher or something see
whatever might happen
so you've got the press and you've got
the local
host committee and you've got the vice
president's
group
visiting the present and he
present comes and mrs kennedy and some
staff and agents and whatever come down
and
goes over to the chain link fence
that was there i have pictures of it
that there are all kinds of people on
the other side of the fence and there
are all kinds of people in on the
airplane side of the fence you can't
even you can't even see the fence and
almost many people on the airplane side
of the fence because the hangers on and
the staff and the press and this and
that you know so and president kennedy
and
ms kenny
go along the defense greeting people and
being seen and seeing people
and for a few minutes
and
then
they go over and get in their car and
the motorcade takes off
uh a special
cut was made in the fence to allow the
motorcade to go out to a certain place
you know to start the motorcade and all
that
and uh
the pilot car is
has now gone ahead
and the the lead car that i was in was
just ahead of the
uh presence vehicle
a follow-up car behind him
and um
and then some other vehicles and the
pres the vice president and the staff
and it was it's quite a motorcade buses
and staff cars and vip cars and things
of that type
who was in the lead car with you
the lead car was driven by
chief curry and in his
either his or another unmarked
dallas police car
driving so he was in the front seat
i was in the right front seat
uh
sheriff decker was in
the rear seat and saic sorrows the agent
charged sorrels from the dallas field
office was in the back seat
unprecedented
about how far ahead of the
limousine did the lead car stay
throughout most of the motorcade you
usually try to be
pretty darn close
you know
so that
they can see where you're going all that
because if you have to go to a hospital
you got to do this or that whatever
[Applause]
in those days especially when the driver
didn't come
now probably one of the drivers would
have would have been part of the
advanced team i remember i think i said
before that you would have site agents
depending on how many sites you had a
motorcade agent you'd have the
the uh
technical people the intelligence people
the uh
uh
an airport agent the site at the
trademart agent and so forth
but
uh
the lead car
the presidential car follows that lead
car and he stays up pretty darn close to
the lead car
to keep anybody from from coming in
between the two cars just like the
follow-up car is almost on their bumper
to prevent people
things
cars etc from from coming out of a side
street and being able to get in between
as a matter of fact that's the only
reason why
clint hill was able to get on that that
car
was because it was so so close
uh
to to the president's car and all that
in some of the films that we we've we
have here at the museum that show the
motorcade going along you see the
buildings downtown and there's open
windows and people looking out of the
windows uh was that something that
concerned you as you were as you were
going along but in those days there was
nothing you could do about it
if there's a parade situation today
each each field office has
[Music]
has already made a survey of of known
motorcade routes whether it's in dallas
or new york or
wherever you know to probably the areas
that people would be going to in a
motorcade type situation
they've
agents have inspected the building with
the maintenance people the building
manager
owner whatever
and
today's modern buildings most of them
you can't open up a window now these new
high-rise office buildings and all that
the windows don't open you can't even
throw us a chair through one if you
wanted to
there are some of the older buildings
and and so forth that you still can open
windows but what they do
they put out a notice i mean this is not
a
a country where by
by fiat you can just say you can't open
your windows i mean it's not a
totalitarian country but you can request
people not to open their windows you can
request people not to to bring all their
friends down and and be in your window
because boy this would be a great
vantage point to see this motorcade you
know please don't do that if you want to
see go on down
and whatever or if you are in if you are
in your windows they got to be closed or
whatever
and
they have enough people now with
[Music]
station long with radios
and
counter sniper teams on certain
uh buildings that that look down on
other buildings and all that that belong
to the secret service you can service
kind of sniper teams
and if they see an open window or if
they see something look suspicious
and
also it's requested that people not be
on rooftops and all that and there are
certain things that they do so that you
know if there's someone on that rooftop
ah that's a security person or whatever
you know
so if they see anything that type
immediately
it's broadcast uh such and such a
building the sixth floor right hand side
there's an open window that gets
broadcast to those agents or the police
in that area
so they can immediately check it out or
at least keep it under surveillance if
they can't get there in time and the
same time it goes to the motorcade
we have a home movie that shows the
motorcade making a turn i believe it's
from lemon avenue onto main street and
an agent or two agents from the
follow-up car come and ride on the side
of the presidential limousine why would
they do that when making a turn
uh
they may have seen something in the
crowd or maybe people started out you
know it's
it's not uncommon
it's common for people to try to get out
touch the car touch the
president or whatever
and that's why
some
that's the bone of contention sometimes
be the president and the staff and the
secret service we'd love to have
motorcycles completely surrounding his
car
but
noise
lack of sight back and forth etc they
you know they just don't want it
we'd like to have them in a bubble all
the time if we could which and not just
a plastic one but another one but you
have to give and take in these type of
things and and i would imagine something
happened on that route where either
people were coming out
or something else caused them to to jump
off and run up uh often i mean that's
just that's just done all the time
at one point during the dallas motorcade
there was a
a group of people and they had a sign
that said you know please stop and and
shake our hands and i believe the
motorcade did slow long enough for some
folks to shake the president's hand do
you recall that i i i don't but that
happens a lot
you almost you can plan
depending on
the present that it is
the type of
things that you know he likes or doesn't
like or she i mean i'm sorry i'm not a
chauvinist but
so far we haven't had a lady present so
i'll probably keep saying she you know
that but
rather probably keep saying he but
president kennedy you could almost
always figure
that he went by
a catholic church or catholic school and
there's some nonsense and kids out there
he's going to stop i don't know how many
times i you know you just would know
that and if that was on your particular
route you try to put some police there
ahead of time and all that you know
when
and if
like the sign you said sometimes there's
some signs that you know you know you
don't know what they're going to be
but as you're going along and all of a
sudden you see this sign you say that's
a catchy sign or that's
that's something that i'll bet you that
those people about
10 yards behind us or less are probably
going to stop
and
and it happens it happens a lot
frankly i'd rather see the present go
along
and going along all of a sudden the
president would see something be
interesting stop the car i want to go
want to go over here because that's an
unplanned thing now where is dangerous
is
that if somebody has a catchy thing
or some reason you know somehow it's
going to tickle tickle their fancy
and then plan it so that
this he's probably going to stop here so
i'm going to be the assassin here and so
forth but it's the true unplanned things
uh
you don't have to worry as much on those
unplanned things sometimes people did
didn't that drive you nuts when when you
stopped at such such a place you know
frankly i'd rather have him stop there
when no one knew that he was going to do
it than some place that
that you would know about
there had been some andy kennedy
literature um
in dallas the the wanted for treason
poster and the the black bordered ad and
the dallas morning news
you saw this prior to the motorcade
what did you what'd you think about it
well you know it's a free country they
can say what they want you know you'd
have a
you'd uh
be concerned about it but you've made
your plans and you've done the best
thing you can and just
hope that everything will work did you
report it to anybody or or was that not
the police
police brought it yeah i can't remember
now someone brought to my attention uh
mr sorrells had already seen the the
flyer for example the police brought it
to my attention they knew it before i
did
do you have any idea whether president
kennedy
saw any of that literature i do not know
during motorcade
were you focused on the car
or were you were you looking at the
crowds
i
probably should have had a head on a
swivel because i would be looking
forward
for example i remember looking forward
here
you know at the overpass
and and seeing
people up there with ben arrangement
that there'd be
a
a policeman
at least up there and
if anybody they couldn't be directly
over us and so forth well there were
some people standing on that and i was
trying to kind of making a motion like
this you know to the policeman you know
get these people away from us and so
forth
i also would keep looking behind to make
sure that
to tell chief curry to speed up to slow
up to whatever depending on the
situation i'd be looking at the crowds
also
uh just
in case i i could see something and
broadcast to
the follow-up car or particularly the
president's car saying watch out for
such and such on the right left so
my head would have been on a swivel the
whole time looking ahead looking forward
looking i mean looking sideways looking
backwards
uh as you entered dealy plaza did you
make any comments to chief curry
i don't remember that i did
i seem to remember reading in your
testimony that you made the comment that
you were only about five minutes away
yes
i think i probably asked him aren't we
about four or five minutes from the
trade center and i think he said yes and
i said
okay so uh yeah
i can't remember now whether
i broadcast to
to the people out the trademart i think
he did to his uh
the various officers that were uh on
duty out
of the trademark
well if you can tell me in as much
detail as you remember about the the
assassination itself
um i believe i was just
about to go under the uh
pretty pretty close anyway to the the
underpass to go on this stemmons freeway
sometime a little bit later
and i heard a
shot like that and then i heard another
one
and then that third one was a little
closer to the second one then the second
one was to the first one
and
i didn't think firecrackers i didn't
think pop balloons i thought
shots
and i thought immediately that it
you know because i was facing that way i
thought immediately that it come from
over my right hand shoulder which
in fact it had
and
it was it was so quick and all that and
i think almost immediately
we heard
from the from the president's car the
assistant aiden charge kellerman
you know
said something about
florida or hurry or president might be
hit around that same time a motorcycle
has pulled up alongside of us i believe
and said to chief curry that
that the president had been hit
and uh
both of us said to one another we got to
get to parkland hospital and he started
broadcasting whatever he had to do and i
started calling on my radio to people
and so forth and
he he floored it and we went out
steven's freeway going like heck and as
a matter of fact lost
uh most of the motorcade you know that
wasn't part of the security bubble
and as a matter of fact they not even
knowing what had happened or maybe uh
wondering what had happened
the
part of the motorcade pulled into the
trademark
not knowing that we'd gone right on by
the trade martin and gone to parkland
hospital
but we went about as fast as you can go
out through there and i don't know how
clint hill ever stayed on that car
during the uh during the assassination
itself did you did you see the president
or mrs kennedy
[Music]
uh no you mean back behind you behind no
you didn't see anything so you weren't
actually aware who was hit or if anybody
no i just heard the shots and then was
told that
uh the president had been hit so what
yeah
and you think the shots came from i know
they came from my back right now i mean
that
i
fired enough before and had fired enough
synths and
firing ranges and all that i do rifle
fire and i uh
i know where the shots came from
well um
as you
got to parkland hospital why don't you
pick up the story there and tell me what
happened
chief curry had
had already
had either called had someone notify
the hospital
that we were on our way
and when we arrived
i ran in the emergency
area
and met
someone coming with a couple of
gurneys and all that and turned around
and helped them get back out
these gurneys out to the car
of course governor conley
and his wife had been in
the jump seats which are full
up seats and and they were in front of
the president and and mrs kennedy
and uh
governor conley had to be moved before
the president could be moved
and then i helped put president kennedy
and with other agents and people and all
that and on the gurneys and go into the
emergency room area and to the
trauma
place there where we were guided to
and originally went on in
with the president and
the doctor and
the people were pushing the gurney and
all that
and then
not too much later i don't even know how
much longer but i went back outside to
make sure that
[Music]
because my advance wasn't done make sure
make sure that
we had people
from the hospital just letting the
proper people in the area that they're
agents
in the area i soon found out that they
were already taking care of
president johnson and another area close
by the agents adam
and so forth
and then went to one of the uh
one of the offices nearby where there's
a telephone and called washington and
uh kept the line open in washington with
our secret service headquarters
all the time we were there
did you get a a good look at the
president's wounds when you approached
the motorcade
no i don't know if clint hill had
already put his coat over his head at
that time or not i i don't recall
whether
but i know that when
we were in the
trauma room
and when they were starting to take care
of him before i left i left the room
that he was
[Music]
not moving he was extremely gray i mean
it's
i can't describe the color
that he was
did you feel at that time but it was a
it was a fatal wound
i yeah i think i did in my mind
um
the the back of the limousine um
it was it was pretty bloody did you
notice that when you when you went up to
it
um was mrs did you encounter mrs kennedy
or have any communication with her
during this i didn't have any
communication with her but she she went
on in you know with us to the trauma
room and she was in there for a while
and i think her staff took her out and
so far
what were you what were you feeling at
this moment
uh
shock
by
you know you wonder you know
everything's going through your mind you
know what what could i have done that i
didn't do how did i did i mess up and if
so how
i was
i was
the first agent
to lose the president
and to this day i'm still the first
agent to lose a present
that
i can't say that i couldn't believe it
because you know that it can happen all
the time but i was in shock that it that
it did happen i don't mean in shock like
you know people with a wound or
something that go into shock but i was
um
just
you know my gosh it did happen type of
thing you know
there have been stories that
in the immediate aftermath there in
parkland there was some uh
confrontations an actual physical
struggle between some fbi agents and
some secret service agents do you recall
that i i don't know i see i wouldn't
have been
right off the bat i was inside
and i was in the trauma room and then
from there to the to the office that and
i stayed there at that telephone and all
that
and um
[Music]
i didn't leave until we took
uh
the body out
to put it in the uh
the undertaker's hearse or whatever i
think it was a hearse
and uh
and then on
then riding on on out to the uh
out to the airport to put the body help
put the body on the airplane
some of the agents had already left
by that time because they'd taken vice
president then vice president humphrey
listen to me vice president johnson i'm
sorry
i was with vice president humphrey so
once in a while i'll get them mixed up
um
but some of the agents had already gone
out with
vice president johnson and then of
course he was uh
he was not sworn in because he waited
for for mrs kennedy to get out there
before he was sworn in
and that was after we we got out of the
place
um a point of controversy that has come
up over the years is the fact that while
the motorcade was there in the in the in
the parkland bay there some secret
service agents got some buckets and
sponges and started wiping out the back
of the limousine
i know you weren't part of the group
that did that but do you have any idea
why they they would have done that
immediately at that point no i don't
okay
it's just something i wanted to ask
because it's stuff that comes up yeah
right
okay um and one other thing i want to
ask you about the motorcade another
another myth is that the
lead car actually stopped after you
emerged from the triple underpass the
lead car
lead car never stopped never stopped
okay
okay well once you got
back out to love field with the uh with
the casket why don't you go ahead and
pick up the story there if you would
well waited outs outside the airplane
chief curry you know had gone out with
with vice president johnson so chief
curry was inside and he was in in there
when
the federal judge
came and swore in uh vice president
johnson to become president
and then aft uh pretty soon the uh
the the plane started taxi and left
and i rode uh
i rode with chief curry in in his car
down to uh police headquarters
and uh i believe uh
agent in charge charles was
uh was i don't know if he was at his
office but he eventually he he came over
to uh police headquarters also
and
i was i was there in police headquarters
for for a number of hours
and i saw
the complete chaos you know that was
there you you wouldn't believe how many
people
were in there i you know people in off
the street the police themselves the
news people uh
you could hardly walk up and down the
corridors for the amount of people that
were in there
um
at one point i i i looked in and uh
uh
his name was fritz i can't remember if
he was a captain or whatever he was
captain wilfred he was almost i think he
was chief of homicide detectives
and uh listened in on some of his uh
and mr sorrells
and with them uh
questioning
questioning oswald
and um
back around then sometime later i went
over to
fbi office
and then uh
[Music]
eventually
uh was was taken to
one of the air force bases near here and
rode back to washington dc to andrews
air force base
with some of the evidence that they had
collected and cuffed the fbi agents that
were on the plane and
we landed back there about six in the
morning six or six thirty in the morning
at andrews air force base uh eastern
time
while you were at the police station did
you ever see lee harvey oswald no
um did you
were you ever did you sit in on some of
the questions
i watched watched some of it and i saw a
couple of times when uh
i think they moved them from one place
to another place but
never talked to them never
considering your position
did you have any personal feelings when
you saw this man
uh
i suppose yeah i really can't even think
right now about it because i still
[Music]
no i i
i can't recall any particular feelings
that i had about him
is there anything else uh relating to
the fbi that that occurred here in
dallas that's that's worth putting on
the on the record not that i had
anything to do with
do you recall what the initial thought
was i mean there's there's been talk
that uh originally they might have
thought it was some sort of uh
conspiracy but it was a russian plot or
something like that were you were you
privy to any of those discussions by the
fbi no okay well
um
i just i just know that
they wondered if if it was part of a
plot to get the president and the vice
president that's why he wanted him out
and
back in washington as soon as possible
and
i was i wasn't a part of any discussion
really about that okay
once you got back in washington um
what what part did you play in the
funeral and and what other uh
i i gave a
i gave a written written statement on
the 23rd of
to my knowledge of everything that i
knew that i had done and that people had
done on on the 22nd
and then on the 1st of december i wrote
to memoranda
one you know
everything that i could remember about
the advance from the
first hearing about it on the 4th of
november through the 21st of november
then a separate one which was more
detailed than the one that i'd done on
the 23rd
uh for events that i could recall on the
22nd
and
but that wasn't until december 1st but
you asked me about the funeral so
i was on duty
at
at the at the funeral
i was on duty at the gravesite
and
[Music]
that was uh
that was really something you know
the the the funeral and uh
being a part of it and the uh
the music and everything that was going
on i i remember just being extremely sad
being extremely uh
sorry
you know
all right
and the secret service got me pretty
busy
like i said you know
the day after it i
i was i was in and i i went to work
each day
primarily the first first few days it
was
it was all talking to people about the
advance and this and that
and writing things for
for the record and all that
[Music]
eventually i gave
testimony to the one report and then
then
later what was it 78 or whenever it was
that the
house
committee special special committee i
testified at that also
but
um i stayed on
i
i don't know that there was any formal
request but i think the
i may have indicated in some way that
that i wanted to
to stay on protection for a while
ordinarily i probably would have been
transferring as i said i came from
syracuse to
the in those days the white house detail
which now presidential protective
division
i got there in 61
spring 61 this was fall
of
63.
i probably
[Music]
without anything happening in dallas i
probably would have been there
another year maybe a year and a half and
then transferred to some
field office
then back maybe to washington some
capacity then back to another field
office because it's not uncommon for
agents to be transferred six seven or
eight times in their career
in my mind
i felt that i owed it
to protection
to stay in protection for a while if
they would let me
[Music]
and
uh
you know the the secret service uh
didn't fire me
i don't think there was a reason to but
i mean they could have found reasons too
they didn't fire me they didn't transfer
me to to one of the places that
the people hear about you know if
there's if there's an agent that they
want to discipline or something whether
it's the fbi the secret service or
internal revenue
they're always one or two offices where
they're going to ship joe blow off to to
one of the offices kind of repentance or
whatever it is they never sent me to
some place in montana to an office or
something like that
i continued on uh
working i uh
was on
president johnson's detail then from
from that point on until
[Music]
i went to vice president humphreys
detail in uh in 1966
and i stayed there until about 1968
when i went with vice president elect
agnew
and then i had
then i was sent over to our office of
protection
in in headquarters where i
had a couple i got promoted in
the humphrey detail
then i got promoted on the agnew detail
to assist an agent in charge of the
detail
then i was made a special agent in
charge a brand new position in the
office of protection where
uh
i was the one that filtered out the
request for for post standards and you
know an advance agent that someplace
would call in and say now that they had
more agents
i need
i need 30 agents in austin for
vice president so-and-so or present
so-and-so
and i'd wake up in the middle of night
was that austin or boston yeah
but
i got those requests and then i also had
something to do with people being
transferred in and out of protective
divisions
and
then
also for
had quite a bit to do with
transferring people temporarily
if
the queen of
england was coming or the prime minister
of
england or great britain
or the
emperor japan or something like that was
coming
i had to go and borrow agents from the
office of investigations the office
investigation i was in office of
protection
we had all the details whether they were
temporary details or regular details
like the uh the present the vice
president the candidate details the the
whatever
and
if if we found out that king husseina
jordan was coming to town hopefully it
wasn't late on a friday afternoon and he
was coming on sunday but often it
happened
and i had to go over the office of of
investigations because they're the ones
that had the
they're the ones that had the
demand power
out
in the countryside
and you'd say to the deputy assistant
director over there look
king hussein is coming in
he's going to arrive in new york city
day after tomorrow
and we got to put a detail together
and
it might be for three days it might be
for
three weeks
and
i was then involved quite a bit in the
25th anniversary of the u.n
which happened up in new york city and
we were
by that time we had heads of state heads
of government and we were charged with
protecting people that came to the u.n
that that fall
for you and un-25 of course are
you know more than more than the normal
amount of premiers and prime ministers
and kings and
uh
that type of thing and uh
was up in new york city from from august
through november to part of november on
that deal
eventually became uh
[Music]
the secret service sent me to cornell
graduate school right after that
particular thing
because i started getting a little
burned out on that one seven in the
mornings about 11 o'clock every night
for about four or four months
and
then this made the
agent in charge of our liaison division
which we hadn't had
in 1963
but that was one of the things that one
report brought out we should have better
liaison with the other federal agencies
and so forth so
in
i was about the third agent in charge of
that but eventually we had liaison
agents
spending
a lot of time with the fbi with the cia
with nsa the national security agency
which you may or may not have heard of
and they're the ones that
hear the talk out of out of the ether
ways and so forth
[Music]
and all that around and uh
everything from and customs state
department and so forth
and then went from there to uh
deputy assistant director for uh
inspection
that would be like internal affairs in a
in a police department or the ig or some
inspector general something like that
deputy assistant uh director for uh
for that and
with that you would have the internal
investigation if any
one of the agents
you know it was either suspected or was
pointed out as maybe having
done something wrong or something like
that that was the b part and the a part
was just inspecting the offices and
you'd have
inspectors
who are
people that have been an agent in charge
of about a medium field office to a
large field office
and then there are assistant assistant
inspectors and they they would do
investigations if need be and they'd
also inspect the offices to make sure
they were
the liaison with with the local
officials to see that everything was was
all right but between the secret service
and the
the local people whether it's the mayor
the police the whatever
[Music]
check the records to make sure they're
doing their investigations properly
check with the people they'd have to
work with on any protectees that were
coming through and all that so
then became the acting assistant
director of secret service for
inspection
and
then i left before i retired
instead of becoming the assistant
director for inspection
what year did you retire i retired in
1981.
what did you talk about with the other
agents
some of the other agents that were
involved on the dallas detail what did
you what did you talk about in the
aftermath
um
in a way
a lot of the agents didn't talk to me
about it except in one regard
and to my dying day i will be
very grateful for this
um
they would come up to me and say if it
had to happen
to any agent win
we're glad it was you
and i mean you know originally it's
you know but they meant that in a good
way
i took pride in the fact that they knew
that i had already done a good advance
that had done at least as much and
probably in certain phases of this
dallas events more than most people had
done
they knew i didn't drink and there was
always that you know there was that
problem that had come up
uh
they knew i didn't fool around
and so
uh
i i i took that as a compliment and they
met it as a compliment
we didn't talk very much other than
uh
they really didn't we didn't talk too
much about the advance or or what had
happened
i think part of it was they didn't want
to bring up certain things
but
about really about the most
and to this day i still get to get some
of that that if it had to happen we're
glad we're glad it was you
um one thing though and here's an
anecdote for you
after i was at headquarters
i would
you know get to work about 7 38 in the
morning and i'd go back i'd leave home
about 6 30 both because there was
so much going on or something to do
and because you couldn't get out of dc
at 5 or 5 30 and go go south on shirley
highway or the interstate 95 because
you're a bumper to bumper to take you
you know if you waited it at the office
an extra hour you'd probably only be 10
minutes longer getting home if you just
started
so often and especially in the in the
fall and the winter and the early
spring i went over what's called the
memorial bridge and if you've been in
washington
memorial bridge as you're going into
virginia you look at arlington cemetery
and at night
you see a little flickering light
and that's president kennedy's grave
and
that was my way home
and so for
a number of years
every time i went home i'd cross
virginia over into virginia memorial
bridge and i'd see that little
flickering light
that was quite a
reminder did you uh ever talk to clint
hill about his experiences that day
clint hill's a very good friend of mine
and we we talk but we don't talk about
that
he did a tremendous job he just i don't
know how he made it i don't know how he
made it up onto the car in the first
place but in the second place especially
when he slipped and almost fell down
but the most important thing how he
stayed on that car when we were going 60
and 70 miles an hour down the stems
freeway and about as fast as
as we could often and and then over into
parkland hospital it's just it's
mind-boggling how he held on
the dallas police department came under
a great deal of criticism after the
assassination especially for allowing
jack ruby to get into the basement and
assassinate uh oswald um
do you think that um just based on your
observations and your advance work do
you think that a lot of that criticism
was justified at the dallas police
[Applause]
there are police buffs
all over
all the time
and
that'll always be that way if
policemen police women know all kinds of
people in town
and they don't know what's in their
thoughts
and
i i know that in many cases
they'll let an acquaintance come on in
where they're not supposed to go and
99 times not 100 it won't matter
like i said originally there was just
such a mess you know on the afternoon of
the 22nd
in police headquarters
that's because just they had other
things going on and there were just
so many people flooding in there with
things that they had going on they just
had an officer shot they had that on
their mind the president united states
had just been killed
and all that and so
it just all added to the thing where
there was chaos
and
it probably was still chaos a couple of
days later when when oswald was shot
and
as i understand it
he was known to many many people not
only in
in the city around the city both
civilians and police and all that
uh
you know they never gave it a thought
uh you testified to the warren
commission for for a lengthy period of
time do you recall any any details no i
i really don't okay
i uh
on the fact that i remember it was
afternoon i was there for a number of
hours
but uh
treated very well i recall but i i have
no idea even you know other than i
probably said roughly the same things
that i'm saying here and that i've said
other times later
you mentioned before we started
recording that for a number of years you
you couldn't talk about this subject
that's right can you can you talk about
why that was
um
well i would get quite emotional
i really would
thinking about
you know again you know was there
anything i could have done that i didn't
do
uh the what ifs
that that we all know about
um
i just
thinking you know how what
how much
the world changed because of that one
one thing that i was a part of
and the fact that uh
you know i was the first agent that got
a president killed and
and to this day i am
so i'd get quite emotional about it
but i gave my first interview around the
25th of uh anniversary the thing
and
i still get somewhat emotional about it
but especially when i talk about the
secret service and how they treated me
and uh there have been times in the past
i don't think i did it today but when i
talk about the agents that they come up
to me and say if it had to happen we're
glad it was you
um there have been times when i've had
tears streaming down my eyes uh talking
to you about that
but i'm a little emotional right now
talking about it but not the extent that
i was before
well it's been 40 years this year since
the assassination took took place you're
you're back here in dallas
are there any particular thoughts or
feelings being back here in this spot 40
years later
no i've
our former agents association had a
we have an annual convention every year
someplace
last week it was in chicago and i was
there
i've been an officer of one kind or
another either president vice president
president-elect
past president or board member
for 20 years and i just gave it up i
will be just a regular member now like a
lot of them
this past year
and
well i stopped being a board member last
week it didn't run for reelection
but the
[Music]
well got off on tangent i'm sorry
we're talking about it being 40 years
and you'll be back here in dallas yeah
right okay well
uh and i can't remember how long ago it
was but it was before
your uh museum uh
was made
i'm gonna we had a
one of our annual conferences in dallas
and i had not been here
in dallas as part
while i was still in the secret service
from from 63 to 71
um
no plan of it it just happened that
whatever protectee
i was with whether it was a vice
president or president
never happened to come to dallas and so
i hadn't been there then
and uh like i came to dallas and i'm
gonna guess it was maybe uh
uh
[Music]
you know probably
80
88 something like that that we had a
conference in dallas we've since had one
you know we had one in fort worth and
never had one in houston but
you weren't open then anyway and when
when was the opening in february of 89
89 what was prior to that that i was
here
and i remember that
they had buses for us to come down to
dealey plaza
and that was the first first time
uh by that time i'd been retired for uh
you know six or seven years whatever it
was we came down to daley plaza and i
looked at dealey plaza and
you know and then went back and we had
our other functions for two or three
days and
and so forth
then uh i was here last i was here in
october of last year
and that's where uh the first time that
i came to uh
and here and i met mr mack and he gave
us a special tour
and then this time so this is the third
time i've been back since 1963.
can i ask what you think of the idea of
having a museum here at the side in this
building well if you're going to have a
museum you can't have it in a more
apropos place than than where it
happened
you know
if you had it intended in timbuktu or in
some place in idaho it just wouldn't
have the uh
the impact that it does here
and uh
i think they've done an excellent job
with it
and i enjoyed my tour here last october
very very much and
and again that's something that i
wouldn't have been able to do years ago
either you know but uh
free weekdays at 1-877 on c-span that's
1-877-662
american perspectives continues now on
this 40th anniversary of john f
kennedy's assassination
the late dr james carrico was one of the
parkland hospital surgeons who tried to
save president kennedy's life
in 1997 he took part in an oral history
project conducted by the sixth floor
museum at dilly plaza this is the first
time this interview has ever been shown
on television
do you recall
when you heard or you thought you might
have had about him coming
to dallas on a political trip i
i knew it was coming but there was a lot
of uh as i'm sure you're aware really uh
negative uh
statements in the paper about
uh
kennedy and some real hateful stuff in
the paper and we were aware of that and
i thought that was at the time i
i didn't think that
was going to help anybody
uh
i didn't have any real thoughts about
his coming or any any concept because at
the hospital
i guess particularly since this was a
place where
uh some
someone who would
what happened with nasa would be brought
was there any uh
advanced preparation in any way just a
contingency
plan if something
happened while the president was in the
city no as a matter of fact one of the
big differences in then and now
is not just not only the hospitals
preparation but the secret service
preparation for for presidential
business
at that time there hadn't been a
president assassinated in probably 50
years i don't know exact time and it
never really
seriously occurred to anybody
that that the president would actually
be harmed at least to anybody i knew
they uh
oh go ahead as you're well aware right
now when a president
visits visits any city
the secret service precedes him
they
select the hospital where he'll go they
select the physician
a whole situation set up his medical
records are made available
he's followed by a
paramedic band
etc
in 1963
there was as far as i know and i'm
pretty sure i know this no pre-planning
the reason they came to parkland simply
because
they're headed that way and that's where
all the injured patients went
uh the
we didn't there was no uh selection of
hospital or letting us know his blood
type or anything else
so the secret service did not while they
had been around town
i'm sure yes i'm confident with the
parade route and the luncheon
arrangements and all this sure as far as
you know they never came to as far as i
know there were no hospital arrangements
and certainly there was no
information provided about the
president's health status or anything
like that
well
uh
zeroing in on the day of november 22
1963 canada can you
kind of reconstruct your day
for us and
were you at the hospital overnight did
you get up that morning were you right i
i don't uh i don't remember the early
morning the the
we i was on actually assigned to surgery
c which is an elective surgery service
uh and it was our day to admit patients
so we came in
i'm confident we came in early that
morning made rounds it was also our
clinic day we didn't
operate that day we had our our
basically office so
we
early in the morning probably 8 30 or 9
went over to to our clinic and started
seeing
patients both patients would operate on
and patients who were
being evaluated for for new operations
about 11 30
we were getting pretty close to
through with our clinic and we got a
call from the emergency room that there
were three patients down there to be
evaluated for admission
this was not
president kennedy this would these were
three patients who had come to parkland
for uh
for care
uh the
and somebody needed to go down one of
our service needed to go down and start
seeing those patients and evaluating
them we also had scheduled a
special x-ray where a patient had we
thought that blood clots in his lungs
and somebody had to go down and
participate in doing that x-ray study
the x-ray study sounded like a whole lot
more fun than working up three patients
so jerry gustafson who was a year ahead
of me in the program and i flipped and
he won the coin flip he got he had the
privilege of going to do the x-ray study
and i
went down the emergency room to start
evaluating the
patients that we were we were going to
end up admitting so that's how i got
down to the emergency room that's why
you were there
an hour later i guess about just about
just about 12 30 yeah did you call
having any thoughts or any discussion
about oh gee we're missing the parade or
anything like that or is that just you
know i the only we didn't the only the
only comment i made
i remember and i'm sure if i remember it
or i remember dr jenkins talking about
it dr jenkins commented on the president
being in town and
hoped everything went well so do you
remember sort of exactly
how you first heard what you were doing
at the time
a dispatch came in right
we were
again i may be telling you more than you
want to hear no no we don't want to hear
it all the uh
the other thing which is different we
talked about how different things are
yes right now as as you know there there
are uh
mobile intensive care units really
paramedic
equipped fans ems's
who who
pick up injured patients pick up ill
patients they have direct radio
communications with the hospitals we
know what's coming we can actually help
direct their care before the patients
get here
in 63 none of that existed i mean that
all started really about 69.
dallas really did have a very
sophisticated system for the time
but it consisted of some of the
ambulances having radios which connect
with the police dispatcher and the
police dispatcher would then call the
hospital
and say
you know ex-patients are coming
there was frequently some confusion and
all that
communication with several people
so a lot of times we got a call from the
police dispatcher which turned out to be
false alarm or overstated
so
that leads up to what happened then we
one of the nurses came out
and told dick delaney richard delaney
who was actually in charge of the
emergency room that day that she just
got a call from the police dispatcher
and the president had been shot he was
on his way to the hospital
only the president
that's all that was the first message i
remember president's been shots on his
way to the hospital
uh
the uh i mean the obvious question is is
what do you do
well first thing you do is you don't
want to believe it
you know and with all the misinformation
that that happened in a situation like
that it was easy to say
yeah it must be wrong and it can't be
right but the other thing you do is you
get to start getting ready
so
we had the nurses
paged
the appropriate people to come help take
care of an injured patient they paid the
surgery team the murder the rest of the
surgery team on call
the
chief resident who was ron jones who's
now chief of surgery at baylor yeah
anyone you can identify by name and be
helpful yeah matt malcolm perry who was
the attending on call that day
dr tom shires who was the chief of
surgery he was actually in galveston
given a
paper but obviously the people in the
emergency room didn't know that but
basically they paid the whole
resuscitation team
and we hoped it wasn't enough
we hope very much it was a false alarm
right we also
were you know there's always a risk that
you can recall in a fossil line anyway
it seemed like two or three minutes uh
after we got the message that
door to the emergency room
came open and
a patient was rolled in
and
it was that was governor connolly as a
matter of fact and the reason governor
conley was brought in first i believe is
because he was sitting in the jump seat
well that's the explanation they had to
remove him before the company right so
they had to get the governor out of the
way and they brought him in first
uh
so we looked at
governor conley and he had a
a a large wound in the front of his
chest and was actually unconscious from
from the abnormal breathing breathing
that results from that large wound
we knew he was
hurt badly
we knew we figured we could treat him if
that was all was wrong and we also knew
it wasn't the president
it didn't occur to either delaney or i
who it was we were only interested in
who it wasn't yes and it was not the
president so we kind of heaved this
great sigh of relief and
said you know maybe it's a secret
service man but we'll take care of him
and so he rolled we rolled him into
trauma room two which is big really the
biggest trauma room
and uh did that cause you to divide your
team up in any sense
of expertise not really because i mean
the beauty of parkland then and now is
is
is the contingency i mean you there's a
you start you have a team but you have
tremendous backup and so you can always
get more more health and expertise i
guess nothing's always but you can
handle an immense amount of work when
you need to yeah but basically delaney
and i both went in the room with him
then we knew the rest of the support was
on the way
the way you treat a wound like that is
you plug the hole basically when you
breathe air normally goes in here if
you've got a hole this big air goes in
there so you plug that hole
in that part
and
you plug that hole and then the air
starts going in the right way and the
governor started waking up
the
so about that time
another patient was rolled into trauma
room one
and delaney and i kind of looked at each
other and i'm not sure how we decided
but basically we decided delaney would
stay with
the governor
and i'd go see about the patient in the
other room
and that's
how i ended up being in the presidency
and in that room do you recall at that
time
he was there exactly when uh mrs kennedy
was kind of standing by the door
my recollection is there were two men
in the room and i assumed they were the
driver or secret service people
they
very rapidly
stepped aside when when
we came in
and did anybody that mr kennedy speak to
you
i know i don't recall any
spoken interchange
i think they were getting out getting
out of it
they they they they
clearly saw we were coming in and take
care of things and miss kennedy as i
recall stood by the door for a long time
and the two the two gentlemen
i never saw them again that are
recognized
from this point
probably you're going to need as much
you can to
give a sort of specific
descriptions that the medical
professional would recognize and then
maybe also the kind of late person like
what
what you saw how you approached the
problem who did who was doing what okay
uh the uh
you know the the the uh people that were
there were
that i remember and i'm i'm sure there
were others were myself
a nurse diane baurin
b-o-w-r-e-n i think
uh and two interns
uh marty white who's uh
now uh
head of the organ bank here in dallas
there's a lot of
people still around
uh and an oral surgery resident whose
name i don't remember right now oral
surgery intern
so that was the team the the your job in
a patient who's severely injured
it kind of goes in the steps of do what
takes keeps patient alive
then you go back and evaluate
the injuries more detail and kind of
make your long-term plan
and the keeping alive first you got to
have way to breathe seconds you got to
be breathing third your heart's got to
be pumping and fourth your your head's
got to be working your nervous system is
going to be working so the your job is
exactly that you see what's going on
with the airway see what's going with
breathing you see what's going on with
the circulation and then you look at
that neurological function
uh
the
usually one person kind of takes charge
and everybody else one one team gets
some
the ivs going to support circulation the
nurse kind of gets the patient undressed
and and gets the
keeps things flowing and that's pretty
much what we did uh dark marty white and
uh
the other intern started doing a cut
down on the president's right ankle i
think cut down is where you
where you start an iv by actually making
an incision and putting a little tube in
the big tube in the vein so you can give
a lot of blood and fluid if you need to
uh
diane and i looked at the president
overall so that he was
was not breath he was breathing very
erratically call it agonal respiration
it's kind of gas
the impression was
that he was not dead at this point he
watched that at this point you do this
anyway
yeah the the uh well we looked at him
and he still had some breathing he still
had some heartbeat
he had a terrible looking wound but that
wound you you kind of really defer to
later in terms of evaluating in detail
uh
the principle is
uh
if you've got somebody who's
got a what looks like a terrible injury
in his dip
first thing you do is you you do the
things i talked about you get the airway
going you get them breathing then you
see
then you have time
to evaluate the extent of the injury
my
i
told folks before that the thoughts that
that i remember going through my head
takes longer to describe them than it
took to have them were
were first
presidents had it i mean he's not gonna
make it
and that was right
second is uh we gotta do something
uh that was the political what the
medical thoughts you know we can't just
let the president die third thought was
uh
gosh what if we get him alive and then
he's a vegetable
and the the rational thought was
treat this patient like anybody else get
his airway under control get him
breathing get a circulation going then
you can can
decide about all that other situation
so that's what we did uh too well you
obviously must really felt being aware
of the president the
sense of responsibility were you
thinking
in terms of history or just
gotchas
the uh i mean i guess this is on my
shoulders those brief thoughts and then
they you know it took a long time to say
it took about that long to have them
were were uh
where the the non-medical thoughts if
you will you know i mean the
the i guess my major thoughts were
you know i really didn't think about the
historical impact what that's going to
do i said well our job is to take care
of the president and that's uh
i we got kind of the
reputation of medicine and everything
else on our back for a second there and
then that's when the
rational thoughts took over and says
okay
we know how to do this i mean whether
this is the president or or whoever we
know how to take care of this guy we
and so
it became pretty much
unemotional and uh not automatic but
dispassion at that point professional
aspect kicked in as it did i think with
law enforcement agencies and reporters
and everything right so there was that
short personal
emotional what am i going to do feeling
and then the professional aspect is you
say kicked in and you know what to do
and that's what you're trained to do
okay so kind of go ahead okay so the the
procedure then is to
first see if the president's br breathe
has an airway and he really didn't we
when we looked at him he had
we saw this
wound up here inside of his head
that was readily apparent oh yeah he was
laying on his back laying on his back
and came in and
that was obvious would this be the point
you want to kind of illustrate
that in terms of
of where on his head and if it's yeah
what did you see that's fine it can't
it's kind of out of order medically but
it's probably
inorder forensically okay yeah the the
what i remember and i was telling dr
montgomery earlier
with the president laying on his back
i could see the whole wound in his head
and that's important because that really
doesn't fit perfectly what we wrote down
later
so that meant it had to be in the uh
well it was about right here as i recall
and about as big as i'm showing with my
hand about you know a big chunk of bone
and scalp missing
and the fact that you could see all of
it from the front and that involved the
parietal bone which is this big skull
bone and the temporal bone which is this
big skull
so we saw that hole we saw
uh he had a little hole right
was that about another sort of
controversial thing was like was this
above his
his collar line or slightly below by by
the time what are you calling i looked
diane the nurse had started taking his
clothes off
it's which was her job so i really
didn't don't know
whether it was through the collar or not
but it was certainly
at the collar line it was just about
right there just to the right of the
trachea and just
certainly where his collar should have
been and she was the one that removed
the tie
uh or you know or yeah i i mean i think
it was cut off is that right that's
correct i uh would that be
normal
yeah
you know i was doing other stuff i was
lifting his head and stuff and diane was
doing that but what you normally do is
just take scissors
right there or right there so that both
gets the collar and
the tie beside the knot and then you
just go right on down take shirt off and
then you can see the patient's chest of
breathing and all that so i that's diane
bauerin was doing that while i was
actually trying to
evaluate what we're going to do
i think i just messed up your microphone
you know
all right you're getting it okay okay
the uh
anyway so the next thing since he really
wasn't breathing very well the next
thing to do was was try to get him
breathing better
and that involved putting in an
endotracheal tube which is a tube which
goes through the mouth down into the
windpipe
uh and
you can breathe through
so we got that done
and at that time we could see that there
was some
some
blood beside the the the larynx which is
is
down deep in the throat
okay from inside along along about here
you know that would be inside you
actually take okay you take a a lighted
instrument and you look down
and see the the the windpipe inside the
at the bottom of the throat and then you
put tubing when i look down there i
could see that there was
some some bruising and some some
abnormal swelling over to the right side
of the the windpipe
and we were able to slip the tube in
into his trachea and should have been
able to to breathe better at that point
that head wound which uh you're well
aware of been
been
such a part of controversy and
various interpretations and so forth did
you have any impression at that point
say the direction was it
a shot that came from the front from the
rear just
no i mean the two two two answers to
that
uh
really didn't and that's not what you
think about at a time like that although
obviously you can't separate thoughts
that much
the other is that that that wound
certainly this one certainly looked like
an exit wound i mean just because things
were just really blown up blown away
uh okay
exit towards the back you're saying
they're just out just just out it looks
like you mean you got wounds go in and
ones that go out this was an out
okay and that was the way it looked like
but it did there was nothing about it
that would say whether the entrance had
come from the front or from the back i
see this looked like where a bullet went
out i see
well watch it once again on my emphasize
now this was really in a sense
routine this team worked with these kind
of emergencies
every day right correct and so
that aspect of it was
not that unusual for you correct okay
and also the the order of things so you
you
try to keep the patient alive you try to
treat their wounds and then
then in the patients where you're not
successful then we would work with the
medical examiner to
try to figure out help them figure out
the forensics they do they were really
the forensic experts we provided the
clinical information and sort of
as much as we can clarify the two wounds
uh
did you ever
determine exactly in your own mind
where the uh the shoulder or neck wound
and just recently now something's come
out about uh
gerald ford is on warren commission uh
slightly altering
uh a description there that's
kind of brought some
stirred the issue again sure the well
the
the the simple answer is the only wounds
i saw the only ones we saw
were this
wound here
in this big hole here we we never
saw the
wounds in the president's back
then
the medical process is we got his airway
going
then we cooked him up to the ventilator
and
we're trying to help him breathe
then
you got to answer how's his breathing
going and to that to answer that you got
to ask are there any
major holes in his
chest wall like the governor had in his
chest well which would impair his
breathing
so you don't
always roll the patient over to look at
that particularly in the situation where
you're in you don't roll them over you
just put your hands behind the patient's
back down about the belt and then kind
of move up feeling to try to make sure
that
the body cavities are intact
and in doing that
did not detect any big holes and
obviously didn't uh see
what apparently turned out to be two
small ones one kind of
over the shoulder and one back here
way back in the lower lower back of the
head so we never saw those two ones in
the back
and that's the long answer to a short
question no well we probably need long
answers to almost a local question
in that sense
and uh the reason we didn't is that that
that was at least at that point that was
not part of the appropriate medical exam
to try to find
that would actually require to roll the
patient over washing blood off etc and
clearly in somebody that you're
struggling to keep alive you don't do
that
is there anything else we need to fill
in here before say the point where
it was determined he was dead or
declared dead and who called that shot
uh
not really or we can feel i mean there's
some medical stuff which which we could
film in briefly uh after we got the two
men tried to breathe
for him he still wasn't breathing very
well
and his heart rate was slowing down and
his heart actually stopped
when his heart stopped
by that time dr perry dr jones dr
jenkins
dr giseky that assistant chief
anesthesia and dr baxter a number of
people were there
uh they started cpr
uh the
because there was concerns about whether
he had tension pneumothorax or not we
hadn't had time to get an x-ray they
actually put
chest tubes in both chests those are
things too so if you do have a collapsed
lung it can expand it and you can
breathe
concern about
whether or not the endotracheal tube was
actually where it should be because of
the tracheal wound so dr perry did a
tracheostomy which is where you
make an incision in the neck to get a
shorter tube in more directly in the
trachea so there's no question it's in
place i guess all that
is important in terms of
certainly explaining
what was done and a lot of thing that
happened in that 20 minutes uh as i'm
sure you're aware the the tracheostomy
wound was right through
this uh this wound i'm sorry this wound
in the neck
and that caused some confusion later but
that's where tracheostom had to be
then the
we gave him some steroids because
we had remembered from
some stuff in the in the press that he
probably
had abnormal adrenal glands
you've already covered this and since
and you talked about the secret service
you didn't have any
you didn't have his medical record there
that's correct uh on hands you would
have today correct
the
so at this point we had
gotten his
gotten his airway under control gotten
him breathing trying to to make his
circulation better circulation wasn't
getting better getting worse it's hard
to stop
but we've done all we could do to get
things stable kemp clark who is the
chief of neurosurgery
evaluated the situation evaluated the
head wound in much more detail than than
i did
and then kemp clark
was the one that the chief of
neurosurgery was the one that
actually pronounced him dead and this
was some 20 minutes later about yeah
something like that
the
priest had come in
actually
dr clark
uh said
he basically said it's time to stop the
resuscitation
he would
for whatever reason the president the
decision made not to actually pronounce
the president dead until after the
priest had come in and gave him
given him the last rights so we stopped
treatment
but dr clark didn't pronounce him until
after the last rides for
you know who do you recall who notified
mrs kennedy was that one of the medical
team or did you i don't know don't
recall that no and
so from that point
uh
what happened
well from that point
uh
my job was the medical part i guess the
patient care part of my job was over
had
two things to do one is we had to to uh
as we do for all patients write a brief
report in the emergency
room records of the treatment and what
we saw and what we did and my other job
was to
to find those three patients who i had
been working on before the president
came in and
take care of them
we did
sit down
i remember
one thing which probably have not walked
out of the trauma room one had been to
the big emergency room
which
20 minutes before had been a big city
county emergency room full of people
being treated etc
all the patients were gone when i walked
out they've been moved elsewhere
uh the
people in the room were by and large
folk men
with coats off shirts and tie zones and
guns on their hip
and a couple were talking on the phone
to washington and
that's when i guess really the
the whole thing kind of hit me you know
it just
up until then except for that brief
moment it had been professional
work
and i walked out there and realized that
not only had my little world changed but
that
what the whole world had changed and it
changed that quick
so that i was i was smoked at that time
as a lot of us did we thought it was
cute thing to do right
so i started a lot of cigarette and
imagine lighting a cigarette at an
emergency room now but that was common
in 1963. so i started to light a
cigarette and was
realized i was trembling so that i
really couldn't get
had trouble getting a match to the
cigarette
but
kind of got that under control and sat
down to
write
my my recollections and
again just individually was not the team
or each physician writes their own
report independently there's no
there's no a proscription against
exchanging information and
you know i'm sure you could ask the guy
next to you where do you mean where was
that wound what was involved and i
remember we did i do not remember if we
did that or not but uh
we also wrote our records and
also kind of i think in terms of
any conversation you might have had
about
the effect on others is that being part
of that process
uh
did y'all talk about it later if not
then or
uh
you mean just how everybody was dealing
with it yeah how it
affected you personally yeah
uh we really we i'm sure we talked about
it some but but we didn't talk about it
as a group and there was none of the
debriefing which would would happen
happen now
but it was we just kind of went back to
work i mean the but we finished writing
our reports as you know by the time we
finished writing our reports they had
taken the president's body away so so
our reports did not get to bethesda for
time for the autopsy
um what do you know about that
issue this big conflict about removing
the body
uh state law that
autopsy should have been done yeah here
at the time did that seem
significant to you that what happened
that it was removed
no i i
was a little
surprised in a professional sense and
and and kind of in this sense as i said
what would usually have happened with a
patient who came in and died of a
gunshot wound
is we would have tried to keep him alive
we'd have done whatever we had to do
medically
we probably would have spent more time
after the patient was dead kind of
trying to figure out the forensics
ourselves
than we did with the president but but
it didn't seem appropriate to do that
with the president
but it really wouldn't have mattered
because when
earl rose who was the new county medical
examiner
did his autopsy if he had questions
about the treatment he would call us
matter of fact he'd frequently call us
down just to teach us you'd call the
house staff and say okay here's this
patient you treated tell me what you did
and then let me show you how to
recognize exit wounds entrance wounds
etc
so we we kind of all assumed that there
was no reason to to roll the president
over that that earl rose would be doing
the autopsy when
the president was
taken away we realized
gee
the body's gone earl's not gonna do the
autopsy and these guys are not going to
have any medical records to go by
but that that was kind of the medical
surprise if you will
didn't think about why they would have
done that
that wasn't related to his competency as
a
oh or anything like that no zero i mean
earl rose was
was and i think he's still recognized as
one of the
really outstanding forensic pathologists
in the country
uh well
the reason we're given and i it makes
sense is that
president knew president johnson
uh was not willing to leave dallas
on air force one president kennedy's
plane
without president kennedy's body
so you think it was probably
his decision
as opposed to mrs uh kennedy or the to
you know
really
what i've heard is is uh yes that
president johnson wouldn't leave without
president kennedy's body and
i i don't know
any facts
but it makes sense i mean he he was a
pretty shrewd politician and you can
imagine
the impact of of people saying boy he's
done he took the president's job he took
his plane left town left president just
left the president in this
mess well let's recall in the interview
we did with uh henry wade who was the
district attorney at the time
and just kind of
dismissed that as
he said well the only uh
uh fine was a hundred dollars if you
remove the body from the state of texas
was not that big a deal from that
point of view no it you know that you
mean the law is as i understand it that
murder here the autopsy the examination
has to be done here but
gosh it was a president there's no laws
about shot presidents and and
it's no big i mean if i'd have been a
secret service man i think i've done the
same thing and i've gotten that body out
of here and got president johnson out
here because they didn't know if it was
a you know this was a russian plot they
didn't know
what was going on
so their job was to get johnson to
safety
when
the autopsy was performed the
information that came back
to you or to dallas
however that came about
what was your reaction then do you
remember
well the first uh you know we we had
we'd you know friday night had been busy
with taking care of those three patients
that were waiting and that
well i want to get the details of that
weekend too
saturday morning was
our our
mortality and morbidity confidence every
saturday morning we sat down went
through all the cases we'd done during
the week and anything that had gone
wrong we analyzed what had gone wrong
and
which is a fairly typical medical
approach to things so we were
in our saturday morning conference
when the phone rang
and it was the pathologist in
bethesda trying to get hold of dr
malcolm perry
to
get some medical information
and that was the first time i think that
the pathologist in bethesda knew that
there was a wound here
because all they saw apparently was a
hole here
a little hole here a big hole here and
tracheostomy line and it was and since
they didn't have any medical records
they didn't they couldn't figure out how
in the world three holes connected
so they called malcolm
and that's when they told him
that there was
you know that these other two ones were
there and that's when it kind of began
to make sense
that
bullet went in here came out here nicked
his trachea maybe he hurt his spinal
cord didn't kill him and then the second
bullet went in here
hit the bones inside his head but came
out here
and blew that big hole and and so that
that was the first time we could really
put things together in a way that made
sense
and what you were hearing from them and
after those discussions that didn't make
sense to you yes
excuse me
uh
because
because before we see
this hole in this hole
didn't know whether there were holes
back here or not and we were trying to
speculate how these two could connect
and that's
it's hard to make any sense out of that
what about also the controversy about
the bullet that
went through president kennedy went into
governor conley out of your experience
with other
gun shot moves and everything is
is this feasible to you
uh it's yes it is and there's some
there's been a lot of analysis on that
on both sides and i'm not haven't looked
into it in detail but
certainly the concept that
a bullet this first bullet
went through here and really
hit very little other than muscle in the
side of the trachea which is soft
then went to governor conley's back
and the first time it really discharged
a lot of his energy was was coming out
to his chest here
then
then it then i guess it hit uh his right
or left wrist i forgot it must been his
right wrist
and and
hurt the bone but but it really
uh if if you look that wasn't a terrible
destructive wound like this thing was
and then kind of splattered into his
thigh
that that sounds like a lot of a lot of
traveling for a bullet
uh
but it's certainly plausible i mean you
know
bullets do strange things and that was
unlike some of the
the movie
suggesting it bounced all over the place
that was pretty much a straight line
you were in that
that first room working with dr delaney
did you ever realize it was conley in
there
not until after no not until later i
mean so you left that room to go to the
next body and you didn't know it was the
governor right
when did you realize it was kennedy in
the other room as soon as i walked in
the door because that's who we were
looking for right i mean we you know
what's the old story you see what you're
looking for we were looking for the
president
connolly wadded him and it
this i gotta see it's very careful it
didn't really matter who that was did it
in terms of treating him we were going
to treat him same no matter who
and then when i walked in the room and
saw the president it was obvious it was
him because that was
what the tape for running to look for
and
of course he was
very recognizable
tell us a little bit about the addison's
disease and what was out in the medical
community
yeah
the
well
what i know in retrospect at least what
i believe is that that
president kennedy had had some severe
arthritis etc and had
been put on steroids for for pain relief
or for relief of inflammation
and when you put people on big doses of
steroids long enough it actually the
adrenal glands quit responding
and apparently his adrenal
glands had quit responding whether he
had had any
primary problem with his adrenals i
guess we'll never know because they
apparently they were they were not part
of the autopsy
but uh the way we kind of had some hint
that something was going on as i say we
were aware of all the noise in the press
or some of the noise in the press
somewhere in congress within a few
months before the president's
assassination
there had been a discussion
where
somebody had said that the president had
addison's disease and bobby kennedy
had said
addison's disease is caused by
tuberculosis
my brothers never had tuberculosis
therefore my brother doesn't have
addison's disease
well the logic is is there but the logic
to a country boy is that
that's a little evasive right
and so our
we kind of come it was kind of common
knowledge that the president had
adrenaline has been depressed i can
recall that yeah those rumors so those
rumors that he had wringle sufficiency
were around
and so that was uh
we we have to remember that and so we
gave him
steroids hydrocortisone uh
early in his treatment normally you
would not do that to somebody who is in
shock but if they had
if their adrenal glands weren't working
you would
so that's what actually tuberculosis is
not
addison's disease and turquoises are not
connected well
medicine's funny business see there's
there are
phys i know you've got
tapes running short there's physiologic
diagnosis adrenal insufficiency okay
that means adrenals aren't working
then we sometimes name diseases right
addison's disease is named after dr
addison
and dr addison desi
described adrenal insufficiency
in people who had had tuberculosis and
destroyed their adrenal glands so in
literally speaking addison's disease is
adrenal insufficiency caused by
tuberculosis
and literally speaking president kennedy
did not have addison's disease
but he still had adrenal insufficiency
see the difference it's a eponymous
versus physiologic
description i've heard that had you not
done that had you not given him those
injections
for that abscess disease
that even if you had saved him he would
have had problems
well
well what probably would have happened
if he really had adrenal insufficiency
and we think he did that he never would
have responded to the shock he never
would have come out of shock at least it
would have been much more difficult to
get his circulation going because what
the adrenals do
when you get stressed is they kick out
cortisone and
other things which help your body
respond so it would have made it much
more difficult for for him to come out
of shock
but it
but had he lived over it
then then
he would have still needed steroids long
term
but it wouldn't have been there would
have been no
uh
injury any organ injury from from not in
the steroids but they would have been
important to getting him to survive and
you've been a little modest it really
was you who remembered this
that
yeah but that's
that's what a team's about
and everybody
pitches in and
and actually he would have gotten him
anyway because
admiral berkeley came in late in the
resuscitation
carrying vials of hydrocortisone to make
sure the president got him
he
again his car had been separated
admiral berkeley was the president the
president's personal physician
was traveling with him traveling with
him but he was two or three cars back so
it they got separated in the
in the
traffic etc and all the the melee and
well i think the rest of the motorcade
diverted to the trade center yes yeah
yeah yeah so and then people had to
scramble get over to the hospital so i
and it took him i know it was late in
the resuscitation when he came and said
give the president
hydrocortisone and but then it was too
late and but then we'd already given it
but
he was pleased to know that you know
yeah right
one of the other issues with
some of the conspiracy theorist
relates to the
how his body was removed from parkland
and uh
questioned about a switch of a body bag
or something you know anything about
that at all i really don't i mean i just
you know we're not in the room one room
we left i wasn't even aware that when he
left i was just aware that he had left
there's there's one thing which dr
montgomery and i were talking about
which
which is an inaccuracy in our records
which
clarify that that was kind of the next
step in this was
for you to add anything we haven't
touched on certainly if you look at what
we wrote we said
that the
the scalp wound
was occipital
occipital parietal which would an
occipital bone is way back in the back
in the parietal bones here
again those notes were written after the
president gone we were kind of trying to
remember and uh
didn't occur to us that this was a big
forensic record we were writing we
thought we were writing a medical record
so you could have said head wound that
would have been a lot better
if if the occipital bones way back here
and the president's laying on that he
couldn't see the whole wound right
that's good could you kind of turn your
head yeah
in fact there's a little knot on the
back of your head and that's kind of
where the occipital bone reaches its
peak right in the middle everybody's a
little knot on the back of their head
okay so occipital parietal would have
really been right back there
and literally speaking
uh
number one that would have been very
difficult to explain as a exit wouldn't
if he was shot from the back
and number two you couldn't have seen it
with the patient lying on his back on a
gurney
so
if the recollection that we can see the
whole wound from the front is accurate
and i think it is
then then our
what we should have written down was
temporal parietal rather than occipital
cryo
part of that is is learning through the
years that a medical record is much more
than a medical record it becomes a
forensic record sometimes it's a billing
record
so uh so that i wish i wish we'd have
been more precise in our writing we
weren't
tonight on american perspectives we're
looking back at the assassination of
president john f kennedy which happened
on this day 40 years ago
the next oral history interview is from
malcolm kilduff the assistant white
house press secretary who traveled with
president kennedy to dallas and
announced his death to the public
the sixth floor museum at dealey plaza
provided us with this interview never
before seen on television
had you traveled with uh with the
president say prior to the trip to texas
uh oh yeah i had done most of the uh
from the time i first went to the white
house and even before i
had before i went to the white house in
61 i did some uh advanced him in london
and i advanced him in in ireland and in
italy
and uh
i advanced him in
i forgot how many of the states but in
every state that he went to
after 62
in the say in the like in the
congressional campaign
of 1962 which of course bumped into the
cuban missile crisis in october
uh but i did all those states
but when you say advance that sounds
like i mean you were there before he was
there yes and then you double back and
pick him up and go out on the trip okay
yeah that kind of one right get
clarified for instance here in dallas
uh the white house had an advanced man
by the name of jerry bruno okay and uh
he uh wasn't it it was jerry wasn't it
jerry bruno was the advanced man here
uh but you know as to what the schedule
is going to be
all that has to be taken into
consideration
because you have your local press to
consider you have the needs of the local
pressure the needs of them
in other words and you can't go pulling
a motorcade into town into new york city
five o'clock in the afternoon they'll
all hate you and we'll vote for you
especially if it's an election year if
it's an off year you can forget it and
hope they forget it but yeah you know
and so every place the president goes he
has to be advanced not just
by secret service but also by his
communicators the white house
communications agency as it was known
there waka i forgot what it's referred
to now because it's a combined
command now
of
a navy and army
was there anything uh particularly
different
in advance of the trip to texas and i
guess maybe specifically
when the subject of dallas being on the
attempt no we were of course very aware
of the fact that
in his visit
to dallas in october i believe it was or
maybe september
adelaide stevenson had been belted with
rotten eggs
oh well yeah he got hit with a uh
a poster a picket yeah had a poster that
right and then there was some rotten
eggs thrown because i remember a great
herb block cartoon
showed the the seal of texas and two
rotten eggs dripping from it yeah that
it was a you know it was and so and we
knew at that point
we knew
that
the forces of goldwater
were starting to pick up in 63
preparatory to a run in 64 against
kennedy
but surprisingly enough
uh
we saw in our in the day before on
november 21st
before we got to uh before we got here
to dallas
and in our other stops we had
seen very few gold water signs yes we'd
seen a few of them and we'd seen a sign
you know shame on you for cuba and all
this business
but not not too many not
to reflect
uh
the feeling that that sometimes today
people are are crediting with what the
feeling was at that time and i don't
think that dallas had any uh
uh i didn't sense any anything in dallas
i know there was a full page
advertising uh there's a copy of that in
our exhibit is it yeah i i remember
seeing that that morning because we saw
that over in uh i was staying at the
texas hotel and i performed fort worth
we saw that in there
before you came before we even hit the
ground yeah the paper had been over
there well i think there was some
discussion wasn't there that morning
about
say whether to put the bubble on the
limo or something there was yeah but
the president always wasn't unless there
was a weather reason to leave the bubble
off and the bubble wasn't really that
important because that bubble was not
the bubble that exists today
it was a piece of plastic is all it was
yeah i mean it folded up in what it was
it built two parts
and uh two parts that folded up and went
into the trunk and all it was was to
protect them from the weather now i
don't say that the bullet would have
gotten a good cl is clean a shot through
that bubble as it would without the
bubble uh but you still could have
gotten at him uh with with the bubble on
top but the president always felt that
the people if the people were good
enough to come out and see him
he was good enough to sit there in the
open car and let them see him and so he
could see them because he enjoyed that i
mean i mean you take a look at the
pictures when john kennedy arrives at
love field yeah you know the smile on
his face and there was nothing very
comfortable about his doing that because
of his back an awful lot of trouble with
his back but you go over a period of
years in any of these books that you
have here of pictures of kennedy in a
crowd
i've got some pictures
there's one picture i've got
in costa rica for instance
where there are thousands of people i
think must be the whole country
and in one little dot
you can see
the president he was mobbed in
because they had set up line quote
police lines
the only problem was that the police
lines the costa ricans didn't quite
understand it is what we meant by using
barricades
they had school children who all
carefully made little paper link
chains and they went out to quote hold
the crowd back
and so you can imagine what happened but
i mean you know we never thought of that
but that and you know and i think i look
at that picture today
and i think look at this here he was in
costa rica mobbed by thousands of people
secrets
completely out of control
totally out of control and god he was
safer there than he was on the streets
of the united states not necessarily in
the streets in dallas because i don't
buy that dallas as a you know has a has
any shame to live down i don't think it
does
because after all there have been uh
after all mckinley was killed in buffalo
and i've never heard that buffalo goes
around with wearing a mourning band
that was interesting
what kind of kind of recall first if you
can say
uh arriving in dallas what
your impressions well of course there
was no arrival ceremony scheduled for
love field as such
uh it was announced what time he would
arrive approximately and where he would
arrive
and as the films will show we had a
pretty good crowd out there a lot of
people out there who were a lot but
there was no speaker stand set up no it
was no microphone set up so that we had
no arriva typically you would have
arrival remarks but he didn't have any
arrival remarks and he didn't make any
he and jackie as we as we would call it
work the crowd worked the fence
and um
and that was
totally by design i mean he did not want
to do anything at the at the airport i
mean the big event i guess that's right
was the luncheon
at the trademark right yeah
and that was to be the
big event and of course he was very very
mindful
that he was walking into a political
bed
of the forces loyal to
ralph yarber and those forces those
democratic forces loyal to john conley
because he was very fond of
governor connolly as everybody knows and
so therefore you suddenly find
and
yarborough was riding in the car with
johnson and he didn't really know why
and i don't think johnson knew why
either well they were
well-known political enemies yeah but i
mean you know here they were in various
places sitting next to each other and
riding in cars together and and i never
saw two unhappier fellows in my life
they weren't very happy
about that whole thing but it was
important and kennedy was thinking of
the 1964 elections
and he did consider this area
particularly as being key to his own
reelection bid in 1964 and to to try to
meld the forces yeah uh
loyal to conley and those loyal to
yarborough and to come up with a unified
democratic party he considered this trip
was necessary to the extent
that since 1960
when he was elected
mrs kennedy had not gone on any
political treatment i mean she went to
get you to comment yeah she went to uh
canada with him and she accompanied him
to paris
which he mentioned in his speech at fort
worth that morning
and uh but aside from that she did and
and she really didn't like political
trips i mean i hate to say that but it's
the truth and everybody knows it no
sense in you know
edging on the
issue but that's how important this trip
was this was to him
and uh and i think she was rather
enjoying it if you wanna know the truth
i think so yeah i was wondering about
what impressions you would gain is not
necessarily in dallas but say you know
along the way yeah no she seemed to be
enjoying doing it yeah
and i i think well being the subject of
a great deal of adolescent and so forth
yeah and well really and i i think and
he also knew something in being shrewd a
politician as he was that is and he said
said this that as many people would come
out to see her as it would come out to
see him
you know
at that point you take any
[Laughter]
vote well you you talked about a uh sort
of sparsity perhaps of say goldwater
was did that hold true along the dallas
route he came into the airport yeah you
can see it in the films you'll see
yeah that's the impression i had too
yeah people said there really was
very few
there were some anti-cuba signs
but that was understandable and we knew
that because of your free cuba movement
that was active well
we must inevitably get to
yeah the point of
getting down to uh
uh
the street in front of the runs in front
right
we took this and so if you can kind of
walk us through that well i was riding
in the in the press car which was in
relationship to the three afterwards
okay and um
that was the
in any presidential motorcade in those
days you had
a pool car which was made up of four
reporters yes and the usually in the
press secretary
and then behind that you'd have a pool
of cameramen and one car still cameraman
and another car motion picture cameraman
for the
television cameras because those in
those days they were shooting 16
millimeter film yeah
so you had the three pool cars and in
the pool car i was riding in
press secretary's car
and then the reason i was on that trip
as acting press secretary for the trip
is that pierre salinger president
kennedy's press secretary was on his way
to japan yeah
yeah with doug dillon and
dean rusk
for an economic conference and he had
decided he'd go along on that
as a white house representative
that's enough said about that but anyway
um
so that's that that was the reason i was
on the trip brother salinger i would
have been on the trip in bed been in the
motorcade somewhere but certainly not
not up there had this had this night and
the four pool reporters were bob clark
of abc bob baskin of the dallas morning
news
excuse me uh jack um
jack bell of associated press yeah and
of course merriman smith the united
press
and of course the driver was an employee
south
of the bell system who was and we had
the one phone in the car so as we came
right
we turned right here
right at that window
and this is off of houston onto elm
street
and going down towards what's called the
triple underpants underpass
right as we passed there i heard this
first noise and
and
switzerland what the hell was that and i
said well it sounded to me like a
firecracker and i remember having the
thought process well you know it's a
week for thanksgiving
and uh
it uh
uh they sell fireworks here i mean that
much i can remember
and then the second shot
by that time i noticed when
that clint hill who was a secret service
agent assigned to mrs kennedy had jumped
off the secret service follow-up car
and was running towards the president's
car but then i looked up to from where
the the second shot
came from and i was looking of course
at the six looking up at this building
yes now i cannot say that i was looking
at the exact
location it was coming from but i
knew was coming from above
and
over my right shoulder it was not coming
from the grassy knoll over there yeah at
all it was coming from above me and uh
and from my rear and i look back there
and i could not very honestly i could
not see anything and of course now that
i've i've seen it
i can understand why two shots that's
right that's right
and uh then i
there was a longer space between the
first and second than there was between
the second and the third shots
and uh
then i noticed that the secret service
car
and the president's car had started to
speed up yes
so we sped up in the pool car
but that still didn't
surprise me yeah because after all it
was obvious that something untoward had
happened
and that this would be a normal
operating procedure to get the hell out
of there yeah in a big hurry yeah
and uh
it never
and of course merriman smith grabbed the
phone in the pool car
to say that shots had been fired at the
presidential motorcade at that time and
not until we got to parkland hospital
did any of us know to what extent and i
remember thinking that gee i want to
thank shot connolly
this is kennedy
you know it never even occurred to me
that the president had been shot
i mean
what do you think what do you think you
thought
because i think that it is you know this
is america it's inconceivable
okay
the inconceivable nature of it all right
just
just
blocked that thought from uh
that's the last thing you you know this
is america we don't do we're not like a
banana republic but we're going yeah
shooting off shooting off our leaders
right and left of course the fact
remains is we've we've killed six
i was shot at six i mean and if you take
um uh you know roosevelt with the with
mayor ceramic of chicago was killed you
take harry truman
and you take um
mckinley
lincoln garfield i forgot who else it
was reagan
right well that was before reagan oh
before right before i mean yeah you're
talking before yeah okay yeah that's
right
excuse me but i mean you know we're
we're not the freest nation in the world
of having
taken our leaders out the hard way but
nevertheless i guess because
when you're that close the last thing
you think of of course and i was i
didn't have the view of the president
some of the people on the grassy knoll
did that
who responded to newsmen saying he held
his i saw him clutch his throat yeah
which of course we saw that was a brutal
film
yeah
and even as we pulled and of course as
we
drove out
i didn't know the area that well so
therefore i didn't know where the
trademark was where we were headed for
lunch or anything else and then we
pulled into parkland hospital
and i ran around with some of those film
clips or the years will show i ran out
of the car and went over and there was
the president you know slumped over in
mrs kennedy's lap
and
of course they couldn't remove him from
the back of the car
until they removed conley and nellie
because they were sitting on the jump
seats in front of the president mrs
kennedy
so they got conley out of there
and this is connolly and then they
removed the president
and that's when we went into
the um
uh
emergency entrance there at the back of
parkland
who was the security that was kind of
managing this was this the secret
service the dallas police board no
secret service it was roy kellerman
stayed with the president the whole time
you you went in with that that's right
and i also had police identification
we always wore
uh buttons of different shades and
colors bill
here can tell you he
same thing we'd go in different trips
and we'd have a trip button it might
[ __ ] be a
blue porcelain button with a white dot
in it and other times would be green
with an
orange dot in it and
and all the police
would have a
card that would show what the authorized
buttons were some of them were circles
they were staff some of them would be
triangles they were security
some of them would be
squares they'd be a signal core
something like that yeah and i know that
they shut it down or i understand they
shut it down
right away as is
letting anybody get into the hospital
back there
say a guy in a business suit if you
didn't have you yeah they did but but
they secret service even got to the
point where they didn't even allow the
dallas police in yeah well it's got a
little testy there yeah but kellerman
shut it down
just completely
and
after we got there
and i was and when we got to the
hospital
it still didn't occur to me the
president was dead
you did not say
visually say looking at him in the car
he was a mess
but but it didn't
i guess i had a mental block
he's there no i did that
and
i went in and i remember my
thinking and recalling back when
eisenhower had a heart attack back in in
denver one time
that jim haggerty had set up a press
room and they had a press thing i don't
know why i thought of those things they
just did so i told a fellow who was
traveling with us by the name of wayne
hawks who was
uh
on the staff to go find something we
could use as a press room he came up
with a nurse's instruction room out
there apartment
and to get in the whole get a hold of
the telephone company to start getting
some press phones in because
you know you couldn't get apparently
from what i've heard you couldn't even
get a the phone's lines were just jammed
here in the house well yeah they were i
know some of them but i do know some of
the people i know marilyn smith got a
hold of a
a
coin telephone
right there outside the emergency
entrance
and he got an open line right away and
opened to washington and it stayed open
there was no problem there jack bell
again was not very
he he never he just lucked out all the
way uh luck though i mean had no luck at
all
smith had all the luck in finding the
phones and everything else by the way he
got uh smith
eventually got the pulitzer prize for
his coverage for that yeah yeah and uh
ended up blowing his head off but
committing suicide like sometimes uh
does play a role in these things but
yeah who are you working with say at the
hospital in terms of getting information
about dr perry dr perry yeah
okay
yeah same with his name as mike yeah
yeah yeah he's the one who told me okay
so and i don't know who bill uh stinson
was working with he was of course he was
working for on the conley side of it too
and we were equally concerned about
getting information out on the who
beside yourself would say involved in
the process of deciding
when we're going to announce what we're
going to ask for okay
when it became apparent to me that the
president was dead
and that was within a very few minutes
after we got there
um
before one o'clock
uh
i went to kenneth o'donnell and i said
uh kenny i said uh we're gonna have to
announce the president's death
kenny was chief of staff to canada yeah
and uh
kenny said to me and kenny of course had
been
um he'd been close with been close with
kennedy's and a roommate of bobby's at
school
and you know this was his life
his life had just been shot away
kenny's now dead
and um
he said hell he said don't ask me
go ask johnson
so
i went across the hall into a trauma
room
where rufus youngblood
is johnson's
uh service agent was
and uh i walked in and i didn't know
what to call and i didn't know lyndon
johnson that well yes i'd seen around
the white house he knew me by name and i
naturally i know
but
i walked up to him and um
i suddenly realized i didn't know what
to call him
the situation the fact though he was the
president
i said mr president
and ladybird because it's kind of
screamed yeah and it let out a
audible and apparently and according to
him and according to some writings of
his
when i said that to him was the first
solid information that he had that he
was the de facto
president
i said i'm going to have to announce
president kennedy's death
and he said well
and uh
wheat and it's very interesting and you
know the man was a great historian
he had a great mind for history lyndon
johnson did
we don't know what kind of a conspiracy
this might be
and later he and you could see it going
through his mind
of um
booth
with lincoln and all the mary sarat
conspiracy and all this this business
going through his
his head
he said but i think bert and i ought to
get out here back to air force one
before you make the announcement
and i said all right
so he said come on he said to rufus he
said let's go on back the plane
and by that time we knew that the
president would be transported
the body would go back on air force one
now secret service made the
determination
that lyndon johnson would go back on air
force one
a lot of people have been critical
of johnson saying that he seized power
at an opportune moment it was not it was
on
the advice of the secret service
going back to air force one
and number two it was on the advice of
secret service to use air force one
rather than the backup plane yeah which
was the second plane air force two if
you will
but um
when
we got him out of the
emergency entrance i walked out with him
about bob pierpoint i remember of cbs
said he remembers seeing me come out
but doesn't remember seeing johnson well
i don't know how he could ever miss
lyndon johnson i mean we put him in the
car and we got back and as soon as we
got the word
and in those days the code was uh his
his uh i always tickled me his his code
name was volunteer
and it always tickled me because
lyndon johnson was about as much of a
volunteer to be being in the white house
there's nothing but i mean it was kind
of amusing and said that volunteer had
returned to angel and as soon as i got
that angel was the
uh code name for air force one
were there were there other reactions i
mean do you think johnson's reaction
to
uh fearing that there was a conspiracy
with was that sort of the common
reaction among the people
it wasn't in mine and it wasn't
in kenny o'donnell's a lot of people
have had second thoughts about it and
have said to will say today oh i thought
right away it was a conspiracy well if
they did they sure as hell kept their
mouth shut about it at the time
i think that it you know hindsight is
always 20 20. yeah but i sure didn't
hear about it no and they did not talk
about it even there at the hospital or
even coming back on air force one yeah
but johnson you could see it he was he
was forever the historian yeah yeah and
by that time
of course and then after he cleared and
after i'd received word that he was back
and at approximately 131 i went ahead
and made the announcement that you have
here
at least i think you have it yes we do
have yeah
and made the announcement and then when
the body was returned to
wanted to keep the body here for
an autopsy yeah and that's when roy
kellerman
and some other agents and myself formed
sort of a flying wedge
and the dallas police were told to keep
the body here
roy kellerman had
received word from headquarters to bring
it back to washington for an autopsy at
walter reed yeah or bethesda naval
whichever was to be used and
we flew out that door and put the casket
in the
uh ambulance and we took off and i went
to love field how spirited what was the
uh
uh
effort to keep you from doing that there
were a couple of detectives who
were quite spirited upon them i remember
looking down on them on the floor as i
passed them
uh they one of them took a rather nasty
hit i don't know by whom but one of them
went down well there was a
law or an ordinance or whatever that the
body couldn't be removed but we did an
oral history with henry wade who was a
district attorney at the time and he
rather riley observed that well
it was breaking a law but the only
penalty for that law was a hundred
dollar fine
were you were you was anybody aware of
that no no no no
no so and then we went back to air force
one and by that time
lyndon johnson had contacted
the attorney general of course
president's brother brother yes
you know in calling a spade a spade and
you got to do it there was no love lost
between lyndon johnson and robert
kennedy
even though he stayed on as attorney
general they were not exactly enamored
of each other
but bobby advised him that
uh in case any presidential decisions uh
not knowing
what was what was going on that it would
be best if he
was sworn in here
okay so that came from bobby kennedy
that came from bobby kennedy now here
again
uh history loves to rewrite itself
because
you'll find among some of the kennedy
people
here again that that johnson had seized
the power as quickly as he could he did
not
do that at all he uh
he did this on the advice of the
kennedys
if you accept bobby as a as the kennedys
which i think you have to yeah so that
was the that was a decision made by the
attorney general that he should be sworn
in
and of course he was sworn in as we have
photographic knowledge
on air force one and sworn
in by
judge sarah hughes which of course was
another slight irony
as you probably know
since welch and you want to explain that
for us well he uh uh as you know lyndon
johnson had opposed her
uh
appointment to the federal bench that
will disrecord judge
and it's so it's every time i see that
picture of the swearing in with the
president lyndon johnson looking down at
judge sarah hughes
wondering to myself now what in the
world was he really thinking of of all
the judges they knew its world they had
to find this one well she was sort of
a leading jurors in in the city and at
least in terms of a public profile i
don't know anything right but no it's
just i think they got a hold of the
first federal court judge that they
could it was her this happened to be her
and i know that it was reported back to
me and that he had
opposed her appointment to the federal
bench now did you go from the hospital
with
the casket or
you mean back to the uh air force one in
left field i mean yes in dallas get it
back okay now as you pointed out we
looked at photographs you were recording
the swearing in that's the only that's
correct uh
on air force one in the in the residence
hall you had the foresight to do that
yeah you want to tell us about that well
as we got on air force one
and
all the kennedy people were in the far
section of the plane around the casket
they had removed four seats from the
back section that back section of
air force one at that time contained a
conference room and a bedroom
and then behind that four more seats
and an aft galley
they had removed the seats from the
the four seats
to make room for the casket
the
kennedy some of the kennedy people
pamela turner mrs kennedy's press
secretary
mrs gallagher this is gallagher
mrs kennedy's secretary
was back there with her ken o'donnell
dave powers
stayed in the aft section of that plane
then when when judge hughes came aboard
the president asked that mrs kennedy be
invited to come up during his
swearing-in
i suppose that was a no-win situation
yeah
that uh
some of the people would be critical
that he wanted her by his side whether
despite any ill feelings that there
might have been but she did come forward
she was only too gracious about coming
forward she never
never blinked an eye or twitched a
muscle and on that some of those
pictures again you can see the blood on
that red suit of hers
and she stood right next to him as he
was sworn in
uh as uh as our president
and
then within a few very few moments of
course
we after judge hughes left the aircraft
we were airborne back to washington
nothing on that flat i'd
whether you yeah everybody we all drank
about as much as
human beings could possibly consume
but nobody got drunk
it was absolutely amazing i
i don't know how much we had to drink
and or how many of us did drink but i
know i had plenty and yet that was on a
friday and i did not end up going to bed
for a full night sleep until the
following wednesday
you sure had a
a kind of awesome responsibility on your
shoulders at that time was it were you
thinking about that one no no you no i
think it's one of those things
that happens to you and you
when it's all over
you ever been in a close call in a
automobile accident and you you
everything's fine and then
an hour later you suddenly look at your
hands and they're all filled with sweat
yeah it's uh
no you but you're
you're aware of the fact that that here
is history being made you don't think of
yourself
in
relationship to that
history in other words you don't think
of yourself well what part of my playing
history that didn't certainly i never
did anything about it
but uh
and but suddenly and you you stop and
you think oh my god you know what what
look what's happened
and you know and it's uh it was
certainly far more
uh you know
traumatic than other things that i had
witnessed
such as the attempted assassination of
harry truman and and of course the
sunday that my mother and father and i
went to lakehurst new jersey to watch
the hindenburg come in
i feel like that joke that fellow that
al capp used to draw
joe blitz fits with a
little black cloud over him
but that no you don't think about that
at the time you don't think well what
was maybe kind of the most difficult
thing in that time period was just
trying to the most difficult thing
was to say
that john kennedy was dead
i
the film will show that i stutter on
that yeah and i didn't get into it clean
because i i guess it's
sort of like telling somebody that
a close friend has died
it's hard to come out it's hard it
doesn't you don't want to say it because
once you've said it it makes it so
and then i in a reflection i think
that's how i felt i know that's how i
felt that by saying it it's so and if i
don't say it it won't be so
what do you remember about say the press
that you were
making this announcement to what have no
recollection of the press in front of me
yeah not yeah
and i just to me it was a sea of faces
i remember off to one side
oh there's a great fella from the
washington post
old fellow
he's dead now i remember i remember him
he was a
marvelous
good old what's his name but i mean it
was
um
he was just
and he followed
had been with the washington post a year
i remember seeing him over there
and i remember merriman smith right in
front of me of course
i remember a fellow by the name of chuck
reynolds who was the guy with the
alderson reporting company he did the
the stenotyping he was sitting right in
front of me one of your photos i think
around here shows that or maybe it's
just in my book what about when you got
back to washington was
of course this was a different
group
well a whole lot of people had been
brought in i don't know
by whom or for what purpose into the
white house
by the time we got back and somebody was
working at my desk and somebody was
working at salinger's desk and i had to
there's a fellow by the name of paul
southwick who was a very good friend of
mine he kind of taken over my desk and i
had to kind of reclaim it to
tell him to get out and they said well
you know i've been asked to come in to
help out i said help out what
i said you know i don't have anything to
help out
well they're making the funeral
arrangements i said well i'm not going
to make the funeral arrangements i said
neither are you i said the kennedy
family is going to be making the funeral
arrangements with the assistance of the
military district to washington not get
out of my desk yeah
but there was a little bit
i guess really what it was is nobody
knew what to do yeah so therefore
everybody was doing what they thought
somebody would want and it just it it
was it was confusion you know let's face
it it had to be confusion
uh did procedures or anything much
change say within your office uh say
after the assassination took place no
not in the if not in the press office
if
local organizations
wanted to cover the arrival of the
president
they would they'd have to let
let the local uh politicians or who was
ever running the show
know in advance enough uh uh enough in
advance
uh who they were going to assign what
their social security number was so they
could throw it through a computer but
you know if a president is going to to
keokuk and he's going to address ten
thousand people
uh why worry about three reporters from
the keokuk times
and do a whole check on them because
you're not gonna be able to do a check
on the ten thousand that are gonna get
probably tickets from every ward healer
and uh either that a grocery store clerk
yeah
was kind of the the inner circle at the
white house
uh kind of quickly make a transition
over to
we have to continue business as usual
i think most of us did there were some
of them who's
spent an awful lot of time
kind of mourning the president's passing
and it's uh
it's too bad because some of them were
very talented people who just
more or less kind of made a
career out of being uh kennedy mourners
but to me it was kind of you know the
the torch has passed as they'd said and
they you know the king is dead long live
the king
we're
a country whose laws provide for such
things
you have to go on the government goes on
the government doesn't stop
where you say in your office saturday as
opposed to
and then sunday when the
you know during the funeral procedures
and then i was on my way up to the there
were services up at the rotunda the
capitol that day
and i was going up my way up to uh
and we had to share our car
our cars
we had had a garage then that had
a few more cars that mr clinton is
allowing
he apparently has cut down on the number
of cars yeah which won't last but he
wants to think it does make the gesture
oh yeah make a big gesture and i know i
shared my car with billy graham matter
of fact we were in the car i was in the
car when a message came over
that uh it was
that
oswald had been shot by ruby
the only problem was yeah they got the
message garbled they immediately knew
who had shot
oswald they got their name slightly
wrong they said have been shot by jack
rubley rudely do you remember the l in
there well
the signal core officer who we left here
to cover was a major jack rubley
which was funny you remember him
and you were with billy graham i was
with billy graham was in my car
his reaction
was just how yeah he's isn't that
terrible when will this all land so yeah
attitude yeah
but i mean
you can't do that
chest thumping too much because you know
things are going to happen that's just
well
i guess you know the ruby thing was one
of the major contributions to all the
conspiracy oh sure
set off later right exactly but i just
i've never seen of all these books that
you have here
of all these uh
great you know post mortems and the
oswald affair
all this
they you mean to tell me they couldn't
pin it down if it was actually a
conspiracy yeah i can't buy that
who had to deal with all that speaking
of uh
sort of the problems of dealing with
with the press
office dealing with all the dignitaries
that came in for this you know no the
state department no most of the state
department office of protocol yeah did
that yeah yeah we had uh many people
coming in from overseas that of course
since
uh
in
june of 63
president kennedy had been ireland and a
big
group had come over from ireland
including one of the fellows who he was
the chairman of the new ross county
council
and i i had done
he was one of the favorites of kennedy's
that kennedy met on the trip over there
i did the advanced work
and
his name was andrew minihan
and he had a big red beard and he was a
great looking man and the map of ireland
he made barry fitzgerald look like an
arab i mean it was just marlon and he
came over and he was
just they they just loved him in ireland
yeah
you know i never saw a cr
i think the whole nation was at every
one of our stops in ireland i never saw
this crowd in my life
well uh
one of the people from dallas one of the
community leaders uh later king mayor
eric johnson
was one of the representatives from
dollars who went to washington felt
they should
have some presence there
and said they were standing on a hotel
room balcony looking out and with the
gall and said you know
the thought occurred to them if we had a
raffle here we could have taken out oh
you mean on the parade up yeah he must
have been saying at the mayflower hotel
yeah i think that's where he walked yeah
because that's where we went that's
where that parade
i've seen every time i see that
the goal marched right at the head of
that foreign
and he was a pot shot for anybody and he
remember he was having trouble in
algeria at the time if you go to paris
three or four times a night you'd hear
that e or e on somebody racing because
they'd set another bomb off
and he refused secret service protection
he absolutely would have no body guards
around him for that walk from the white
house oh and he's almost blind as a bat
well yeah and one of the films in the
exhibit
that there's a clip of that yeah it just
is a bat and here he walked just as
stiff as he could right up
connecticut avenue to saint matthews and
i'll tell you that was in one impressive
sight
the only other impressive sight that
impressed me more
was at the graveside
i'm gonna describe that for us well
after the
after the service of saint matthews the
motorcade went on
went its way out to
constitutional avenue across memorial
bridge up to
arlington cemetery
going to arlington cemetery for me is
kind of like old home weekend
most of my family members are buried
there
and
as the services were going off on that
old just beneath the
uh
lee house the robert e lee mansion
air force one that's on a hill and we're
looking up at the mansion the grave was
down here
suddenly air force one comes across
they've had the
the
fighter planes come in the missing man
formation then air force one came in at
about 500 feet
and two six thousand and dipped its
wings and i tell you
that sent a chill right up my spine and
i was i was doing great until that and i
kind of broke down a little you know
well jim swithdell
did a real dip i mean he dipped that
baby you know why you start dipping a
707 you're dipping a hunk of machinery
i'll tell you
that was a very very uh
well it's a very very moment poignant
also moment with uh
walter cronkite in the videos we have
where
he
passed along i think you saw that little
part of that where he had to pass along
the announcement where he obviously was
choking and
and holding back
that maybe that's when that kind of hit
him too i think yeah he went through the
same thing when bobby was killed
i spotted for cronkite don hewitt who's
the executive producer for
60 minutes
called me that night bobby was killed
and asked me to get to new york right
away and could i do it i said yes
68. and i went up there and i did with
someone who's spotting and i stayed in
the control room
and spotted and i could i was feeding
cronkite all who these various people
were
who were on the on the train as the
train came to washington all right
but he he's a very emotional guy
well
i guess all of us who are old enough to
recall it at some point there it really
hit us too
it really hits you that way well just to
kind of clarify one little another thing
about uh
talking about the three shots
uh you were satisfied they all came
from the same direction
there's never been any same sound same
never any question in my mind from that
day to this
as to
as from where the shots originated
the sound of them
and where they no absolutely not i was
never
did you compare notes with any of the
other people saying in the motorcade
about that or anything like that no
because
the others in the motorcade
the others in the newsmen
were in my car
they were not even in as good a position
as i was to hear it because i had the
open window i think
merriman smith was sitting in the middle
i've talked to secret servicemen like
roy kellerman
who was riding the shotgun in the front
seat
talked to clint hill
and clint and roy
you're always dead now which i didn't
even know until a couple months ago
but there was never any questions
yeah
seems to be the general yeah
no but i mean for somebody like uh
mark lane it you know makes for great
copy when you want to write another book
and make another couple of thousand
dollars on a lecture tour around the
country
when you weren't even there yeah
before we end these
interviews they always ask the subject
if there's anything that we have not
discussed no not really i just uh the
only thing that i would say and the one
thing that i think most americans are
not appreciative of
and i'm not saying that just because i'm
taping in texas i've said it for
30 years
that i don't think i
could
i don't think that we were could have
been in better shape
than having the government turned over
to lyndon johnson
that he was the master of it
from the first moment
that he had a calm he was the calmest
and coolest of us all
seemed to know exactly what we you know
what should be done
and
i think
that he proved that it was a
he was a credit to the american
political system as to how the
as they would say how the torch was
passed
we'll wrap up american perspectives
tonight with an oral history from don
hewitt he's better known today as the
creator of 60 minutes but in november
1963 he was the executive producer of
the cbs evening news with walter
cronkite in this interview mr hewitt
recounts the jfk assassination from a
journalist perspective it was part of an
oral history project conducted by the
sixth floor museum at dealey plaza
the interview we are doing today is part
of the oral history collection for the
sixth floor museum at dealey plaza and
today we are joined by mr don hewitt
thank you very much mr hewitt for taking
the time to come to the museum and
record this interview while you're
visiting dallas and from this point on
we'll go on a first name basis don and
steven for the remainder of glory
i like that all right as we do with all
of our oral histories for the record
could you please give us your full name
date and place of birth and a brief
summary of your whole life and career
my name is don hewitt i was born
december 14th 1922 in new york city
i worked for cbs news for the last 55
years
first is the producer of the cbs evening
news
with
first doug man named douglas edwards and
then with walter cronkite
i started a broadcast called 60 minutes
in 1968
which is still going strong
and that would what brought me down here
to
dallas to accept the alga meadows award
which is
very big in texas and i'm afraid nobody
outside of dallas knows what it is
but uh here i am and uh
jack kennedy happened to be i can't say
he was a close friend but he was
somebody i worked with worked around
knew quite a bit about
was part of my
early years
and
was probably as devastated as anybody in
the country by the assassination
and
fire away stephen could you maybe talk
about your perceptions of dallas texas
prior november 63. i mean what you know
when you thought of dallas what was what
was what what were that
cowboys you know i think the whole world
listen let me tell you a great dallas
cowboy story and then i'll get on
my friend david frost sir david frost
came to dallas
a couple of years ago to speak at smu
and he brought
his secretary his english secretary with
him who had never been in the states
before let alone in texas
and they went out to dinner
and
she excused herself from the table to go
to the ladies room
and she came back 30 seconds later and
she said david
am i a steer or a heifer
no that kind of tells me
you want to talk about the uh about
okay i've got it in my book if you let
me read okay is that all right
okay on friday november 22nd 1963 i was
preparing to go out to lunch when the
chatter of the ap teletype was
interrupted by alarm bells that meant
that something had happened somewhere in
the world that editors should
immediately take note of the alarm bells
that went off that afternoon single
signaled
the biggest story i ever remember having
a hand in and that includes the d-day
landings i was at omaha beach in
normandy
were we under attack had an enemy
decided the best way to go to
us was to knock out not a naval base as
the japanese had in 1941
but the president of the united states
until lyndon johnson raised his hand on
air force one and took the oath of
office
no one was sure that government as we
knew it was still intact
we went into our fire alarm mode and
crashed our way under the air with a
bullet
however sick mickelson the vice
president who ran cbs news was already
on his way to lunch and i needed some
guidance on how long to let cronkite
stay on the air
so i picked up the phone and i called
the president of cbs frank stanton who
at the moment was in a meeting so
important he told his secretary he was
not to be interrupted
sorry mr ewich he said i have
instructions not to interrupt him he'll
have to call you back
tell him the president's been shot i
said and he might be dead before he can
call me back
hold on she said
a second or so later stanton was on the
line
keep walter on the air he said until you
know whether the president's dead or
alive a few seconds later he called back
and said forget what i just said even if
the president survives don't go back on
the air
i'm on my way to your office he said and
we'll run the network from there which
we did
television america in america across
america went on as one people everywhere
looking for someone to tell them that we
were going to be all right
and that our nation would survive
and that job fell to all the cronkite
that day that weekend cronkite who
already was everybody's uncle
became everybody's priest
everybody's minister
and everybody's rabbi
he was the glue that held america
together
dan rather knew the cbs and our
correspond on the scene phoned me from
dallas and told me that a guy named
zapruder was supposed to have film of
the assassination and was going to put
it up for sale
in fact he eventually did you sold it to
life magazine
or reported six hundred thousand dollars
in my desire to get a hold of what was
probably the most dramatic piece of news
footage ever shot
i told rather
go to zabruda's house
sock him in the jaw take his film to our
affiliate in dallas
copy it under videotape and let the cbs
lawyers decide whether it could be sold
or whether it was in the public domain
then take the film back to zapruder's
house give it back to him that way the
only thing that you they could get him
for was assault because he would have
returned to brutus property rather said
great idea i'll do it i hadn't hung up
the phone maybe 10 seconds when it hit
me
what in the hell did you just do
i called rather back luckily he was
still there and i said him for christ's
sake don't do what i just told you to i
think this day has gotten to me and
thank god i caught you before you left
knowing dan to be as competitive as i am
i had the feeling that he'd wish he'd
left before the second phone call
the things you do in the heat of battle
because i had a hand in the so-called
debate that helped catapult jack kennedy
into the white house
i felt in a strange way bonded to him as
i'd never felt to another president
and when an assassin's bullet ended his
life
i mourned his loss about as keenly as i
remember
mourning the loss of franklin roosevelt
the plain honest-to-god truth about jfk
was
that despite his potential for greatness
you realize very little of it between
the time of his
ask not what your country can do for you
an inaugural speech
and the motorcade that took him through
dallas's dele plaza and to the emergency
room at parkland hospital where he was
pronounced dead
assassinating john f kennedy made even
less sense
i thought
than the warren commission report
about who did it and why i always
believed that the commission held
something back
that there was a lot more to the story
than we were allowed to be privy to
that's why one morning
sitting with bobby kennedy in the
backyard of his house at hickory hill
just the two of us drinking iced tea
and talking about a broadcast i wanted
to be a part of
i decided with more guts than brains to
ask him the big one
the million-dollar question bobby
do you really believe lee harvey oswald
all by himself
killed your brother
he dismissed the question almost with a
studied indifference
what difference does it make he said it
won't bring him back
i never believe that bobby believed
what difference does it make and i've
always believed that he knew something
he didn't want to share with me or
anyone else that whatever was still
being kept in the dark about that
fateful day
he preferred his stay in the dark
in the fall of 2002 i had occasion to be
in chicago with ted sorensen who had
been president kennedy's council
and i told him about my conversation
over 30 years ago with bobby
ted responded it wasn't just bobby but
all of those who were close to jfk
felt more or less the same
what difference does it make
it won't bring him back
however
he did express the opinion
and i've gotten his permission to
paraphrase it
i read this to ted to make sure it was
okay that while it would surprise him to
learn that oswald had had accomplices it
would not dismay him
should it someday surface that had that
he had
because
to learn that haswell had accomplices it
would not dismay him that him should
someday service that oswald had
accomplices because it would lend some
badly needed rhyme and reason to an act
of
that up to now
had neither
be that as it may i am still not
satisfied that there isn't a lot more to
the leo harvey oswald story
especially now this will stun you since
one of the respected republicans who
ever held office
republicans
really solid guy
said to me in front of witnesses
that he once asked richard nixon
what do you know about the kennedy
assassination
and nixon said
you don't want to know
i tell you
i took got cold chills that morning
but one of the things that sticks with
me most about that november america if
well i'm not going to go any further
that's that's
that i will not tell you who because
he's still alive and i'm not sure it was
at a privileged breakfast
but what he said
i asked nixon and nixon said you don't
want to know
it reinforced what i've always believed
i've always believed that lyndon johnson
knew a lot more
that alan dulles knew a lot more
and that richard nixon knew a lot more
and they thought that now he all you've
heard all the theories
we had
60 minutes had in new york with us
a woman who claimed to have been lee
harvey oswald's mistress
whether she was or she wasn't but she
knew an awful lot about him
and she had pictures of herself
lots of years ago
she was a dead ringer marina oswald she
looked like her twin sister
of all the things she told us
about
oswald
the one thing
that sticks in my mind
jack ruby was not a stranger to lee
harvey oswald
jack ruby was not a guy
who went crazy when he found out his
president been killed and walked into
the police station here and decided to
kill him
lee harvey oswald's uncle
was an associate of jack rubies in some
shady business somewhere they were both
gangsters
and according to her what she said she
learned from oswald
jack
lee harvey oswald's uncle
asked jack ruby
be sure and take care of my nephew
lee
in case anything ever happens to me
i believe that jack ruby
was hired
to go there to make sure that oswald
never talked
she also
this was par that part of the story i
have no doubt about
she also told us an awful lot about
oswald
and a
cia group of
in the everglades
of renegades
this part i've heard
from
uh howard hunt
who was part of a watergate crowd
and i heard howard hunt on this subject
they
hated the kennedys
because eisenhower had promised air
cover
for the bear pigs invasion
and kennedy i think it was bobby who
convinced jack not to do it
denied them air cover for that invasion
and they claim
that their comrades who died on the
beaches
during the bear pigs invasion
were left
were
were
left to die
because of the kennedys
and vowed to get even
i i don't know how what the connections
were
whether the connection was from a
cia
group of renegades
through
[Music]
the mafia
to
leo harvey oswald's uncle
to jack ruby to somebody here
but i i don't i don't i believe if
oswald did it
out of a window in this building
that kid was not smart enough to have
figured all this out all by himself
whether there were shots fired from the
grassy knoll
we're never going to know that
maybe someday we will
somebody told me just this morning
that jackie
papers
have
some revelations
about
the assassination
i don't know if that's true or not
but i am so convinced
that one guy did not plan
and that the theories
that
are richard nixon you don't want to know
uh
the rest of whatever the fact that
i have tried to talk to pierre salinger
dave powers
kenny o'donnell
steve smith
bobby i did talk to bobby and got a
no
ted sorensen
there is
a veil of silence
among anybody in the kennedy clan
and knowing bobby kennedy's temperament
as an attorney general
bobby kennedy would have turned the
world upside down
if somebody had killed one of his kids
if somebody had killed ethel
i mean that was his nature he would have
never rested till he found the guy
the fact that he said
what difference it makes it's not going
to bring him back
i never believed
that teddy believe that
why do you think i mean it's our
perception
or my perception i should say
that the media has kind of historically
for the 40 intervening years
just kind of nursed along the warren
commission there's been there's an
occasional kind of front line or these
kind of why is the media not gone after
the store anymore they have or and they
guess because i did i brought that woman
to new york
i i i we had gloria boyce of of uh
of uh
uh no she also works for u.s news
you know we gloria and i were convinced
that we were about to break the biggest
story of our times and yet
a guy
who's a lawyer for that senator i quoted
who was a member of the warren report
was a a council of the army boy was all
for us he kept saying you're onto
something let's go ahead let's do this
the door was slammed in our face all of
a sudden
we came to the conclusion actually brian
duffy was the washing bureau chief of
u.s news who was doing it with us
and brian called one day and said
we don't have
we only have her story
i i
why have they all let it go
i i would think there isn't a news guy
in the world who wouldn't like to break
that story
and somehow
how
that story
is unbreakable
is beyond me
but i i'm i'm do you know that when earl
warren he this you could find this quote
and you probably haven't
walked out
on the steps
after the last warren report
said
we may not know the truth in our
lifetime
and i said
wait a minute what does he mean by that
[Music]
there were so many things going i don't
know whether dallas police department
was in on this thing
but
you've got
lee harvey oswald in your jail
there hasn't been a more important
prisoner since john will's booth
that they didn't cordon off at least a
square mile
around that
they would cordon off the jail after
they got
terry mcnichols and the guys in oklahoma
city
that they
handle him so cavalierly
that a jack ruby walks into that garage
all the cameramen are in there how do
you know who those cameramen are you
don't know who those people are they are
treating him like he's some pickpocket
they picked up on the street
now
ruby kills oswald
the dallas police grab ruby
the next thing i know i see ruby in the
hallway
on television of
the police headquarters being
interviewed by guys and i'm saying wait
a minute you just lost the most
important prisoner in the history of the
united states next to baby john wilkes
booth now you've got the third most
debate because this is the guy who could
be your link to what happened
and you're treating him like you picked
up some pickpocket on the street
the police work in this town was
atrocious
now here's what i also can't figure i
can't figure out
if nobody in washington is involved in
this
why a j edgar hoover
isn't on the phone
saying to the police chief here i forget
his name jessie curry jesse curry saying
jesse for christ's sake with your cordon
off the police station stop leaving
these guys out there and let the press
come and talk to them are you nuts what
kind of police work is that
nobody did
there
after
think about this after ruby killed
oswald in the garage of the police
station
there are reporters in the police
station talking to jack ruby
and i'm sitting home saying i don't
believe what i'm looking at
you know cheaper story bob schieffer no
we're telling this he worked for the
former star telegram yep and got the
phone call and from the lady asking for
a ride to dallas
and it was marguerite oswald
and bob put margarita in the car leads
my i never knew that drove her over here
and then spent the better part of a day
and a half at her side because nobody
asked the police never asked who he was
and they assumed she was he was her
lawyer or with her i never knew that bob
told me i was coming here on the 21st
actually to talk about that and i really
knew ryan is writing his book but but
there was such access the media i mean
ruby of course we have all the film
footage the night the friday night the
night of the assassination
of ruby standing in the hallway talking
the police i mean just walking around
with his paper in his arm and just
hanging out he was everybody knew him he
was a very familiar character but he the
access was just amazing because he was
and he was in the midnight press
conference correcting the questions were
being asked of oswald so he was around
the whole weekend everybody never knew
about that
but it it it's something i mean our goal
is the museum and i want to talk about
this but our goal museum is
just to factually tell the story and so
there's a we don't know who killed john
kennedy it's up there on the you know
our exhibit says who done it we don't
know we allow some of the major
conspiracy theories but we we don't take
the position we're always trying to you
know try to
walk a middle ground here but it has
been you know on occasion we get calls
and say don't why don't you just tell
the truth that i as well did it why
don't you just let go of this this this
conceit that somehow there's mystery to
it and then there's our position there
is mystery to of course it is
i don't know a news guy in the world
who wouldn't
give anything
to be able to break this story
how this remained
all these years
you know
you think about
this watergate connection that's the
same crowd
there's a it's
do i know it
no i don't know it for sure
but am i about
99 sure but yes i'll show you a map
upstairs that one of one of the chilling
moments for me was when i first started
working here and researching things
if you draw a
oswald was put out at the rooming house
in oakland for you yeah right and he
started walking which was south right
down any intersection patton uh patent
and tenth where he shot right
right
if you keep drawing that straight line
to that point he turns and goes west to
the texas theater you go a straight line
you you hit jack ruby's apartment
he goes about 10 blocks halfway to
ruby's apartment if you go straight now
if you turn you and you start in the
other way you obviously look like a
theater so it's just there again it's
one of those moments you go
where was he going
my feeling that the two of them knew
each other
i i i have no doubt
i'm sorry go ahead go ahead and finish
your thought um
well
do i know any more than that no i wish i
knew more than that
would i love to have been the guy who
broke that story that i think we had it
the guy who was working with us
was the attorney
for the republican senator
who told said nixon said you don't want
to know
nixon knew a lot
i think lyndon johnson knew a lot
i think
well you know
there were people who think ladybird did
it
lyndon
put alan dulles
on the warren
commission
i think
to kind of calm the country down i think
they thought
if the truth ever comes out here
[Music]
we are right for a revolution
and i don't think they could take that
chance
and i wonder
well somebody would have turned up
somebody like michael bachelos would
have turned it up if there isn't
anything in the lyndon johnson
library
that sheds light on what he might have
known there's a quote upstairs where uh
johnson 1971 was interviewed by a
monthly magazine
and you know he was he was that point
the hair was down on his collar and over
his ears yeah it was right and and his
dissent as it were
he said i can believe oswald pulled the
trigger but i don't believe he acted
alone
so johnson says this in 71 and this kind
of you know not rumination but this is
what i think i mean that clearly
johnson's point of view was the warrant
commission report was important the very
reason you specified get it out there
say it was all you know one guy and then
later on we can sort that later right
right but now is there anything in
connolly's papers
uh nothing substantial in terms of the
uh
connolly and nelly i've toured yeah yeah
it's not it's knowing so i was still
live but it's outside of austin and uh
and when i took her through ten years
ago i had a bruise on my arm for three
days where she held my arm because of
the intensity of it and she said you
know we always believed in something
else we know what it was
but you know that nellie thought it was
three shots of four shots and there was
lots of confusion but they were there
sure now the yeah nelly i think at the
time i think connolly at the time
said there was more than one shot before
the house select committee they both
said they think they thought there was a
fourth shot
now somebody
i'm trying to remember who
ran
a mock trial
in which evidence was
given
that seemed
to stand up
that there were shots fired from the
grassy knoll and i'm trying to remember
well the house select committee's
finding was the probability of 95
percent there was a there was a shot in
the grass
that was the finding that later there
was challenge the acoustic uh
reception
the shots from the grassy knoll
they claim there
somebody explained this to me once
they say if there were shots from the
grassy knoll
there would have been bullet not in the
back of the head but in the front of the
head
and then somebody raised it yeah suppose
the car had already gone past the grassy
knoll and the shot went into the back of
the head it's all contradictory yeah
that's it right out there right yes
where's marilyn and she's up to the
museum she's touring me she said leave
me alone i said okay okay uh
the
i i've talked at this
place with hugh seidi
big staley from like the great i took
salinger another walk i took one hand
for a walk
uh cronkite showed up one morning in
february four or five years ago freezing
cold and wanted to at the museum
we were we weren't open so i feel like i
remember walter and i were here right
afterwards because we did a lot of
filming up in the window walter stood in
front of the we had the video of course
where he tells the country the nation
the president has died and i said he
cried yeah he did absolutely i was i was
in the control room i mean i was an
emotion i mean what what was it like
because i i as i talked to all these
guys and then you know and not that
you're all liberal democrats that's not
my point but i think clearly there was a
kind of almost
adrenaline rush
and then because when someone were
conservative democrats
but when they come back to visit they
let down i mean one of them cried in the
parking lot but that's a very personal
loss but at the same time just the oh my
god you know this but i'll what if i
read this correctly
s sorensen salinger
kenny o'donnell dave powers
see mayna became here they couldn't take
ted said it is too painful to talk about
ted and i sat in a hotel room one
morning in chicago we in fact we went to
chicago for the anniversary of the
first
kennedy nixon debate which i produced
and directed
and um
i'll talk about that night too that
night was a lot more significant
in america than anybody
maybe but i realized
big
the worst night in american politics
that's the night if you want to change
this up sure
that's the night
that politicians looked at us and said
that's the only way to campaign
and we looked at them and said
that's a bottomless pit of advertising
dollars
since that night
no one can hold office in the greatest
democracy on earth without the money to
buy television time
and no one can get the money to buy
television time unless they're in bed
with a lobbyist
lobbyists have taken over america there
are more lobbyists on capitol hill by
far than there are legislators there are
more lobbyists in austin than there are
legislators
you know why because nobody there
can get reelected
without money to buy television time
and then you get nuts like mitch
mcconnell who say
it is against the first amendment to
deny anyone the right to buy as much
television time as he can afford
you know the founding fathers would turn
over their graves if they heard that by
television time what has that got to do
with the first amendment so i've said
okay you can't outlaw
it because the first amendment the first
amendment has never kept you from
outlawing obscenities
declare them obscene
[Music]
but
that night
that night gave birth to the dirtiest
word in american politics you know what
it is
fundraiser that's all every time the
president leaves the oval office he's
going to a fundraiser i don't remember
jack kennedy going to fight
before that that's touched it off
when they were planning the trip to that
to texas uh connolly was the point
person in the state and connolly
they were trying to plan these events
and conley said you can do one
fundraiser but that's all you can't
either it's unseemly for the president
to come to the state fund raise money so
that's why that night in austin was
going to be the one fundraiser i've done
in houston and san antonio in fort worth
and dallas but it was going to be
unseemly for the president to raise
money
and today i'll give you an example
you any idea what it caused franklin
roosevelt get elected president united
states
2.2 million dollars in today's money
it's like 26 million
hillary clinton and rick lazio spent
twice that
on television commercials to win one
senate seat it is so out of hand
there is no more democracy when you have
to buy television time and the guy who
raised the most money probably gets
elected and it all weaned off that night
now i don't think
jack kennedy or i or anybody else
realized what was going to happen but
that is the legacy
of the nixon kennedy debate
was it i mean clearly
there was a there was an attempt not to
appear biased the the debate was
happening and yeah but what was the
intrigue in terms of of of organizing
that evening i know that nixon comes in
and he's moving things around like his
people are trying to move at desk in
front of howard case i mean what was
your sense of the politics of this read
the book no no there's the picture yeah
that's that to me is my favorite picture
ever fantastic picture
um
but
did you guys what was your sense i mean
obviously i say obviously the people
watching tv believe kennedy one people
already believe nixon one what did you
believe what i believe
i saw
i i'd had a meeting with kennedy at
midway airport
ted kennedy
ted saw uh bobby kenneth
jack jack kenneth he ted sorensen and i
had a meeting at midway
two weeks before
the debate
he was so curious where do i stand what
how long can i answer
can we interrupt each other i mean every
question in the book
i never met
with nixon before he walked in there
that night
kennedy went home and rested and boned
up on everything the afternoon of the
debate
nixon spoke to it was either the
plumbers of the carpenter's union
he thought it was just another campaign
appearance he never realized
how much was riding on it which kennedy
understood
i was standing there talking to nixon
when kennedy sort of walked in
it was like it was like the referee
telling like sitting in the ring with
the two guys
i looked up
there's this guy he looks like a matinee
idol
he's well tanned because he'd been
campaigning california in an open
convertible
well tailored
harvard
looks like
it's a movie star has walked into that
studio and not a presidential candidate
nobody ever saw
a presidential candidate before who
looked like
some guy who offered college campus who
was the best-looking guy in that college
and i thought my god you know this is
this is not going to be a fair fight
so i said
do you want makeup
and kenny snow he didn't mean any
there's a ps to that too
and i
said to ken
dixon but you like some makeup
and he heard kennedy say no
somebody said no
he needed it he went in the back room
and a guy made him up with something
called a shape stick
looked like the wrath of god
came out put him on camera
he looked terrible
i went out and got frank stanton was
then president cbs i said frank you
better come in here i think there's
trouble brewing here
he looked at him he said
called in ted rogers who was
nixon's
television guy and said you're satisfied
with the way he looks he said yeah we
think it looks great
stan said to me and it's none of our
business what are we going to do about
it i said fine
they claim that that
in fact they're probably right
that that
debate turned on
who looked the best
now
was i happy
that kennedy got to be president because
of it yes
is there something wrong like i get to
be president because he looks better yes
that's how you ought to pick miss
america that's not how you're going to
pick your president
but we got the right guy for the wrong
reason
[Music]
nixon never recovered
from that night
there were other debates he did better
but that first one
left that
an impression on america it was they
stamped
that's the guy and no matter what this
other guy says no matter what they do
from now on
what they said that night
may i nobody can remember
they talked to
historians i always say
that thing was all about
makeup
and historians who are holier than thou
say to me
well what about what they said about
kimoy and matsu and i say okay
where are kimon matsu and who said what
nobody they don't know
they know the words
mean
kimoy and matsu
but it wasn't about it was about a guy
one guy
who looked like nobody had ever seen a
presidential candidate before another
guy who looked like the run-of-the-mill
presidential candidate
now
i'm telling this story to ted sorensen
actually we were on the history channel
talking and we're going outside to get
in the cab
and ted says to me
i'm going to tell you something you
never knew we made up
kennedy in the back room
i said well you did a better job than
ted rogers did
it's strange
that
one broadcast not the whole series the
whole series wasn't what did it was that
one broadcast that left an indelible
stamp on america
of a guy
who at that point nobody knew and nobody
could have cared about who is this guy
from
you know this rich kid
whose father was kind of a crumb bun
his father was
you know that tina sinatra
told me
we put it on the air
that her
father frank sinatra got a call from joe
kennedy
saying we need help
in
west virginia in the west virginia
primary against hubert humphrey what can
you do for us
and kennedy called sanjin comma
and they got the unions
to back frank sinatra and when it was
over
when bobby started go after the mob
ginkarma court this is all from tina
sinatra and her father
ginkama called her father
and said
you son of a [ __ ] we helped this guy
what is bobby his brother doing to us
and frank said
you don't don't be mad at them be mad at
me i did it
what do you want
he played
12 or 13 dates free at sanji kama's
villa nietzsche
uh nightclub in chicago to pay back
ginkama for his help with jack kennedy
brought the whole rat pack
dean martin sammy davis joey bishop they
all came and played there for nothing
that was the payback for what they did
for jack kennedy
when sinatra tried to get a license
for a gambling casino cal neville lodge
outside of vegas it might have been
outside of tahoe i'm not exactly sure
he was asked about it and he said it
never happened
and tina said to me
he lied he lied because it did happen
now
think about this we go through this
whole monica lewinsky thing
jack kennedy had sanji and kama's
girlfriend judith extra in the white
house
i was married
to a woman before i was married to
maryland
who
was
one of the women he used to sneak out of
the white house to go and see in
washington i mean he got away we might
well today you couldn't do that but he
got away with an awful lot
and um
it was a charming rogue i mean he was
the charm
was
nobody was ever that charming and and he
got away with everything but he was
great russian though i mean it was oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah no but he knew he
picked and chose what he was doing i
mean
clinton's problem is not sexual it's
cerebral i mean there isn't a guy in the
world who isn't smart enough to know
that a young kid making it with the
president united states going to brag
about it i mean why is she doing if she
can't brag about it so somebody's going
to find out about it
jack kennedy was discreet he was a rogue
he was
he was everybody's hero and um
he got killed
one more question oh that's a good time
yeah look around a little bit while
you're here uh if you could and this is
this i know we're kind of like a broken
record but one thing we're trying to
understand better is that is what went
on in this community it's not a local
store necessarily but there's a local
component to it
after the assassination how did the
country the media view dallas texas
as with it with a second rate police
department
that
screwed up badly
that
dallas was kind of
you know boo dallas i mean i think they
started rooting against
the dallas teams
uh
dallas was
dallas had stamped on it
site of assassination
it's no longer that i mean i don't think
there's many people around here even
remember all that but i do remember that
that
and i've got to wonder
was jessie curry
inep
or was jesse curry
knew a lot more
than
did jay and hoover know a lot more
the j edgar hoover wasn't on the phone
to jesse curry saying hey paul are you
out of your mind what are you doing
there this guy's running in and out of
this place and there's no you didn't
cordon off the roadblocks around the
place
which i wonder
did was hoover
did hoover know a lot more
did jesse curry know a lot more or was
it just
plain
inept i don't know
oh we're not we living in i'm so sorry i
don't know what the journey is it's okay
i'm gonna do that you know it's all
right i um you didn't have a mic no
he picks up on mine
but did you get more or less what you
wanted absolutely sure at the end of
these we always just leave it open is
there anything we left out any stories
of any interest relating to kennedy or
the assassination that you think we
should have on the record here
um
no i i was just one uh amusing story
um
i was doing a we were doing a three
network conversation with kennedy
and uh
i know
not well but we brought through it
through an ex-wife
and uh
i'm down there and we're setting up in
his
in the oval office in the morning he's
going to church
he arrives about 11 o'clock
and walks in
and i said
we're being very careful we're covering
all the furniture nobody's going to bang
into anything
and we put a drop cloth down to protect
the floor
he said forget the floor and he went
over and he pulled
the
drop cloth back he said you see that and
the whole floor was eaten up it looked
like like animals come in there and
eaten up the floor and i said what is
that
he said
that's the son of a bitch's golf cleats
i knew right away it was dwight
eisenhower and he said you know what
that son of a [ __ ] did he used to wear
his golf cleats into the oval office and
he'd get up and he'd go outside this
putting queen and he chewed up the floor
no that was that was
jack kennedy's best
you can order a videotaped copy of any
of tonight's